good morning if everyone could please
rise and join me for the Pledge of
Allegiance
the States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
thank you
um we'll be opening House Bill 113 first
I just wanted to give a shout out to all
the members who stuck with us last night
and especially to our clerk who did this
for the first time on a record day
yesterday with a record number of
testimony and did not miss a beat I
appreciate it thank you with that I open
house bill 113 and recognize who's gonna
good morning Mr chairman for the record
I am representative Jennifer Rhodes I
represent Cheshire County District 17
which is Winchester Richmond Swansea
Troy and Fitzwilliam our Prime sponsor
is not here this morning so I am just
introducing House Bill 113 relative to
the physical fitness performance
requirements for law enforcement
officers
and I am assuming that there are
probably some great people behind me
that can
testify to the reasons for this and what
Cheryl
there good morning
so I'm Charles rataj I'm the chief of
the Hinsdale police department and uh
the reason I'm here this morning is
because of a crisis in law enforcement
it should come to no surprise to any of
you that uh struggle on uh day to day
and lately year-to-year basis with just
keeping law enforcement officers on the
road and responding to calls for service
and keeping our community safe
I'm no stranger to physical fitness
tests I began my public service career
in 1992 in the National Guard I've been
taking physical fitness tests off and on
for years and uh honestly the uh there's
a great amount of importance in
maintaining physical fitness the issue
that we've come across is that uh
several fold is that the uh this
particular physical fitness test
requires a test once every three years
should the officer fail it becomes once
every five years because they get a
two-year waiver
as opposed to the military or other
places which hold a test every single
year there's really no Great Value in
taking a test once every five years and
expecting that to maintain a level level
of physical fitness looking at what
other states do no one else has the same
requirement they don't do this in
Vermont they don't do this in Maine
Massachusetts Rhode Island or
Connecticut only New Hampshire and the
end result of that is that it hurts both
recruiting and retention it hurts
retention because we have outstanding
fine police officers and this is usually
the ones that are more senior with the
most experience that just can't do their
sit-ups fast enough or they just can't
run the mile and a half fast enough
it also hurts recruiting we have another
crisis in law enforcement and it's
amongst police administrators right now
these senior law enforcement officials
the sergeants the lieutenants the Chiefs
we're the ones who are training the vast
huge number of individuals who we're
bringing in and the problem is that us
older and more seasoned officers some of
us are struggling with a PT test
and I worry a little bit about who's
going to train all these new people who
were trying to recruit to fill out all
of our ranks if we're chasing them out
because they just can't run fast enough
or there are a couple push-ups short
um
and it doesn't seem to be affecting any
of the other states and in fact it hurts
us we can't reach out to a retired
officer in Connecticut with 20 years and
say hey why don't you come to New
Hampshire and be a chief of police
because they look at the PT requirement
and say well why do that when I can go
to Vermont or I can go to Maine and
start a second career and a second
pension it frankly it hurts us it's a
detriment
um
and I guess uh just overall what it
really comes down to is that
on a daily basis we struggle and it's
not just Hinsdale it's not just Cheshire
county it's Statewide we're struggling
to just answer basic calls for service
and we're struggling to give the
communities the level of safety and
performance that they need and uh
I would rather have a large strong cop
with me on a midnight shift I just
covered one last night I've been working
a lot of 12 to 12 and 10 to 10 even as a
chief because we don't have enough
people to work and I would rather have a
large strong officer who just can't do
20 sit-ups with me as opposed to no
officer at all or I would rather have a
detective Lieutenant who's outstanding
and investigating sex offenses and who
is in her mid to late 40s and just can't
run a mile and a half without hurting
her hip
you know and I look at that and I say
you know we this is a PT test is a
luxury
and it's it's something that I feel that
has value but I feel that it's something
that's detrimental to uh our overall
thank you
um if you could a few questions
how would this affect the disability
retirement system I'm surprised they
actually didn't come today because if an
officer is become so unfit they're more
liable to an injury and on the job
disability versus one who isn't you have
any opinion on that or thoughts on that
my thoughts and opinion on that it
should be up to the individual
Department it should be up to the
individual agency
I think that individual agencies could
have uh standards that require yearly
medical screenings or if individual
agencies or or at a point where they
could run and manage their own physical
fitness tests I think that's a great
idea
you know I remember a time where we
could have 20 applicants for one job and
the hiring board would be arguing about
hiring the top three
now we're lucky if we get three
unfortunately
um my second question is is there a
sliding scale as an officer ages where
the the like in the military when you're
17 it's 50 push-ups in two minutes and
57 what about as it ages does it get
less there is there's a sliding scale
um but even with a sliding scale I mean
I don't think that it takes into account
um injuries
or it doesn't take into account the
overall Fitness level I recently had a
71 school year old school resource
officer who retired he was an avid hiker
and you could put a 30 pound backpack on
them and he could hike all day long
however he struggled with the impact
that the concrete had on his 71 year old
joints
thank you representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question would you be able to
explain to the committee what the
difference is on recruiting or hiring
officers between New Hampshire and
Massachusetts because my understanding
is there it's not done the same way as
far as training and recruiting
no training and recruiting are two
separate things if they're recruited by
the agency that's just the beginning of
the hiring process they still need to go
to uh to the police academy where they
have to undergo a physical fitness test
there's medical
requirements and um a legal package that
they would have to either test out of or
just just for clarity do you know how
Massachusetts does it I am unaware of
how Massachusetts does our system okay
just for the committee it's
Massachusetts civil service system where
you have to take an exam and they have
to choose from the exam
um other questions from the committee
representative
so are you looking to do away with it
all or replace it with something else
just kind of I'm looking to do away with
the entire thing and place a
responsibility back on the individual
to to what extent uh
is an officer who isn't in good shape
um to what extent do they present a
potential issue uh for other for other
officers and members of the public in
I think that that's uh mixed I think
that there are some agencies where um
they maintain strict standards and
that's no issue at all I think that
there are some agencies out there that
have allowed some individuals who uh are
overweight or obese who they probably
should hold accountable and I think that
agencies can do that through their own
policies and their own procedures
thank you
one more question does the the city or
town or does anyone provide these
officers paid time to maintain their
Fitness to work out to
some agencies the agencies do different
things have seen many of them provide
incentive bonuses for employees who
maintain a level of physical fitness if
you pass the test they'll toss you 500
or 300 or whatever dollars the problem
with that is that uh in most of our
agencies we're short staffed so they're
working end over end 12-hour shifts
which leaves them virtually no time for
physical fitness and it becomes a
repeating Loop where you have no help
they work harder they don't have time to
work out which then makes them work
harder PT test time
which as opposed to people that are
incarcerated who have all day to work
out and gonna come out in great shape
um okay thank you is there any further
questions
seeing none thank you for your testimony
good morning chairman Roy members of the
committee thank you for letting me speak
with you here today
my name is Brian Lord and I am the
civilian manager of the Antrim Police
Department
and I submit this testimony in support
of hb133
on behalf of myself
I have been in law enforcement for 15
years
I began my career with the Antrim Police
Department in 2008. have risen up
through the ranks worked hard and
reached the rank of Chief of Police
in that time in 2019 I
while training for the PT test I injured
my knee which required surgery to repair
because I wasn't going to meet the
deadline the three-year deadline I opted
for a medical waiver from the academy
which was accepted this allowed me to
keep my certification while I recovered
from surgery
and then began training again for the PD
test
once I began training again after the
knee surgery and Recovery I developed
another medical condition
basically after many many visits to the
doctor and many many tests
I was diagnosed with a defective aortic
heart valve which needed to be repaired
having to do that at that time I was
again not to meet the deadline from my
medical waiver extension my
certification was suspended
and there were no other options for me
at that time
[Music]
I was able to work with the town they
agreed to keep me on as the chief in a
different title civilian manager
administrator and since that time I have
been running the police department
day-to-day managing the police
department everything that a certified
uniform police chief would do the only
difference is I can't wear the uniform
and I can't perform any law enforcement
the reason I'm not certified is because
in my opinion it's an unfair standard
doesn't take into account
medical conditions that are not the
fault of the officer
I have been training
extensively since 2019 since recovering
from my surgeries I've hired a personal
coach and a professional running coach
to help me with my training
I can do everything I'm in great health
I have a strict diet I exercise nearly
every single day but I can't finish the
the current PT requirement is proven to
be a hardship for me
and many of the law enforcements I am in
danger of losing my job because I can't
pass this one portion of this test
this is hurting law enforcement in New
Hampshire especially at a time
when there are Mass retirements from law
enforcement along with an unprecedented
lack of applicants to fill the multitude
of vacancies
not only New Hampshire but across this
great nation
losing experienced in highly qualified
officers is not in the best interest of
New Hampshire law enforcement
in closing I asked that you find this
bill ought to pass thank you for your
consideration
with your condition do you qualify for
medical retirement
I'm not sure let's look into that okay
thank you
representative Newman
with the repeal of these two law two
laws that cover physical fitness is that
in and alone sufficient to make it so
that it wouldn't be a problem anymore or
are there other laws that might come in
yes repealing this law for the fiscal
requirement the ongoing Fitness
requirement would certainly help me I
would be able to keep my job if it were
to be repealed and I'm going to start
the process but I would think that I
could get my certification back and
continue on with my career
thank you thank you
representative jambrian
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh are you aware of any
criminal of of any
law enforcement jobs that do not have
this requirement that they go and be
certified by the police academy I
specifically know of two elected
positions in the state of New Hampshire
that don't require uh certification but
you can also be a law enforcement
officer
yeah I believe the sheriff can be
elected and I'm not sure the other one
you're speaking of but of course the
only one I know of
a constable Constable yeah
any further questions
warning Mr chair it's okay if we uh
testify together
thank you I'll introduce myself my name
is Joseph hobecki chief of police in
Hollis and also the immediate past
president of the New Hampshire
Association the chiefs of police
good morning Glendale I'm the police
chief in Northwood also past president
we're present uh here before you today
Mr chair and members of the committee to
testify on House Bill 113.
um the association
will not take a position however we just
want to provide you with some
information that might help
um you make a better informed decision
on this legislation
at a December meeting of the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police we discussed at length this
legislation
with the intent of trying to determine
the association's stance and position
I can tell you the discussions were very
lengthy they were spirited in a good way
and the points of view range from
supporting the legislation to not
supporting the elimination of these
standards to modifying the current
physical fitness testing battery so it's
more job specific to the role of a
police officer and matches the functions
of of the position
uh give her given uh the differing
points of view in the overall lack of
consensus
um what we determined it is it would be
best
um to form a subcommittee uh to discuss
these issues in further detail uh with
the purpose of presenting information to
our executive board in general
membership
um some of the points of view relative
to the legislation
and so in fact on January 4th we did do
that we met as a subcommittee which
included myself Chief trelay director
Skipper from pstc who's present today
Chief aldenberg from Manchester Chief
Levick from Merrimack Chief profansky
from Bedford and then of course Captain
Hawkins from pstc
some of the key points and take
takeaways of our meeting of our work
um
ours Falls I'll just read a few that
there's some concern the current fitness
test requirements could be challenged
could be challenged under the federal
civil rights act
it is important to note that the
legislation Deals Only with incumbent
testing
meaning those folks who are
in the profession are already certified
developing and implementing New
Hampshire specific testing battery would
take specific time and would be
expensive
but there is potential to use other
physical ability testing batteries from
other states like Massachusetts for
example that would be an option but we
would need to consider how these tests
would be administered
um we're very concerned there is some
concern amongst the membership about
medical requirements and medical
assessments
so if the standard does in fact go away
what will the medical requirements be to
ensure that we have uh officers who
don't have existing conditions that
would limit their ability to perform the
job which certainly ties into the whole
perspective of risk management and and
liability as well
staffing issues certainly which you
heard from the chief earlier are always
of concern as well as recruitment and
retention
we also think it's important to to
mention officer Wellness
and we mentioned Wellness because we
know that physical fitness is a key
component of that
so in an effort to kind of filter and
sift through some of these
considerations
what we did was we we created a survey
there's five questions survey
and I'll let Chief to relay speak to the
results of the survey for you
so seeing as I get the hard part of
remembering all the numbers I'm going to
read off the paper so I apologize
in collaboration with Captain Hawkins at
psdc the survey was created within the
Benchmark analytics system which every
Chief in the state has access to the
survey was then distributed through
Benchmark and by way of Association
emails to the C the Chiefs with a
completion deadline of January 24th
once every completion period ended
Captain Hawkins compiled the results
which are included in the attached
document
we received a res we received replies
from 108 Chiefs provided answers to the
questions listed in this memo which
constitutes in 49 response rate from all
the Chiefs in regards to the questions
as to whether the CEOs or the Chiefs
support the elimination of the ongoing
PT test requirements 62 percent of the
chiefs polled were in agreement with the
course of action to eliminate the PT
standard
29 of those polls of those polled answer
they did not support the elimination of
the of the PT standard while nine
percent were unsure
the results also indicated
that should this standard remain in
place an overwhelming percentage of
those polled would support the
modification of current Fitness
standards reflected in a test a battery
of tests that were more closely aligned
to job function of a police officer
about 50 percent of those polled have
had the certification of an officer
working their agency placed on probation
status
due to the inability to meet this
current standards around 20 percent of
chiefs polled indicated that officers
within their agency have had their
certification suspended due to failure
to meet the current PT standard
finally of the Chiefs polled roughly 52
percent indicated they would develop and
Implement their own Fitness and Agility
testing requirement as well as medical
evaluation
although roughly 62 percent of the
Chiefs who completed the survey support
the elimination of this standard there
was still a relatively high percentage
of chiefs who do not support this cause
of action
uh
with the 50 response rate which means
that less than 25 percent of the
association body has indicated that they
desired to eliminate the physical
is that complete your testimony
that completes we'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you Mr chair could
you explain to the committee how it
works if an officer is injured on duty
um with regard to disability retirement
Glenn do you want to take that or do you
want me to handle that one
of your officers breaks their knee and
they can't work anymore what what are
they entitled to what are they able to
receive and who pays for it so
there would become our covered under
workers compensation and then uh if they
would have to work with the New
Hampshire retirement system to qualify
for a medical retirement that's kind of
a snapshot I
worked with an officer who had a similar
circumstance about five or six years ago
and do you recall what the percentages
what they of their pay they get on a on
a retired disability retirement yeah
it's 66 and two-thirds I believe of
their average depending on current
construct of where they fall in the
retirement program okay and and that
disability retirement is paid out of the
state retirement system so all of the
municipalities contribute into that is
that correct that's correct New
Hampshire retirement system from police
group two okay thank you
um I think uh Chief Joe lay ahead yeah
just just one follow-up that I and I'm
not 100 on this but I think that officer
would have a fight on his hands that if
he's at Planet Fitness on his own time
working out gets hurt he may not be
entitled to anything even though he's
doing it for three years because he's on
his own time and he's not currently
working at that point so your point is
if he's training for the PT test and
gets hurt training he's you may not get
a get a dime he may be out of a job
thank you
um representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I think that you might have
said this in your testimony just wanted
to clarify did you say that this test is
only for incumbent officers so if you
were 22 graduating out of high school
wanted to become a police officer this
you don't have to do this physical
fitness test
you do have to do this fitness test
anyone hired after January 1st 2001 I
was actually the first police academy
class to go through it with my
fellow Academy made over here
um and uh so we were the first class to
required to meet this three-year if
you're a officer who's applying for a
job you have to meet the fitness
required requirements as as specified in
Police Academy
policies a 35th percentile of Cooper
standard ongoing PT test is the same
standard so every three years you would
have to take a fitness test
which is the incumbent testing at the
35th percentile in its age and gender
specific
if that makes sense
yeah just to clarify this is not
changing the standard to get into the
police academy no this is only for the
ongoing officer that's already hired and
every three years until they retire have
to keep taking this test
so three years goes by they test if they
fail they're given two more years to
pass it
and then they're on probate their
certification is held in probation if
they don't pass it after that then they
their certification goes on the
suspension so it does not change the
standards for an officer getting hired
brand new it's for the currently hired
officers and going forward once they're
hired to retest every three years
okay so for clarification because that
was my concern if a new officer being
hired the first time this would not
apply to them they would have to go
through the the same training pass the
test this is for once you're already
hired and you're already a working
officer correct thank you
I'm sorry I confused you
[Laughter]
representative Murray
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I was just going to
ask if you would be able to send the
survey data that you were reading to the
committee
thank you yes ma'am I'll do that today
I have one more question
um earlier I heard testimony that
there's a waiver system you get one one
waiver possibly
um with regard to uh if you're having
surgery or something like that
So within the three-year period
if you extend beyond that there's up to
two additional years of waivers so five
years to pass
a B2 test
I think I'm clear about the uh incumbent
officers in the academy what about
somebody who is already an officer
somewhere and then gets hired in the
state of New Hampshire maybe from out of
state what would they be subject to as
far as PT requirements at this point
they would be also required to take the
three year PT so if you and I think the
chief before us talked about it if a
chief or an officer retires in Maine
that does 20 years comes over New
Hampshire
gets their certification through the law
package of the academy they would have
so when and when so would they take one
immediately and then every three years
they would take one of me thank you
no further questions thank you very much
good morning Mr chair good morning
committee members for the record my name
is John skippa I'm the director of New
Hampshire police standards and training
and I have with me here today uh Captain
Adam Hawkins of our agency who oversees
the fitness program
we appear here today to really be a
source uh to answer any questions that
anyone might have
for some historical background this test
that is now mandatory to incumbent
officers started in 2001 it was brought
to fruition
in an effort to establish a level of
Fitness across New Hampshire law
enforcement to reduce workers comp
claims and to make sure that police
officers were able to meet the
challenges of their jobs
uh
we are the only state in the country
that requires ongoing Fitness testing
for all certified officers uh within our
state
uh I can tell you that uh we are the
Envy of of some other states I have the
opportunity to speak to a number of my
peers at different conferences and uh
I've been approached a number of times
by other states to ask how we do this
program and how they want to establish
the same thing but it is important to
recognize that we are the only state
that requires this
uh the police Academy's position is that
we really want to encourage and build
out a program that's going to help
officers stay well and be resilient
across their entire career part of that
resiliency is based on their level of
fitness and it's been demonstrated time
and time again how important it is for
that those officers to have a level of
Fitness that will help them get through
their careers very challenging career
uh with that said we also recognize that
this fitness test that we use now which
uh comes from the Cooper uh Institute of
anaerobic research uh
is a test that's been in play for uh 20
plus years
and uh Most states use the Cooper test
battery for police officer training
but there is a trend right now to
revisit the use of these uh tests this
test battery and uh
move to a more job-related job-specific
test uh to that end
one of the things that we're trying to
accomplish through this committee is to
look at some of the other available
tests that are out there that would be
more job specific with a single cut
regardless of age or gender as other
people have testified to the test we use
now is age and gender normed
and uh that means that there are
different standards for different age
groups and and different genders as they
really we um at this point we take no
position on this but we do think that
the notion of uh Wellness over the
course of the officer's career is
important
uh how we get there uh certainly uh
there's many many avenues that we can
take to get there uh the only other
thing that I would point out is that
this bill as proposed does not address
some sections of this bill that speaks
to the medical exam requirement
prior to the incumbent officer taking
this three-year fitness test there is a
number of sections that refers to an
officer having to be cleared medically
by their their medical provider
to demonstrate that they're either able
to or not able to take this particular
exam
we don't ask for medical information we
just asked the doctor to sign off saying
that they can either take it or not take
it and so if this bill were to move
forward I would certainly ask that uh
this committee look at kind of those
those other sections to make sure that
they're in line
I certainly stand ready to answer any
questions that anyone might have
thank you and hearing the testimony I I
understand that it's possible for
individual agencies to put their own
wordless bill to pass to put their own
incentive programs in place for officers
to maintain Fitness but my sticking
point still seems to be that the state
is on the hook for paying for retirement
for injured officers regardless of what
individual agencies do the whole state
has to pick up the tab could you speak
to that in any in any way
you know certainly that's an excellent
question certainly uh sir the uh a lot
of agencies
have their own in-house fitness program
many agencies have no fitness program at
all and uh
some agencies use incentives
uh so if the officer is able to pass
their three-year fitness test at a at a
higher level than what the state
requires they're given uh maybe a bonus
or extra time off uh a better parking
spot I mean they they're very creative
on how they uh you know recognize these
officers uh if an officer is injured
during the course of their Duty
then as testified to already you know
certainly the officer may be available
to a a disability retirement
um
and I don't know it's I don't know that
it's been tested yet or not but Chief
drolet did speak to the notion that if
an officer is off duty working towards
uh taking their PT tests they're at
Planet Fitness or they're out for a run
and they get injured is there some kind
of Nexus between uh this this injury
being a job related injury
uh I will say that under the law as it
presently exists the relationship to
maintain the officer's certification is
between the officer and police standards
and training right now so it does not
involve the agency per se it would be a
lot like uh and a long long time ago I I
worked as a paramedic and it was the
paramedics responsibility to maintain
their paramedic license uh and generally
speaking it was not the uh the agency
that you worked for although a lot of
agencies helped out it really wasn't the
responsibility of the agency to take on
a part of that relationship so it does
place the
um
kind of the responsibility on each
individual officer for them to maintain
their level of Fitness so that they can
maintain their license or certification
to work as a police officer
and so it sounds like to me that there's
a different responsibility chain with
different people responsible at the end
but at the end of the day it's still the
retirement system that would bear the
burden if an officer is injured on duty
so the officer reports to or deals with
your agency to pass their physical
fitness tests the department May
incentivize it may not
but at the end of the day if there's an
injury because an officer isn't fit and
and gets hurt it's the State Retirement
Board that has to pick that up so I
guess my question is has anyone studied
the difference since this law went into
effect in the number of people who put
in for disability retirement versus
before that
that is an excellent question sir and
that is a question that we keep coming
back to uh
when this law was put into place in 2001
there was no uh data collection
that helped
demonstrate over the period of time
as to whether this law prevented reduced
mitigated any type of worker comp claims
further
I cannot with any veracity speak to how
many officers we actually lose because
they can't pass a fitness test and and
the reason that we cannot speak to that
is because
uh
I can I can tell you that anecdotally
we lose about four a year that actually
come in front of the council and they
say hey I can't pass I've already gotten
my four waivers or three waivers at six
month increments to get me to five years
what we don't know is we have a number
of people who retire
and they retire uh having made the the
their age
uh and their time and service so it's a
normal retirement we recognize it as a
normal retirement but what we don't know
what we don't ask is are you retiring
because you've gotten to that place
where you can't pass your fitness test
any longer
and uh so it's it's a it's a moving
Target I cannot tell you how effective
this program
has been over the last 23 years I cannot
tell you how many times this program has
helped identify an underlying medical
issue that an officer had that they
didn't know they had until they got a
medical exam I cannot tell you
um what we cannot with any veracity
answer any of those questions and
ironically uh it's serendipitous or kind
of ironic that I'm here uh I was the
training specialist in charge of rolling
this program out in 2001 when it went
online and uh Chief obeki was was uh
part of that first group uh that that
kind of fell under these new
requirements so I I literally have been
here since the Inception of this program
and as we were preparing to speak today
uh and really the work we've done at a
subcommittee you know these questions
have already come up and we just can't
answer them because we've never
collected any data or there was no way
to collect that data
sounds like you may be passing the
subcommittee pot here
any further any questions representative
Newman
thank you
um
I'm wondering if uh a legislative change
would be required in order to make the
program more Wellness focused like
you've talked about it seems like
um
having an officer you know capable of
running 1.5 miles under a certain time
doesn't do you much good if um the next
time the officer does it their
cholesterol level is so high that they
might have a heart attack and that's
something that you would have no
knowledge of unless you were getting
some sort of a regular biometric test so
one of the things I'm I'm really curious
about is whether this is something we
could evolve into something that would
be more useful for everybody as opposed
uh thank you very much for uh for that
and in fact uh we feel exactly the same
way the police academy feels exactly the
same way uh
candidly under existing statute the New
Hampshire police standards and training
Council has the statutory authority to
set the fitness standards the hiring
standards and so really
if given the opportunity to continue
working with the stakeholders New
Hampshire Chiefs New Hampshire Police
Association uh you know those folks that
are going to be involved uh
I believe that we would have uh the
ability to work towards something that
is certainly more job related
would more greatly support to your point
officer wellness and build officer
resiliency to help them throughout their
career but I I do concur with that
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I was just going to ask I know you
didn't come in with an official
recommendation but based on that last
question would it be more amenable to
like retain the bill or study it further
or just ital it and let you guys kind of
come next year with a better idea of
what you would want to change the
testing standards to
thank you very much for the the
opportunity to weigh in on that
um I
I don't know I don't want to speak
there's there's a number of stakeholders
here in the room and I I don't want to
speak unilaterally to that uh I think
given the opportunity however this
committee sees fit to provide that
opportunity uh might be the best the
best approach and we may be able to do
this as representative Muse mentioned
without legislation but instead working
with uh with the stakeholders and the
council to to come to some kind of a you
know a better system
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
uh
if a police officer who's working with
the agency reaches that three-year time
period does the does the council or the
academy offer uh workout time with a
personal trainer and if they've failed
do they offer that as an option to come
to the academy for say a resident period
of one week to to work on remedial
physical training
uh thank you very much for that question
uh presently we do not uh we do not
offer any type of uh remedial or support
training for those folks who uh do not
pass the test I will say that uh the
captain who's sitting next to me has
advocated for trying to create that kind
of a program again in
with a notion of supporting Wellness so
that is uh that has been part of the
discussion but presently that does not
exist
um is there any ability uh how to hire
retired officers and police departments
and if so how how does that apply and
how do physical fitness apply to that
and I'm just thinking about Staffing
kind of things yes uh thank you for the
question
there are a small group of police
officers that were grandfathered
and are not required to take this test
and those those officers had 10 years of
service invested continuous service
prior to 2001.
uh that there's probably about 200 total
officers in out of the 4 000 that we
have that still fall under that
grandfathered section
uh
if uh a retired officer wants to come
back
and they fall under that very small
group they're not required to to
then be required to take the fitness
test
uh
anybody who was required under the law
that began in 2001 even if they retired
and then came back they would they would
come back under the requirements to take
so for the for the new group now that is
not grandfathered and they have the
opportunity to work without without with
the test
um how does that work do they get their
their retired pay in in some amount of
money how does that work oh thank you
for that question I'm sorry uh so uh if
a retired police officer who is drawing
retirement comes back as a part-time
police officer they're allowed to work
part-time up to I believe it's
1350 hours
per year the hiring Authority has to
report
the number of actual hours that that
retired
part-time police officer is working they
have to report that to us and there are
some uh certain uh penalties that can be
imposed by New Hampshire retirement if a
retiree Works Beyond those number of
hours in any given year
uh they can come back full time but when
they come back full time they stop
drawing their retirement and then they
are now an active uh member of the
retirement system and they continue to
pay in
thank you you're welcome
um final question is there any
restriction on new officers um with
things like tobacco use or anything like
that
we uh uh we are not like Massachusetts
uh Massachusetts Massachusetts and I was
a director of a police academy in
Massachusetts so I can speak
pretty accurately on differences between
the two states uh New Hampshire does not
require police officers to in essence
sign an affidavit saying that they do
not use tobacco products uh nor is there
a penalty here in New Hampshire for a
police officer that uses tobacco
products in Massachusetts uh that does
exist you as a public police employee
you cannot use tobacco in the state of
Massachusetts
and it's my understanding that was
established to protect the retirement
system is that correct that is
um thank you for your testimony this
morning
thank you what oh I'm sorry I didn't see
like the national certification
I I'm sorry madam uh the national
certification like Nashua I think
Hollows they have a national
certification yeah Prudential
accreditation right yes oh thank you
thank that affect this uh I I don't
believe so Madam because uh it is my
understanding that uh for those agencies
to reach national accreditation through
Kalia which is the organization that
that oversees that accreditation process
uh irregardless of uh what standards may
or may not exist in the state those
agencies have to meet the Kalia
standards in order to get that Kalia
stamp of approval so uh if there was any
kind of clear standard relative to
Fitness uh that agency would take it
upon themselves to to uh meet those
requirements and it would not impact if
if any action was taken here thank you
and that raises yet one more last
question for me I understand that there
is potentially some State Standards
being worked on at the moment
are any of those standards involve
physical fitness
I thank you for the question I did not
see any I I know that there's a uh Chief
obec yeah chief o Becky sits on that
committee as well and and there are no
Fitness standards within a state level
accreditation as we're building it thank
I I stand corrected there is a wellness
piece but not a not specific to a
fitness test
so that the the agency has to
demonstrate that they have a wellness
policy in place and a wellness program
and that may or may not include a
physical fitness aspect that is correct
sir okay thank you thank you for your
testimony thank you the chair recognizes
thank you Mr chairman
I
um and members of the committee I
apologize for my tardiness
um and
um it's tough when you get stuck behind
a truck on when on Route 9 coming from
Hinsdale to
Concord
if I'm being redundant and
testimony that was given before my
arrival
the reason why
I sponsored this piece of legislation
it was brought to my attention
the difficulty that
rural police departments have in
officers
under
this
as
you might have heard
there's police officers are the only
ones
who are required to take this physical
examination
we don't require it
so I think you can imagine the state we
would be in
if the rural small area
fire departments were to require
this type of physical exam
and I don't think
that um
based on the nature of their work
that it that a fireman
um
as a less strenuous
type of position
in
I think you can well imagine
what the state of our volunteer fire
departments would be if we had such a
requirement
and I don't think
if you
have questioned
some of the police Chiefs
about
the actual practice
of
these exams
fits into what their
Duties are
I don't think you would find many police
officers
who in their entire career
um
and I think
this is
a matter of local control
like planning and zoning
local departments from having their own
physical standards
and
in order to stay satisfied certified
um
and I think it should be not something
going back to the Chairman's
physical or unemployment
comp workman's compensation for this
this is not a
I think a duty
that the state should be involved in
then if by
putting it under local control
it would be up to the individual
departments
to set the standards
the physical standards
I've lived in Hinsdale for 52 years
count into double figures
the number of police officers
who would not
be able to pass this physical
requirement
and I think it's something that the
state shouldn't have gotten involved in
and should remain
and I'll be
welcome to answer any questions that
you might have that I'm capable
um
responding to
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um so I think you know from the people
who we heard from before one thing that
kind of stuck out to me was
um a a job-based you know what I mean so
it's it depends on kind of what your
role is what you need to do I mean I I
think the goal of it is to to be up to
the job right
um if there were things that were taken
into consideration
um you know what what you needed to do
but also take it into consideration
where you are a police officer but there
was a standard that was adaptable
um to different towns and things like
that would you be amenable to something
like that or is your goal to just get
rid of the the Statewide standard and
leave it on the individual
municipalities
yes thank you for the question I think
it should be up to the individual
Community it's too
what what they require and if the
community
uh the select board or city council
uh felt that some standard
um
would be acceptable I think it should be
thank you for your testimony this
morning
is there anyone else wishing to testify
on this bill who's not turned in a pink
card
seeing none I hereby close the public
hearing for hb113 I am appointing a
subcommittee for this
bill and the chair will be
representative tensar representative
Manion representative Stone
representative Muse representative
thank you
if not let me know I know you're very
busy
I would ask the chairman representative
tanzaro to please get with director
skippa
and also reach out to the Retirement
Board I think that they should have a
seat at that meeting
with that I opened a public hearing on
and recognize representative Schultz to
here actually have to get to committee I
have nothing else to do today so I
wanted to call them with me sure so I'm
here to formally introduce the bill and
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee
um I will keep this very short not
because I have a hearing but because I
believe that if you cannot make your
points in two minutes you shouldn't be
making them yes I'm Daniel
representative Daniel Popovich Miller
Wingham
so
I want to start
the
testimony by mentioning two cases
Catherine Johnston in Atlanta in 2006
Jose gorenia in toxin in 2011 what they
have in common is speaking to the reason
why I'm in support of this bill
which is that they ended up losing their
lives in you know no no quarant
scenarios and
as you know
I strongly believe in supporting you
know our Public Safety our police
officers
but allowing them putting them in a
situation where they they are asked to
use every two linear toolbox to fight
crime and then giving them tools like
the no knock warrant puts everybody at
risk and the reason for this is very
simple
we are creating a situation where the
homeowner has no way of knowing who is
breaking into their homes they don't
know it's the police they can very
easily assume it's a home Intruder both
of those cases have that in common the
homeowner owner was confused they were
not criminals they had no reason to
expect a raid
and they ended up in terrible situations
and those situations are terrible for
the police officers involved too I don't
think anybody goes into public service
anticipating that they may be
responsible through entering those
situations for taking the life of an
innocent and I'm asking you to consider
supporting this bill
in order to
stop putting police officers in
lose-lose situations we are we have a
system in which nobody should be the
judge the jury and the Executioner and
yet this is what happens a lot of the
times in no knock warrant scenarios
because we are creating that situation
where everything is escalated nobody
knows who is there
and you gotta make split-second
decisions and no human no matter how
great and how trained and how you know
well intended they are can judge every
one of those situations correctly I
would urge you to consider you know
supporting this bill to stop putting our
police officers in those situations and
to also to protect their lives and the
lives of the people theirs were to
president Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman um it in direct to
your comment have you asked the officer
any of the police officers if if they
don't want to be in this particular
situation if that's just your opinion
I have spoken with a few police officers
and I'm gonna also
refer to my experience as a finance
director
sometimes people want the ability to
make decisions and it is our
responsibility as people who make the
rules to not give them tools that will
lead to a bad outcome as a finance
doctor I would never approve a system in
which somebody would receive money would
you know verify they were received and
it would put them in the you know in a
pocket and then allowed be allowed to
spend them no matter how honest they are
there should be checks and balances into
place the fact that I did speak with
some police officers the majority of
them did want to retain this power but I
believe that it is in the best interest
of the public and the police officers
for us to not put them into those
situations
you know because again sometimes
it's the people in charge who need to
make the rules and not everybody is
going to be happy with the rules but we
have to balance the best interest of
representative Cameron
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I I'd like to note
that the bill affects search warrants
only and not arrest warrants so the
police would still have the authority
and ability to do a no knock arrest
warrant is that is that my understanding
correct
I
believe you are understanding it
correctly but frankly you know
I think that any no knock warrant is
trouble waiting to happen and
you know I would be supporting
taking that tool from the toolbox of
anybody
thank you for your testimony oh I'm
sorry representative scitec uh thank you
uh doesn't a judge issue this doesn't he
know the circumstances under which this
is being done are we going to substitute
public policy for the Judgment of a
judge
foreign
I very much respect everybody involved
in those decisions and I believe that
they all do everything in their power to
get to the right situations but the fact
is that
there is a large number of situations
when in hindsight those warrants should
have never been issued and yet they were
issued by a judge mistakes happen people
provide incorrect information and so on
and I would also argue that even when a
judge okays that because the law says
that under the circumstances that is an
option in their toolbox the horrific
outcomes of those types of raids on
everybody involved again police officers
and citizens
are a place where absolutely it is the
responsibility of the legislature to say
that you know we don't want to put
anybody in that situation frankly I
wouldn't want to be the judge that
issued the warrant in the two cases I
mentioned especially the case of
Catherine Johnston in Georgia if you
review it I'm sure it's a well-known
case
that warrant should not have been issued
a judge issued it because they acted on
the information they had doing the best
you know to get it right but I'm sure
they feel responsibility in some way for
the outcome of that warrant and again I
don't think we should put those public
servants in those situations
thank you
have you considered
um and I know that we've discussed
you've mentioned the um several horrific
cases and uh
and personally I don't think anyone's
any evidence is worth someone's life
having said that there's hundreds of
search warrants no knock issued across
the country every year that are to do
with officer safety that where the
suspect that they're going to get if he
does or she has advanced warning they're
coming they're going to be prepared to
to fire on the officers what is your
position on a no knock warrant for the
for the safety of the officer
I believe that it is an idea that is
well intended
there are a lot of places where that has
the opposite effect
think about you know I I don't I don't
have the case number but there was at
least one case somewhere in the midwest
where a homeowner ended up killing
police officers in the commission of a
raid and was acquitted because they did
not know they were the police and they
ended up you know
getting you know not suffering
consequences but those police officers
lost their lives in a scenario in which
knocking on the door and announcing
themselves would have eliminated that
conflict I think it's just terrible to
create these situations where nobody
knows who is what
and terrible things happen and we have
to balance those situations against the
I like to point out that while he is not
formally a co-sponsor he does obviously
support the concept in the bill but he
did not have a chance to weigh in on the
language so maybe those questions should
come to me in the formal co-sponsors but
I'll leave his opinion to him
thank you and you're sitting there and
free to jump in at any point on a
question
um I think that's all the questions I
don't see any other hands so thank you
for your testimony thank you so much
I think one of them's leaving and the
other one's still going to stay is that
correct
yes and I there are other co-sponsors
here who have committee at the same time
I'm happy to speak now I just am mindful
when I have had committee days the same
time you know you know what I'm saying
who's next um that would like to as a
good morning uh representative Santo
nastasso Fringe Jaffrey Dublin uh I'd
like to address your question about the
officer safety
um a lot of times these no knock raids
uh
the individual in question they can
arrest these guys
in the city you know anytime uh they
don't need to do these no knock raid
things uh just like
um a couple examples of David koresh
they they could arrest that guy in the
city at any time they didn't have to
seize the property and uh locally we had
uh Ian Freeman they didn't know knock
right on uh I think in 2020
um
same thing they could have just they why
do they need to do a no knock rate they
could have just waited until he was in
the city and just arrested him or they
could have just you know anyway
uh but the as a perspective of State
policy we can't have no knock raids
because we have uh you know it's legal
and it's a very large culture of gun
ownership in this state and when you
have a no knock raid going on uh you
know the police are doing what they're
supposed to be doing and the individual
getting his house rated by the police is
going to do what he believes is correct
to do to defend his family and his
property and uh so we got two people
acting appropriately uh and it can cause
us violent conflict so just because of
the way we have firearms in the state
and and the way people believe that they
have a right to use them uh we can't
have this policy of no knock raids and
uh that's basically the point I wanted
to make
thank you um just a question
um the the koresh and Freeman cases
those were Federal were they not
uh well crash case a long time ago so I
don't remember the FBI ATF yeah the um
Ian Freeman it was a co-operation
between uh state federal and local okay
thank you
and no further questions thank you for
is this the last co-sponsor I believe
okay thank you
hello my name is Glenn Bailey
representing Stratford II uh
I was looking at the fiscal note
associated with this
from the New Hampshire Municipal
Association indicates no knock warrants
rely on the tactic of speed to avoid
destruction of evidence or harm to
officers and others
it's not working they're harming others
and it's a little bit of tunnel vision
I have here
from the U.S Supreme Court the case of
coffin versus the United States it is
better to let the crime of a guilty
person go unpunished than to condemn or
I'll add to harm the innocent
and it goes way way back to the Romans
had this same principle it's in
Blackstone you know
yeah so
we're gonna bust in and they seem to do
it on very little evidence
that I mean I've looked and I've said
it's very easy to find thousands of
articles about this
in which and there was one that was
somewhat amusing where they
arrested the mayor if they broke in the
house of the mayor of their own City by
mistake
um and there's of course that horrific
one where they fired the flashbang into
the crib of the little child who was
horribly disfigured for Life having
barely lived
and
so I would remind you that it's better
to let the guilty go unpunished than to
um
I guess that's
all
thank you thank you for your testimony
oh representative Newell
um I know and I'm sure many of us have
heard examples of you know how this has
happened anecdotally I'm wondering if
there's any is there any place where
there's actually statistics aggregated
about you know um not that I know but I
I just spent half an hour and literally
thousands of faulty no-knock raids thank
you and people have been killed I mean I
won't say thousands have been killed but
it hunt dozens hundreds you know I don't
know
and so those are the innocent being
punished by sloppy
it's it's often based on confidential
informance and they get the addresses
wrong or well the person's there once a
month and they bust in and all the whole
family at gunpoint it's just
unconscionable
representative scitec no no no I'm just
representative scitec it does go back to
try not to elicit a question when he
that thank you for your testimony this
morning
and
Mr chair
I'm representative Chris Schultz
um from Concord including where we sit
is part of my district
um I think they all cited good reasons I
think we all arrived at the same point
for a number of instances like this
um I was inspired by
um the unfortunate death of Brianna
Taylor
I'm from Louisville originally and one
of my high school classmates was an EMT
with her so I shared her grief
from here
and that was an unfortunate innocent
person public servant who served the
community well who
unfortunately did pass away because of a
clerical error
um
but as they stated there are so many
instances I could name a few others that
I knew of before that but the language
of this is essentially the same or
similar language put into New Hampshire
words that mirrored what the city of
Louisville did so if you have a a
problem with the language and you want
to include
more instances to ban I would be open to
that but that's where the language of
this comes from and then was put into
words to fit New Hampshire law with the
OLS folks who wrote the Bill
um it's also interesting a complication
maybe maybe complications the wrong word
but while I did not watch the
president's State of the Union
apparently he is issuing an executive
order
uh with a no knock warrant ban
obviously all these forces are coming
together liberty-minded Republicans
Progressive Democrats the president
black lives matter and I think we're at
a Tipping Point on this issue and I I
have spoken to law enforcement to get to
an earlier question and I know they want
all the tools in the toolbox they can
have to keep us safe and I respect that
but it is our job to put the bumpers
around
what that is when we see a need for
um doing that we should do that and I
you know I would not be shocked if they
say if any of them choose to speak today
or you may hear from your own law
enforcement that it's not a problem here
well I'm a big fan of should we wait
until it's a problem here when there
have been enough instances of this
across the country
um I know of a horrible incident on a
separate topic where we waited until
something awful happened before we fixed
an issue in Concord and so I don't want
to wait for this to be a problem
um
so for that
um oh and the other big point I wanted
to make is we are a state that
encourages gun ownership
I know you heard about that quite a bit
yesterday I admire your tenacity and
resilience on the topic and while we may
disagree on some of the issues
surrounding that I'm mindful that that
actually puts police officers at risk
potentially that if someone for whatever
reason is um law enforcement
does the no knock warrant thing in their
home and someone has a gun for safety
purposes that puts them at risk I don't
by the point that this would be better
in that instance to do it unannounced I
actually believe that's the opposite I
think that's common sense but again I
respect the fact that folks want all the
tools in the toolbox but this is a
Tipping Point on this issue to address
and that so many disparate forces in New
Hampshire have come together
um and just in general with the Tipping
Point issue like I pointed out I feel
like it's time
to prevent this from becoming a problem
here
and I'm happy to answer all the
questions you may have had unanswered
as best as I best of my ability
thank you for your testimony
um So based on what you're saying you
wouldn't mind if we just retain this
because the president has it covered or
I actually did think about suggesting
that I mean my issue with that is I
don't know which would take precedence
quicker
um
honestly I have mixed feelings about
that I mean I think an executive order
comes and goes depending on the
president I think we would need to
address it in New Hampshire law
regardless I don't know if an executive
order would take precedent or go into
effect sooner than the bill which is
UH 60 days after its passage that's
actually
a pretty Swift uh enactment but we're
not exactly the swiftest necessarily
with our legislative and executive
process but I'm open
so yeah I would be open to that
representative Rhodes you had a question
yes thank you Mr chair I'm thank you for
taking my question I'm just curious on
where it says before ending the premises
give appropriate notice what what would
be considered what what how long is the
officer supposed to what is the
appropriate notice I feel like this is
common sense you know knocking
saying police or FBI or whatever I
realize we don't address the FBI I
apologize for
um you know
what would be traditional would be a
knock
you know this really is that designation
of announcing
that you're here I mean I will admit I'm
probably seeing this happen more on TV
than in person but I would think that
this would be a common sense
you know a common sense
moment of safety
representative Newman
yeah I would just uh there was a
question about what kind of warrants
does this apply to when um the first
sentence uh seems to be pretty
definitive that you it just says it'll
execute
uh a no knock search warrant so it it
doesn't differentiate between arrest
warrant and search warrant was that in
the intent of the language yes and I
would be open to including any type of
Warrant potentially that that you would
feel isn't necessary but that was the
instance
um with the Louisville ordinance because
that's what the warrant was
um
in Louisville I will admit so I'm open
to
representative Muse
I just wanted to point out in the
statute that you reference
um I don't see anything that actually
authorizes a no-nock warrant
so I'm kind of wondering
uh how that may have evolved probably
not a question for you but a question
for maybe some of the folks who follow
you
interesting point
um
I do know what happens here
I've found no statistics of how often it
happens here with um state and local law
enforcement but it definitely happens
here
so
regardless of if it's in current law a
thank you for your testimony thank you
thank you chairman members of committee
so I just want to talk about something
that wasn't mentioned was the improper
use of SWAT teams by people that are
looking to pull pranks on people so I'm
sorry I'm Jason Gerhard Northfield
Franklin representative
so swatting is when you call the police
on this actually happens numerous times
with video game people because they're
playing live on the feed so it's funny
to have the SWAT team running on your
friend while he's playing a game but
there's been deaths that have occurred
and so that kind of goes back to the
previous questions where we talked about
foreign
why would we restrain these tools or
keep these tools away from people's
disposal and I think that the reason is
that if you have a tool you're going to
use it
so just because these they exist so they
have there has to be a justification of
why you have what you have so then I was
doing a little bit of quick research and
I came across
from Worcester Massachusetts the Worster
magazine just has an article about the
history which I thought was kind of
interesting is very quick the SWOT
concept dates back to the 1960s when
urban riots and a mass shooting at the
University of Texas demonstrated that
law enforcement needed to prepare to
respond to emergency situations
involving hostages terrorists or crazed
gunmen the following decades saw the
development of the first tactical teams
in New England by the 1980s the War on
Drugs led the federal government to
start channeling more resources to local
and state law enforcement agencies
leading to a major expansion of SWAT
rates and a drift away from the original
purpose of SWAT for example
the Massachusetts State Police Special
tactics and operations team was rarely
activated during the 1970s and then only
for extreme incidents incidences
like airplane hijackings
so the number of operations has since
increased from around 17 per year in the
mid-1970s to 180 to 200 times per year
today
so I think New Hampshire and the rest of
well New England obviously got swept up
in the drug war and this is just another
byproduct of it
and I think it's it's a dangerous
dangerous Trend and it just it
discourages trust between
regular people and the police
unnecessarily I'm I think is
just personal experience and and seeing
that it's very rare that you need to go
bust down somebody's door when people
are so intermingled with Society
there's a way in place and a time to do
it and I trust that our law enforcement
has the capability to do it especially
with all the surveillance equipment
nowadays you can pretty much know when
somebody's going to the bathroom
literally so
represent Newell
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
um that's interesting I was thinking
about that as well but I'm not sure is
is swatting or is are these things
synonymous right is it no knock warrant
the same thing as what happens when
someone swats another person sure the
warrant process does add a layer of
safeness to it admittedly but at the
same time I just wonder if we've not
made this now a cultural thing I mean
we're kids doing this in the 1970s
yeah I wonder too I mean especially
swatting the the idea of just having
very flimsy evidence somebody called up
and said used so that the standards for
using said tool decrease so we can get
usage out of it and say hey there's the
reason we have this armored personnel
carrier sitting next to the fire truck I
mean
the chair recognizes Joseph lacaze and
um
thank you it's okay it's okay it's a
good French name I can run run for
office in the North Country
um
legal director at the ACLU of New
Hampshire thank you so much for the
opportunity to testify today I'm
actually here uh in lieu of Joseph
laskaz who is does our smart Justice
work who's unfortunately unable to
attend today
um so I'll be speaking briefly on his
behalf and on behalf of the organization
this is a bill that we support
um because I think we continue to have
like so many community members and like
so many people you've heard today
have serious concerns with no knock
warrants because they can have severe
and deadly consequences for everyone
involved
so under a Noah Warren as you know
police can barrage into a person's home
they can do in the dead of night without
any notice without clearly identifying
themselves even as law enforcement and
as law enforcement has become more
militarized police departments have used
battering rams to force entry into homes
they've used flashbang grenades
Etc and I can tell you this does happen
you know in New Hampshire and in fact I
had a case
in 2015 in which the case was actually
about videotaping law enforcement but
prior to that action in which law
enforcement was videotaped there was the
use of a now walk warrant on his
property and it terrified people
um including the two women that were on
the property there incendiary devices
were thrown into the windows the doors
were kicked down officers came in with
semi-automatic weapons there was no
issue and there didn't need to be a no
knock rate but the place was trashed
again people were terrorized
law enforcement could have done their
job without that um having occurred and
certainly without the damage that was
done to the individual's property but
we've seen this of course nationally
with much more devastating and severe
consequences the Brianna Taylor case was
mentioned and and there she was killed
by police in a no walk raid in her
residence it was part of a it seemed to
be part of a drug investigation she
herself was not suspected of any uh
crime or any drug involvement
and we've seen this of course in other
cities New Hampshire for example has
come I'm sorry New York has come under
scrutiny for for no knock raids that
have subjected families to being
awakened at gunpoint including in a case
where officers had the wrong address and
another in which only evidence was found
of small amount of marijuana
so I think that the point of this bill
is really to get
legislators to us as a community to
think about
the countervailing civil liberties
interests that come with no not grades
because I have no doubt that you'll hear
testimony from law enforcement today
that these are a vital tool they're
incredibly important they're designed to
ensure that individuals don't destroy
evidence before law enforcement come
um you know I think though that there
are real harms that we just really need
to think about as a state and as a
community I think this also we see this
with respect to some concerns about
racial disparities I don't have data in
New Hampshire unfortunately about
whether there's disparate impact as to
how these no NOC warrants are used here
that would be great to have that data
but nationally there have been those
concerns raised and so I really think
that we should be looking at that other
side of the equation because again it
has been has been testified before New
Hampshire there's a high rated gun
ownership people have guns they have
going guns lawfully it's consistent with
their second amendment rights and when
you allow law enforcement to barrage in
someone's property it is reasonable for
anyone to think
something's breaking into my property
and it creates I think a needless risk
of Confrontation for uh for all involved
and I think that is a real cost that
needs to be part of the analysis in
assessing whether or not as a state we
should have these uh warrants allowed
other states have been doing some reform
efforts as well including including
Oregon I understand Florida I know the
courts have gotten involved in looking
at this so you know our hope is that New
Hampshire becomes one of the states that
thank you for your testimony oh
representative pru
so all I've heard is the negative
effects do you have any data on how many
of these were successfully carried out
and maybe prevented
officers deaths I don't have that data
it's also incredibly hard to prove a
negative right
um it's hard to evaluate and demonstrate
I think statistically well but for this
no knock rate someone would have
flattered but for this Novak rate
evidence would have been destroyed I
don't think that actually can be proven
because you're proving a negative what I
can prove are the instances in which
neuronic rates have led to real harm
real loss of life
and that's that's really what I think is
so critical as part of this analysis as
this committee evaluates the pluses and
minuses of this particular policy
I see
um do you have any information on
whether or not the Supreme Court the
United States Supreme Court has waited
on this issue of no knock warrants I
don't and I I actually haven't looked at
that so
um I'm happy to to take a look at it if
the committee wants but I don't sitting
before the committee my apologies it
would be appreciated if you could thanks
of course representative Muse
and just a quick question I'll ask you
the same question I asked the uh the the
sponsor of the legislation
um
do we have a statute in New Hampshire
that uh allows no knock warrants and
would you consider the absence of a
statute like that to be a problem given
the fact that we seem to be doing them
that's a great question and I don't know
so is the idea that you're contemplating
is that because there's no Authority
there's no statutory recognition of this
policy is it is it otherwise permitted
is that the question would it be that's
basically you know I don't I don't know
uh and I haven't given a significant
amount of thought to that I mean it is
true of course that these no knock raids
they they are they go to a court right a
court signs off on any search warrant
including of course a no knock search
warrant I mean I think
I want to say this without being overly
critical but I think we know that most
search warrants are are granted
um it's not clear to me I'm not and
maybe I'll be corrected by law
enforcement in the room I don't know
what precise and exacting standards
exist with respect to how these are
implemented or how they are sought that
certainly hasn't been formalized by the
legislature and maybe again that's
something that's worth considering for
the legislature you know given some of
the concerns we've seen with this
practice nationally
and as you were answering the question I
did see a gentleman in the back of the
room I'm waiting on his arm going I hope
do you have any comments about the
thought that I have of
um somehow making a warrant whatever
warrant kind it is
um to differentiate between the the
purpose of the warrant is to retain
evidence to make sure you get evidence
or it's to have a to deal with the
dangerous situation where the police the
police officer's life may be in danger
because of announcement of of who they
are and what they're there for maybe
because of speed or some other instance
that might cause harm to the officer
I'd have to give some thought to it I
think my initial reaction is that we
probably still have concerns with
um
a proposal that even in that instance
narrowed the scope of no knock warrants
I mean that that is probably the primary
justification right now for most no
knock warrants and I think we've seen
even with that you know some some
devastating consequences that again we
as an organization continue to have
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members my name is Russian
Chester I'm from Bedford New Hampshire
and I'm coming from a very different
point that I think is important is that
anytime there's a no knock situation I
worked for dcyf for a number of years I
went with police to remove children from
homes without parents knowledge that was
traumatizing for everyone involved it
was traumatizing for the case manager
for the children for the parents and the
officers that accompanied us when we're
whenever we're dealing with a high
emotional situation the risk of danger
for everyone involved both physically
and emotionally is much greater so my
concerns with the no knock warrants is
primarily that is that all of us are
looking at the physical
aspects of the trauma but there's an
emotional aspect too that needs to be
considered during this process the
bottom line is when someone hit when an
officer kills someone in Duty they live
with that for the rest of their life
whether it was justified or not they
still took the life of another human
being and on the other coin when someone
feels that they're protecting their
family or their home or their children
and they take someone's life in most
cases they live with that for the rest
of their lives
I just wanted to bring that up to you
folks as a point of order
representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you so much
for taking my question appreciate you
being here today
um I'm wondering especially to um the
the trauma Factor
um as you're describing do you think
that or I guess my question for you is
in your experience what was the
threshold for doing something like that
for for approaching it in that way where
you needed to go in uh in this in this
type of way and
um and to take a child you know what I
mean intervene in a situation so in
thank you for your question in most of
those cases
someone made the determination that the
family was either a high risk for
running the child was in immediate
danger
um
and in some cases it may have been
warranted
but in most cases what we found what I
found and what our officers found is
that we really didn't need to do it the
way we did it we did it based on the
information we had and that information
wasn't always accurate and up to date
thank you for your testimony you're
and the chair recognizes Mark Harrington
thank you sir I hope it's okay I brought
uh one of my co-workers officer lynched
good morning
Jim and Roy members of the committee my
name is Mark Harrington I'm a sergeant
with the Manchester Police Department I
have been a resident of the State of New
Hampshire and a police officer here for
the last 15 years
I currently serve as a first line
supervisor on the 4-12 shift on a Patrol
Division
I've also been a member of
I've also been a member of my department
SWAT team for the last 13 years the last
three of which I've served as a team
leader I'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak before you today in
opposition of House Bill 135 on behalf
of my department and is also the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police
I'm going to speak about no knock
warrants and knock and announce warrants
both of which I have extensive personal
experience with
unfortunately no knock warrants have
recently gained negative national
attention due to a few tragic incidents
that have occurred outside of the State
of New Hampshire
no knock warrant is a search warrant
authorized authorizing highly trained
police officers to enter an identified
premise without first knocking
announcing their presence and purpose
no knock warrants are intelligence
driven meaning that investigation has
led to to extensive research
surveillance and intelligence that has
been obtained requiring the no knock
warrant
this information usually identifies that
the suspect is likely to be armed with a
deadly weapon has made statements of
resistance has fortified their premise
and has surveillance systems or
aggressive animals
no knock warrants provide police
officers with inner structural control
while clearly identifying themselves
which is a key Advantage when executing
these warrants
this tactic is used without the intent
of keeping the suspect from arming
themselves and harming others within the
premise or fleeing upon police arrival
upon executing a no knock warrant loud
PA announcements are immediately made by
law enforcement clearly identifying
themselves as police to the suspect and
the surrounding community
no knock warrants are highly effective
and when executed properly provide the
highest level of safety to the public
officers and suspects although a no
knock warrant allows for officers to
enter a premises and execute a warrant
it has more complex tactics and decision
making involved depending on the
intelligence gathered law enforcement
May utilize a breach and hold tactic a
first room entry
or potentially a fluid dynamic entry
these key the key point is that law
enforcement has options dependent on the
situation intelligence and safety
concerns
a knock and announce warrant is a search
warrant requiring police officers to
First knock and announce their presence
and purpose prior to entering the
premise a key issue with a knock and
announce warrant is that it gives
suspects time to arm and potentially
attack police
as seen in Philadelphia just three
months ago with three Philadelphia SWAT
offices was shot through the front door
and window of the residence by the
suspect it allows suspects to take time
potentially take innocent victims inside
the premise hostage or inflect injury
upon themselves or a third party
if House Bill 135 were to pass offices
would not have the option to execute a
no knock search warrant and would be
held to a knock and announced warrant
only
in New Hampshire tax fuel teams across
the state take great pride in their
investigations preparation and execution
of these warrants
I speak from personal experience when I
say that I've seen the benefits of a
known Arc warrant in which a suspect has
attempted on themselves upon police
arrival
if a no knock warrant had been executed
the result of the investigation could
have ended with a lethal engagement
instead of a peaceful surrender
in closing I see you find Hospital 135
in expedient to legislate and I
appreciate your time thank you for
consideration
thank you for your testimony could you
explain to the committee the judicial
review process required to obtain such a
warrant the level of versus a knock and
announce and also if there's any
difference on the search warrant return
well I can't obviously speak to as far
as through the judge's eyes who would be
signing it but as far as the department
I can speak a little bit more educated
than just
any any police officer as I worked five
years in the drug unit on my department
as well so I kind of saw it from
not only the Tactical side of things but
also the investigatory side of things
I can speak for the Manchester Police
Department for sure that we take our due
diligence and time there is no uh
set time frame two weeks a month three
months of of the investigation but we do
have
I would say like levels of intelligence
that we need to receive for instance we
need to see the people leaving and
exiting through a particular door we
need to have the idea of not only the
building but potentially the exact uh
apartment door that they go in that's
done with different surveillance tactics
undercover operations and whatnot we
don't
it's not a one-trick pony so to speak
that we don't only do one particular
thing and that covers Us for everything
but we have a a wide variety of tools
that we utilize to get the proper
intelligence
that makes us feel comfortable with that
is the that is the address that is the
door those are the people and in that
intelligence gathering we get gather the
um the other information such as
children animals other people that are
coming and going to the point where we
have gut it down if there are if there
are children involved what what time do
they leave to go to school and we can we
can tailor our timing around that
particular situation
um
we do do a threat assessment as well
prior to anything which a person needs
to score into a certain level based on
their prior criminal history the
intelligence driven through the
investigation are they armed do they
have a history of having weapons as
their premise fortified there's a
there's a list of uh that we go through
on that and the person necessitates a
particular score where the SWAT team
would be utilized for that
the rationale behind it like I said is
we're not going
um to utilize the SWAT team unless the
threat Matrix is there and we feel that
it's necessary that we utilize that
tactic
I guess what I'm asking though is in the
search warrant application does the
court require a higher standard from you
to get a no knock versus a standard not
going to announce warrant no I mean it
could be offered back if it was
necessary in my experience
when we apply for the search warrant it
comes back as that way
so you apply specifically for a no-noc
warrant
not just a search warrant you have to no
we apply for the search warrant and it's
it's granted unless they the the judge
comes back in in his questioning and
feels is it necessary to do this uh
if he has a question on the rationale
behind the search warrant I guess it's
representative Pratt
in one of these no knock situations
um you knock on the door you break the
door down you walk in yeah there's a
German Shepherd or a dog inside the door
how do you uh handle that how would you
handle that I know my dog protects my
house from grade school so if somebody's
kicking the front door down to back up I
apologize yes and it's kind of a archaic
way of putting it that way that we walk
up we knock on the door we break the
door down and then we walk in okay
um like I testified to it depends on the
situation we would have normally the
intelligence of weathers or dog because
if you have a large Shepherd you have
been taking that dog outside to use the
bathroom and during surveillance right
or the intelligence driven we would have
that and we would prefer prepare for
that often we use fire extinguishers
which work very well if the dog becomes
aggressive we also have two Animal
Control offices in the city and if we
feel it's a situation like that we have
brought them out not necessarily right
with us up to the house but had them
back in case we needed to utilize a
snare or some something like that to
make it a more safe situation for the
animal for the people inside for us as
well but there are options that we have
it's not just a
any type of a lethal situation it's we
truly do try to prepare for every
scenario and have contingencies for as
many issues as we can think of going
into a situation
I like to apologize I didn't mean to
insult anybody by saying you'd kick the
door down but at no knock entry
you're not you're not somebody's not
opening the door for you to come in
right well correct we're not knocking on
a no knock right so where the door gets
opened I guess my point is the tactic of
us just going into the house isn't a 100
standard
the the true tactic that we utilize more
often than not is a breach and hold
where the door will get opened
um and at that point we get to see
inside the structure we get to make our
announcements as far as who we are what
we're there for and now we can see
whether we are utilizing the solely the
door have we breached a window as well
and Ray can break the window to get
proper control over what we can inside
the house without
putting people In Harm's Way
unnecessarily by rushing into the house
and
we can control a lot from the outside of
the structure but the key point is to
get that reach point where we can see
the movements or stop the movements uh
control what's going on the best of our
ability which creates a much more safe
environment for everyone involved thank
you
representative Newman
just a clarification on your last
statement if you if you get an Open Door
how do you get in that circumstances if
if if we were to open the door you mean
if you could just open is that what you
mean you just could open the door if the
door was unlocked and you did that I
mean we do that on in breaching if if we
have a no knock search warrant
we still always try the door handle
because it facilitates things you don't
have to break and damage everything
that's not the goal the goal is to get
the door open the easiest way to open a
door is to turn the knob and push it
open if we can just to follow up
so that's uh so that's is that the only
situation where you get the door open
you were just able to do that without
damage and then you could surveil no I
mean obviously it's it's terrific if all
the doors are left wide open but the the
doors are off and locked and if they are
we would utilize some type of breaching
technique to get the door open thank you
representative Muse
yes and and uh excuse me I have a little
bit of a hearing issue and sometimes
you're a little bit far away from the
mic
um but I just want to make sure I heard
something that I thought you said uh
that I got it correctly
um I thought I heard you say heard you
say that when you apply for a search
warrant there is no uh special process
or additional evidentiary requirement
that you have in order to turn this from
just a regular search process into a no
knock search it sounds like you have the
discretion to make that decision
yourself
we can make this if it's not required
but as I said when the SWAT team gets
gets utilized on warrant services
they're bringing us in because there are
special circumstances and more so those
circumstances are the potential violence
or um
guns illegal guns and situations that
could be uh facing
law enforcement to go to that residence
so the requirement of the no knock is
something that we
um
it has to rise to that level for us not
number one just to be utilized as a SWAT
team
thank you for taking my question thank
you Mr chairman
a judge would still have to approve a
no-nock warrant that's not something you
do on your own correct correction okay
representative wheeler Mr chairman I'd
like you to elaborate on what type of
criminal what crime most often warrants
a no knock search in your experience
but more often than not
um we see a gun and Drug crimes in the
city of Manchester where we're going to
these addresses and being utilized and
to also fall back on the threat
situations that are going to get you a
higher score at the the the
known history of weapons the fact
whether the person has been seen with uh
with weapons at that point
um
if uh it falls back on their history
both uh
you know long-term history as well as
their recent history involved in that
particular investigation or case so I
mean drugs and drugs and guns are what
what really pushed the
push the the needle so to speak to to
has there ever been a case in New
Hampshire as far as you're aware of a
human trafficking uh case of no knock
warranting where they had gone in to uh
in regards to human trafficking and or
something other than drug or uh violent
well we have had human trafficking cases
in the city of Manchester that I can
speak of firsthand
um
but while I will say in those cases
it wasn't just the human tracking and
trafficking involved it was also a drug
aspect drug sales as well as uh firearm
purchasing uh illegally
so it was an intertwined situation it
as I recall I believe it was uh multiple
addresses multiple people involved in it
so it was kind of a a fluid situation
but they were no knock yes sir
Representative no
real quickly I'm just really curious
when you're saying here you talk about a
PA announcement and I'm wondering you
know when we're talking about no knock
the the point is it's the element of
surprise you know what I mean it's like
the element of of not knowing so when
does the PA announcement happen
the PA announcement occurs right after
we we get
right after we basically are announcing
our presence so first by opening
um the door breaching the door of the
window whatever it is we're doing and
we're following that up with immediate
PA announcements and to more better
clarify the PA is not like a school PA
or something that even just comes from
one of our police cruisers it's uh it's
actually called an lrad and it's
something that's utilized by the
military
um which is like mounted on uh
battleships and stuff like that so if
utilized we obviously don't use it at a
tone at a level that could be heard for
miles but it's done in a way so that
it's it's very obvious and clear who we
are and what we're there for and that
has been a progression for us because
originally it was just the verbal
announcements and it has progressed to
the point where it made more sense and
it was more safe to go to a more abrupt
voice like that and we could get it
better from this tool and that's what we
have gone to as a team so we have them
mounted
um on our vehicles and we also have a
couple portable ones as well that we can
utilize if it's
say a like a apartment structure that
has a bigger hallway or something like
that or if uh it if it makes sense we
have the ability to adjust to it
thank you very much sure
thank you for your testimony
you're good the chair recognizes Jeff
Charlton from the Attorney General's
office
good morning I'm Jeff stralzen associate
attorney general from New Hampshire
Attorney General's office I'm here to
answer questions any questions that you
have about this and also just to point
out a couple of issues that we saw with
the bill just to bring to your attention
to consider maybe the first thing I'll
say is that so New Hampshire has what's
called a knock and announce rule
that rule was recognized in New
Hampshire in 1985 by a New Hampshire
Supreme Court case and what so it's not
by Statute it's not by rule uh the New
Hampshire Supreme Court recognized it as
part of our common law meaning our legal
history
and they recognized exceptions to that
rule that are the same exceptions that
the U.S Supreme Court has recognized
essentially an exception for the
preservation of evidence and essentially
a life and safety exception and so the
New Hampshire Supreme Court rule is
consistent with what the U.S Supreme
Court has recognized so again as far as
I can tell there's no statute no rule in
New Hampshire what there is is there's
case law from our New Hampshire Supreme
Court that said that New Hampshire as a
requirement of our common law would
require police to knock and announce
themselves prior to using Force to make
an entry and then recognized that there
were exceptions and obviously this bill
talks about doing away with all the
exceptions so happy to answer more
questions about the legal piece of it I
just want to tell you about a couple
observations that we have with the bill
to bring to your attention
the first issue is that the bill does
not contain an exception for the life
and safety piece so that means in
certain situations and these are
typically
high-risk situations involving a hostage
or a high risk arrestee
law enforcement would not be able to get
permission to enter without announcing
themselves and obviously that would
potentially endanger their lives or the
people inside if they're trying to
rescue somebody if there are other
people inside
we would suggest that if you're going to
consider passing this bill you consider
using the same exception that the U.S
department of justice has put in place
and I think there was a reference
earlier about what the what the feds
were doing the federal government
actually put in place a limitation on no
knock warrants essentially what they did
is there was an executive order a
directive issued by the U.S department
of justice that did away with the
property exception meaning law
enforcement could no longer ask for a no
knock warrant and say we want to use it
to protect the destruction of property
the FED said no more of that but they
still kept the life safety exception
um and believed at the time the Warren
is sought knocking and announcing the
office's president would create an
imminent threat of physical violence to
the officer another person they would
not they could get the no knock warrant
so that's my understanding of what the
federal government has done and that and
that was talked about was an expansion
to other fed federal agencies originally
it was issued to the U.S Department of
Justice I think to the FBI now my
understanding is it's going to be it's
going to be implemented across the board
to other federal agencies but again my
understanding is that what the feds have
done is kept the life safety exemption
for no knock warrants but they have
eliminated the one for uh preserving
property so we would suggest that if
you're going to consider this building
you consider keeping that life safety
exemption in place because again I will
tell you in my experience as a
prosecutor there have certainly been
times where we have discussions with
with the police that we're working with
about making an arrest and about whether
or not and you heard that you heard the
term threat Matrix there's a series of
factors that the police use to determine
whether or not SWAT is appropriate
looking at different factors like the
type of crime the history of the
arrestee things like that to determine
whether or not it's appropriate to use a
high risk entry or SWAT entry and it
would seem to make sense based on my
experience to keep that exception in
some limited circumstance so they'd have
that ability one of the other things
that was mentioned was about
the issue of you know why do you need to
go into someone's home and
you know I get involved with tactics
only because as a prosecutor we we are
part of the decision on our cases about
arrests I do not profess to be an expert
in tactics however I will tell you what
I what I've learned from Law Enforcement
Officers because early on I would say
well
why can't you just arrest that person
when they're over here or over here at
work or out in public and the answer is
it's much more difficult for the police
to control that situation out in public
if God forbid shots start getting fired
many many more people are at risk and so
often trying to get that person can you
know arrest that person in a contained
space is the most safest way to do it so
again I'll let them speak to that
tactical piece but I will tell you I've
been involved in listening to that
decision-making process about why it is
you would arrest somebody in a certain
place
and just so it's clear about how the
legal process works
this would affect arrest I think
somebody asked a question would this
affect arrest warrants and the answer is
it would and let me explain why
the way the law Works in New Hampshire
if I get an arrest warrant from my
neighbor the the arrest warrant allows
me to enter into that person's home to
make the arrest without an additional
search warrant
but if I want to arrest that person in
their neighbor's home or at work or in
some other location you must secure a
search warrant to go in and execute that
arrest so that's why arrest warrants
could very well be implicated in a lot
of these cases if you have to go
somewhere else I have to make an entry
that is not the person's home even if
it's just for an arrest so the two are
linked together in New Hampshire by that
requirement and loss so one would impact
the other
um another issue with the bill is
just the wording of the bill and this
may have been an unintended consequence
but in paragraph 2A the bill says that
an officer cannot forcibly enter a
building until the person inside refuses
admittance
so that means if the person inside says
nothing the officer can never enter
or if the building is empty and nobody
refuses abundance the officer could
never enter so we think that was
probably an unintended consequence and
should probably strike that language
because otherwise if an officer knocks
and announces himself or herself the
person inside under this bill simply
remains silent and the officer can never
enter to execute the warrant or if the
building is empty could never
enter the enter the building execute the
warrant again I think that's probably an
unintended consequence but I would just
point that out that that's a little bit
of a quirk in that in that language in
the bill
so those are the two issues we see one
is that usdoj has CR has carved out a
life safety exception we would ask you
to consider that as well and second just
that language in the bill I think
creates an unintended consequence and
I'm happy to answer any questions about
the comments that we have on the bill or
the law or or the process of how this
works to the extent I can
thank you for that testimony Could you
um and I tried to get at it early I
don't think I got it is there any
different process to get a no knock
warrant when you're applying to the
court versus a regular warrant do you
have to tell the court you're seeking a
no knock warrant or Can the police
officer just decide you know what we're
going to do this no knock
so let me just start with saying these
are I've been a prosecutor a little over
26 years I have I can't specifically
tell you about a case where I've had
these but I know I've had them that's
how rare they are my understanding is
that you obtain a no-knock warrant by
establishing probable cause for it just
like when you go in for your search
warrant that it's part of that process
because in New Hampshire our Supreme
Court has said we have a rule and the
rule says you police officer must not
get an announce so the way I read that
the way I've interpreted it and the way
I advise police about these types of
things is you have to lay that out in
your application for the search warrant
and establish the probable cause to be
able to do that
so that should be the process again
these are so these are so incredibly
rare I could not come up with a written
give you a testimony you're welcome
the chair recognizes major Joseph Ebert
good morning everyone my name is Joe
Ebert it's ebirt I'm a major with the
state police overseeing the
Investigative Services Bureau and I
purposely chose to go behind attorney
schroelsen today because I knew he was
going to raise many of the the same
issues that I was going to so I'll keep
my testimony very brief because I think
he touched on the things that were of
greatest concern to the state police
specifically the uh the language in the
bill that doesn't address whether or not
when somebody doesn't respond from
inside the building or when somebody
isn't in the building
one thing I did want to say
generally is that
as the officers from Manchester Police
Department have said and I think
everybody who is involved with these
this type of Warrant
it is incredibly important to consider
life and safety and that is something we
absolutely do on a regular basis before
any warrant is executed
having said that I would request much
like the Attorney General's office did
that if you are so inclined to pass a
version of this bill that provides
bumpers for law enforcement to stay
Within
that you do not eliminate the
possibility of the use of this uh this
action so what that may look like
whether it is life and safety or it is
some other metric that you approve of I
would just ask that you consider the
situations that we've run into where we
are executing these Dynamic warrants
the factories involved in them vary so
much that I couldn't possibly tell you
all the things we may or may not run
into in the future
but I do know that I if you're inclined
to put those bumpers in line I would
just ask that you give us some variance
to be able to utilize this in specific
situations so having said that I'm more
than happy to answer any questions you
might have
thank you for your testimony do you have
any specific or even anecdotal evidence
about how many of these cases the state
police might engage in a year
I can give you anecdotal evidence I I'm
happy to talk to the uh our tactical
team leader to give you actual uh
numbers but uh much like attorney
straussen said these are very rare
they're very few and far between
um and I don't recall the last time we
executed a no knock warrant having said
that though again that's not my area of
expertise uh so I'm happy to uh provide
the committee via email with the number
that we do approximately in the course
of a year the committee would appreciate
that if you could and it's readily
available go back a couple years just so
we can see a trend or a pattern in it
certainly representative Newman
thank you I'd like to follow up on the
Chairman's question about the no knock
warrant
when the state police apply for a search
and their intention is to use a no knock
warrant
is there a rule that's written as
something other than common law that
hasn't been noticed by the Supreme Court
do they specifically have to if they are
going to use the no knock warrants
indicate in the search warrant request
that that is their intention
thank you for the question uh
representative Newman I
be very uh transparent with you and
saying that I don't know the definitive
answer to that question but I'm happy to
provide it in the email that I sent to
the chairman so I don't want to speak my
understanding is that yes we make uh
clear Our intention to utilize a no
knock tactic but having said that what I
will do is I will ask our Tactical Team
commander and I will provide the
committee with a definitive answer
follow up follow up
when you find that wherever it is along
with the information about what it is
I I mean if yes when you return that I
mean there are protocols and stuff for
various places and I I'm just curious
where could we look that up if that's
available to the public
absolutely yeah so I would have to look
into uh I believe our policies and
procedures are all accessible via 91a
and their policies and procedures that
govern our Tactical Team and the
execution of search warrants uh within
them so I'm happy to provide the
information on where that is thank you
if it wouldn't be too much trouble and
you could get one could you get us a
copy of search warrant application
standard application absolutely and just
work to see if we can discern for
ourselves if there's a spot on there
they check no knock
um representative Reed
if I understand you it's not that common
of An Occurrence correct
that is uh so I appreciate the question
uh but I I think there may be a
separation of two separate things there
so whether they happen regularly in
other jurisdictions throughout the
course of the United States that I can't
speak to uh what I can say is that uh
having been had some involvement as a
crisis negotiator with our Tactical Team
uh for many years
I am not aware of a slew of no knock
warrants On Any Given uh On Any Given
year and I think I would again
anecdotally I would offer to the
committee that I as time has progressed
we our tactical team has moved away from
uh no knock warrants throughout the
course of my involvement although
limited with that team
foreign
scitec
could you give us a flavor for what in
your interaction with the judges you're
applying you're standing before the
judge can you give us a sense of feel
how that conversation goes
I can I I've been before many judges to
discuss search warrants
um and oftentimes uh the judges when we
discuss whether or not this is going to
be executed uh at uh early morning hours
or if there is a going to be a request
for a no knock uh oftentimes the judges
are hesitant to opine on what should be
done it's been my experience that what
they will say is well you discussed with
me the tactics that are needed uh you
know I will tell you whether or not you
have probable cause but the safety of
how this warrant is executed is really
something that should rely on uh should
rest with the law enforcement but
oftentimes there's a discussion that
takes place with that judge saying hey
this is the dangerous he's read the
affidavit so he knows or she knows
exactly what the case specifics are and
they will often engage us in a
conversation about well what is the
and if I could during that process is it
is it normal for the judge to to push
back occasionally and say you need a
little more probable cause here this
which are are they routinely granted
without question or do they do they get
into the affidavits and say wait a
minute you know
I appreciate the question thank you uh I
would say that judges are uh it has been
my experience that when we ask for a
search warrant or an affidavit uh the
judge spends a significant period of
time reviewing that and they often will
have questions uh the latter half of my
career in fact most of my career has
been spent associated with a major crime
unit which is homicides and other major
cases and I will tell you that when we
go before a judge and we are seeking a
warrant in a homicide a kidnapping any
any major case a shooting a non-fatal
shooting the judges spend an incredible
amount of time in fact we're often left
uh waiting for that judge uh to return
the the warrant and affidavit because
they are spending such a long period of
time we're left wondering if they had
gone back to sleep or uh but I I it's an
anecdotal way of me saying I know that
they're spending time reading every
portion of that and they will often have
questions about certain facts that are
I've seen over the questions thank you
for your testimony I appreciate it thank
you and thank you for getting back to me
with that information
sure you filled out a pink card the
first time right
thank you for letting me speak my name
is officer linstead of the Manchester
Police Department I am the President of
the Nash uh New Hampshire tactical
offices Association and as I've been
sitting here today I've heard some
things that I just wanted to address uh
if that works for you folks
um this has been touched on but I just
want to touch on it again a couple of
people had mentioned that it's it's
easier if David koresh would have walked
out
um and then just place them into custody
I understand that the thought process of
that but we take every single um
situation into consideration before we
do these search warrants and there are
times
a significant amount of times a higher
percentage of times where it's more
dangerous for the citizens of either
Manchester or the state of New Hampshire
to let these people that have reached a
very high level on the threat assessment
to try to take them into custody in the
middle of Market Basket or in the middle
of Elm Street or Main Street
every scenario was taken into
consideration and then we decide how we
do
take that person into custody
each raid if you will or each arrest
wanted a search warrant is prepared by
multiple officers so an officer or SWAT
team member will prepare that and it'll
go with a super they'll do that with a
supervisor and with the detectives that
ran the case he'll go to a supervisor
and it'll also go to a judge
the next thing that I wanted to discuss
uh was the president's speech I think it
was stated earlier that the president
was going to ban these
I have the verbiage here it says
restricts the use of no knock entries to
a limited set of circumstances such as
and went into entry would pose an
imminent threat of physical violence
that was from the president's speech and
that's exactly what we do now
we
we don't just do these on a whim it
already reaches what the president is
trying to push for that's the way we do
it in the state of New Hampshire again
as the president of the nhgoa
these no knock search warrants are very
rare they're very rare throughout the
whole state
um but again
for the safety of the citizens for the
safety of the accused right because we
are not the judge during an execution or
we understand the places we're going for
people that are accused of something not
necessarily always guilty of something
so we understand they're the accused
we create these plans for their safety
the swatting
um
the thing that was mentioned about this
one there would not be a circumstance in
swatting where it's a no knock search
warrant the swatting scenarios that are
happening around the country there's
they're calling up and saying someone's
actively being killed or someone's
actively being stabbed under those
circumstances we have the exemption
we're not going to go back to the
station call some detectives have them
write up a search warrant go to a judge
have the judge sign that while while
someone's being stabbed if there's a
swatting instance uh police officers are
going to respond immediately and deal
with that that threat immediately
um
and just the last one I know we had
someone here up here from dcyf and I
will tell you that I have been on the
SWAT team for 15 years but
I'm a de-escalation instructor I'm a
cultural diversity instructor I'm a CIT
instructor I'm a cism officer mental
health for police and mental health for
the citizens of New Hampshire is a very
high priority for me I have never ever
as a SWAT team member done anything with
dcyf
so I'm not sure what scenarios that
person is talking about
but I've never rammed a door kicked in a
door and run in on a dcyf warn
those are just a couple things that I've
been listening to I wanted to discuss if
you have any questions for me again as
part of the nhgoa I'd be happy to answer
that
thank you for that um I think the DC the
former dcyf employee was saying that she
had accompanied officers where they knew
children were going to be there so that
vcyf could take custody is that
something that you've dealt with
possibly
I can't remember a specific instance
where even that happened but if there
was an instance where we knew that we
were going to take the children I think
that would be very responsible of us to
make sure that we had juvenile officers
there we had CIT officers there and we
had members of uh outside organizations
that could help us
okay thank you and and for the
committee's edification so you no longer
do no knock search warrants is for
evidence preservation in other words
they have so much fentanyl if we knock
on the door they're going to flush it
that type of reason no and I've like I
said I've been on the team uh for about
15 years
um and 15 years ago we would flow into a
house I was talking to my team leader
Sergeant Harrington in the back and in
the last over two years I I can only say
that maybe once that we could both
recall together
that we even entered the first room we
don't flow through the houses anymore
you know I understand that folks you
know you folks and the citizens they
look at these things I think the first
instance was 2006 that was brought up
today the second instant that was
brought to say was 2011. where police
officers did things that were
inappropriate and that happens because
we're human I understand that but we
take those we do the after action
reports and we learn from those and we
make sure those things don't happen
anymore that's why we have the lrad the
long-range acoustical device to announce
who we are that's why we don't flood
through the house or flow through the
house anymore but if you take this bill
away we're not going to be able to
breach and announce we're not going to
be able to rake and break that window to
look in to see if that person is
grabbing a gun or to see if that person
is running to a child's room to grab a
child and take a hostage you're putting
ourselves anyone on the opposite walls
at danger and you're almost creating an
environment where you're trapping that
person and human beings don't like to be
trapped they don't like to be backed
into a corner we're trying to make sure
that that doesn't happen we're trying to
gain control of them immediately
respectfully look I'll be honest we're
not even allowed to swear all right
we're not even allowed to curse We're
very professional organization and that
goes throughout the whole state of New
Hampshire we're professional we do our
jobs properly and and I would hate to
see you know that tool as some people
have called it being taken away from us
because there are instances where it
could put innocent civilians kids in
danger
thank you and one more question for me
has the law enforcement in New Hampshire
been able to utilize new technology to
help them avoid situations like that for
example thermal imaging to see what's
going on inside of an apartment before
they breach or anything like that
so yeah so I again I I teach and I get
to travel the country to teach other
police officers and I will say this and
you could never convince me the other
we're a very well trained State and
um our team has I think 10 drones
um we have an i-core robot and we have
um two we call them throw Bots and a lot
of times on these no knock warrants when
we reach that door we actually drop a
robot and that robot can look up a set
of stairs
to make sure that even though we're
still recessed outside we can see if
somebody's coming down those stairs with
a firearm we can we can talk to them
through the robot we'll drive a robot in
and say you know sir if you could just
show me your hands you know we have a
warrant for your arrest and they can
talk to us back
so we have all those things we are
looking into currently some that looks
through a wall we have to check the
legalities of it we have to check all
that stuff
um but the other other states in this
country already have those items but so
we're working on it we do use technology
quite a bit thank you
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I too worked at dcyf
when
um the um the woman came in and uh
office testimony and I do not recall
ever a SWAT
um and while I do recall SWAT but not a
no knock warrant uh in
um incident
um I think maybe she was trying to
um suggest which we did say because I
too went to homes and sometimes I was a
nurse coordinator uh in the in the
Manchester Nashua Salem uh Concord
district offices
um and the she's what she suggested
around the level of you know emotional
and mental
um uh health impact of those uh
incidences involving children were
important to acknowledge
um but I I would agree I don't know that
not in my recollection either was there
a situation that involved a no-noc yeah
and we wouldn't hesitate to call dcyf if
we knew going in there that that person
was going to go away for a really long
time and they needed to be placed we
would bring our juvenile division in
like I said I'm a CIT instructor a cicm
officer the mental health aspect is very
important to me
um
maybe I misheard her from the back it
almost seemed like they were
we were doing a raid for them
um and and that it's not something I
could ever recall but well absolutely uh
call in outside resources without
without hesitation
thank you for your testimony
thank you thank you very much thank you
is there anyone else wishing to speak on
this bill who hasn't turned in a pink
card
see none I hereby close the public
hearing on hb135
and we are going to take a 10 minute bio
break
foreign
thank you at this time I'm going to open
the public hearing
in the next bill if you could all take a
seat
I am now opening the public hearing on
which
on hp156 relative to misconduct by a law
enforcement officer
we recognize the sponsor representative
Muse to introduces bill
thank you Mr chair
um I want to open by saying that I I
think this is an issue that would only
ever reply to a very very very small
percentage of officers in New Hampshire
um but based on the definition of of a
police misconduct and I think based on
some of the things that we've heard
during some of our other hearings on
these issues I do believe this is
necessary this is actually a bill that
Joseph lascaz of the uh New Hampshire
American civil liberties Union asked me
to file and to testify on unfortunately
I'm not quite sure if Joseph is going to
be available to testify on it today but
I will try to answer as many of your
questions and and do the best job that I
can
what the bill essentially does is it
expands the definition of police conduct
in New Hampshire to include
misrepresentation of a material fact in
a police report or demonstrable
misidentification of the race or
ethnicity of an individual in a police
report
um as it does for other forms of defined
misconduct under the current statute if
another officer observes uh an officer
engaging in this form of misconduct they
would be required to notify uh their
Chief their chief law enforcement
officer in their Department in writing
immediately or as soon as practical
practicable after actually observing
this type of misconduct
um from there the uh the incident would
go into the hands of the police
standards and trainings people who would
conduct a review
again the bill the need for the bill
really stems from the fact that over the
course of several hearings on bills
similar to this
we have heard about incidents like this
happening in our state and currently if
you look at the definition of police
misconduct
well uh while we cover a series of uh of
of things that that constitute
misconduct unfortunately these things
are not are not represented in there
um misrepresentation of of facts and and
provable misidentification of a person
in a police report may not seem like uh
a very big deal when you compare it to
things like assault and tampering with
evidence and witness tampering and
things like that but when these things
do happen and when they do come to light
they chip away at The credibility of
police and I think this is a time when
as much as we can we need to be building
up that credibility and and sometimes we
need to do systemic changes like this to
actually help things along so this is
not an attempt to hurt police or to
punish police it's simply a an attempt
to establish clearer and more focused
guard rails around what is acceptable
conduct and what is not acceptable
conduct for a police officer
I do not expect that this bill is going
to result in a flood of misconduct cases
for these for these reasons and again
the reason is I think the vast majority
of our police officer would never even
think of doing things like this
but unfortunately
some of the ones who would might think
of not only doing these things but might
think of doing some of the other things
that constitute misconduct as well uh
and and essentially I think one of the
things that we sometimes find is that
small violations have a way of becoming
bigger issues and potentially bigger
violations uh later unless Behavior like
this is actively discouraged and there
are consequences for it when it happens
so again
this is uh this bill is uh is really
designed uh I think to help improve The
credibility of our police I think it's
very much in line of some of the other
things that we've been doing since
governor sununu
excuse me
assigned the police reform legislation
excuse me in 2021
and I would urge you to vote out to pass
and if I don't choke I will answer some
questions
thank you could could you give the
comedian an example of um the the
misidentifying portion of this
yeah this is this is something that uh
Joseph has mentioned several times in
his testimony on different on various
bills that have been front of us most of
them involving racial profiling uh it
was an incident of racial profiling
um that that he was involved with as a
as a victim uh where he said uh where he
he basically told us that afterwards the
police officer who recorded the incident
um recorded him as being white
and so during a time when we have other
bills in front of us that would you know
where we're looking at things like
requiring um a change to Driver's
Licenses to make
um listing of race and ethnicity
optional it's it's it's important that
once we decide how we're going to start
Gathering that data that were accurate
about how we do it and I know one of the
questions that's come up in the context
of those bills is how do you enforce it
well one way to enforce it is to make it
actionable misconduct you know when you
intentionally
misidentify a person so that's really
do you believe that it should be tied to
the other portion passing where someone
has the option of identifying themselves
so it's not up to the opposite of the
guess in other words we don't want to
punish officers for making a wrong guess
about someone's identity their ethnic
background so if the person has an
opportunity to identify themselves and
then the officer intentionally
disregards that that I think would speak
to what you're talking about but if the
officer doesn't know and makes a wrong
guess we wouldn't want to make them
liable would we so you're absolutely
right it would it would have the most
impact if we passed the changes to our
driver's license law if we if we pass
the bill that basically prohibits racial
profiling by law enforcement and we pass
this bill the three bills together would
have the most impact
unfortunately we all know that's not the
way the New Hampshire legislature always
works and so one of the things that we
deal with in all kinds of legislation
from this kind of legislation to
legislation around the environment
is that sometimes we need to address an
issue in in pieces which was the reason
for three separate bills instead of one
bill altogether
um and and really hope that we can make
an effective case for each one of those
um and if we can those bills will get
passed if we can't
um then we will have to try again later
um but uh that's basically
that was basically our strategy in doing
it this way
thank you
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um this bill modifies the definition of
misconduct I assume misconduct would
then you'd be guilty of
improper of misconduct
and I haven't read the law that is being
modified but somewhere else in that law
there is the definition of the
punishments for yeah I can read you the
current definition of misconduct uh
income definition there is a penalty
Associated maybe is there a penalty
associated with that and is that part of
the law that is quoted here you could
find that penalty in the law
there there's a there is a process uh
for reporting incidents like this
um and uh uh this is not a criminal it's
it's not a criminal penalty the the the
danger as I understand it or the
consequences I understand it is the
potential loss of certification
um uh that from what else what I also
understand that doesn't always happen uh
there are warnings that are issued at
times
um I think
um
you know for
I think one of the things that uh police
standards in training does a a very good
job of is taking circumstances into
account
um so that I don't think anyone would be
drummed out of their Department
um for doing this one time or something
you know or something like that unlike
some of the other things in the
definition of misconduct so things like
assaulting people tampering with
evidence
um those are those are much more serious
and and I would imagine that from a
certification perspective they would be
dealt with in a much more serious way
thank you representative scitec
yes um representative Muse
um a little bit something a little bit
slippery you were talked about uh
racial profiling and but I'm considering
a driver's license is racial
identification the profiling means I'm
picking I'm picking on you you don't I
don't see the the bill seems pretty
reasonable I haven't heard from uh law
enforcement but I did want to mention
that profiling and identification are
different in my mind the question I have
is you have demonstrable is there a
couple things occur to me should there
be an intentional in there because look
I write cbpos and I saw a guy I don't
know how to identify him I wound up
writing medium I didn't know what to say
but I wasn't trying to be
the other thing is what happens what
recourse does the police do the police
have if the guy
wants to be difficult and to identify as
being something else and it's clearly
not there does please have an
opportunity to this is the situation
I don't know how to ask my question
thanks well I think what we're what
we're what you're what you're kind of
getting at is
um in in the way I would answer your
question is is is if an uh kind of in
the way that we tell people if you see
something say something that's basically
what we're telling uh other law
enforcement officers to do if they
notice this kind of contact in a
colleague like other forms of misconduct
this would be something that they have a
duty uh to report up the chain
in in terms of the use of the word uh
demonstrable and uh it's interesting
before my testimony I actually kind of
was looking through the bill saying gee
are there any words in there that may
prove a little problematic
um and one of the things that I did was
I I actually looked up the uh the
definition and demonstrable means uh
clearly apparent or approvable
and major Ebert offline uh before the
hearing started actually brought up
exactly the same issue around
intentional that you did I think that is
something you know we'd be more than
willing to look at as a change uh uh I
think sometimes as a committee we've
we've kind of gotten wrapped around the
axle with using the word intentional
because proving intent
can can be difficult but I think the
issue here is we wouldn't want somebody
who just records uh this data by a
mistake especially given the fact that a
lot my understanding is currently for a
recipe it's for recorded in a drop down
menu
and having used a few drop down menus
over the years myself I know how easy it
is to make a mistake so I so I think
your point is well taken and that would
and I would hope that would be something
that the committee would consider
looking at as well
I think if I made Dean to speak for
representative scitec he was also asking
if you have a suspect who um who's
clearly a Caucasian and says I identify
as African-American and the officer
writes down Caucasian because that's
what he observably is is there any kind
of a contemplation about how how that
I I think I think part of it gets to uh
it actually may get to intent so you
know what is what is you know is this is
this a mistake why is why did this why
did this happen I think the you know the
issue is is if you see it happen
um it should be reported so that that
shouldn't be uh in like the other forms
of misconduct the expectation would be
that if this is something that another
police officer observes or someone else
in the department it would be reported
and like any anything there can be a
perfectly logical reasonable explanation
for it that would come up during a
hearing or come up with the chief or
come up during some part of the process
so
um again
you know what we're what we're really
trying to do here is to you know to do a
couple of things
um we want to make sure that
misrepresentation of material facts in a
report which is I don't think anything
uh any
police officer or any any law
enforcement official would would ever
condone
um then we're just making sure that that
is added to our uh our standards for
misconduct
um the the misidentification of racer
ethnicity uh maybe a little bit of a
stretch for now given the fact that we
actually don't have a a
a An approved data Gathering mechanism
for that in place when it comes to stops
however I do believe that for arrests we
do but that's that's also something
where there's a lot less incentive to uh
to put in uh information that wouldn't
representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman so you mentioned
um a few times about if you see
something say something but the bill
makes no mention of that if you see
something say something so
um my if I reading this my understanding
is if there is a question about
misidentification of race or race or
ethnicity it would be from the person
um the defendant themselves so what
you're saying is this bill is expecting
police officers to assume intent of
another police officer and file a
complaint am I correct
um
this is part of the issue with the bills
the way that we get them so
my bill only makes a material change to
part one of the statute there's also a
part two a part three and a part four
and the part two gets into what I've
discussed about the duty of other law
enforcement officers to report this when
they see it
so this is a Section 105 colon colon 19.
in other words it's already in statute
that an officer has to report
representative Mania
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking taking my question do you know if
this would trigger the officer being
added to the Lorry list I'm sorry could
you speak into your mic do you know if
this would trigger the officer being
added to the Lorry list a violist of the
statute
if it would trigger I'm sorry them being
added to the Lorry list in New Hampshire
added to the Lorry list if it is if it
is a form of police misconduct my
understanding of the way that the of
that that list works is it it could be
that actually isn't an issue that I have
have thought through probably as well as
I should but um but I would say it's
distinct possibility given the way the
the chair recognizes John bryoph John
Bry fonsky
don't be sorry it comes out a lot worse
than a lot of other pieces
well good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is John
brofonski I'm the current chief of
police in Bedford New Hampshire
for more than 11 years I've been
continuously serving in law enforcement
throughout the country for almost 45
years
part of that duties involved being an
inspector and Deputy Chief Inspector and
in charge of internal affairs for DEA
worldwide for a number of years which
means that I have a lot of experience in
misconduct cases
I'm here representing the New Hampshire
Association Chiefs of police who are
opposed to this bill
but we're not opposed to honesty
integrity and ethical conduct of law
enforcement officers that is in fact the
Bedrock upon which law enforcement here
in the granite state and everywhere
actually is based honesty Integrity is
critical to maintaining the public trust
and confidence in law enforcement and
you members of the legislature so uh it
is uh odd that we would be opposed to uh
this particular language but we're
opposed to it simply because it's
duplicated in our view and it is uh
vague and would cast a wide net uh if
you will and it's ill-defined so for
those reasons we're opposed to the bill
so let's take it apart piece by piece
first of all currently under state law
RSA 641 colon 1 perjury 641 colon 2
which is uh falsification sworn
falsification 641 colon 3 is unsworn
falsification now with respect to police
reports 641 colon 3 which would which is
a misdemeanor if found guilty
of that particular crime would cover
falsification of information on a police
report misrepresentation
is language that if it were defined as
intentional
misrepresentation of a material
misstatement effect which would fall
under the 640 641 colon 3 other already
is currently in law prohibition and a
crime of that makes it a misdemeanor to
commit that act in addition the policies
and procedures of the New Hampshire
police training Council which governs
the certification of Law Enforcement
Officers here in the granite state also
makes making a false statement which
includes a material misstatement effect
which is defined as making a statement
knowing that it is not true so
essentially false statement is in fact
sworn and unsworn falsification of
information
if the bill were to Define an
intentional intentional material
misrepresentation of fact we would not
be opposed to that particular language
because an intentional is clearly
defines as the act that the law
enforcement officer made was intentional
that there's culpability a culpable
State of Mind to deceive an official in
connection with filing a false report
with respect to the misidentification of
an individual for race and ethnic
ethnicity the first and foremost problem
is that uh oftentimes unless the
individual him or herself
self-identifies to the officer there are
many many cases which you can I'm sure
uh conjure up in your mind whether it's
respect to people that you know
celebrities athletes and so forth in
which an individual's race and ethnicity
is not always clearly identifiable
currently if there were to be a
requirement
for individuals to self-identify on
their New Hampshire driver's license
that particular mystery would be solved
but currently that is not the case so
therefore there would be a number of
cases in which an officer may make a
guess based on his or her worldly
experience right there's no class in the
police academy that helps officers
identify race and ethnicity right and
it's not clear to people to you and I so
that would wrap police officers into a
misconduct matter for which they did
nothing outside of their
scope of their duties and
responsibilities and would not be in
violation of their ethical conduct they
simply made an informed decision and
guess and it was wrong so we would be
opposed to this bill for for these and
many reasons I have written testimony
that I will give to the members of the
committee after I'm done but again those
are the major tenants and issues that
that we face in this particular Bill
given the language thank you for taking
traffic
stop you're not given a ticket but on a
traffic stop today
officers can put whether they're black
white or whatever on their ticket when
they file their report you know as law
enforcement
so if that's the case and someone says
let's say they stop me and I'm obviously
identified as a black female
but on that report it says I'm a white
female
so today do you have anything in place
that deals with that type of situation
yes that's uh that would be misconduct
um in Bedford Police Department and when
officers stop someone they have to issue
even if it's a warning uh they issue a
written warning and and on that written
warning is uh demographic information
with respect to the operator of the
motor vehicle uh if it comes to our
attention that an officer intentionally
or unintentional we don't know until
there's an investigation clearly places
information on that ticket that is
inaccurate and in the case that you just
described if that were to be the case
uh and a internal affairs investigation
was conducted and interviewed you
clearly identified your race and
ethnicity as being inconsistent with
what was written on the report that's
making a false statement that officer
would be subject to misconduct
allegations would likely be fired by me
and perhaps face a criminal charge and
misdemeanor charge and likely be subject
to losing his or her certification as a
law enforcement officer
follow up
okay so given the case of myself that I
just mentioned then um and I filed a
complaint with you
am I notified as to what happened
in that situation you can certainly
request that information via 91a once
the investigation is complete
um those reports
um of misconduct investigations that I
um
have released to the public and some of
which are in the union leader are
subject to redaction based on the
attorneys that are hired by the
municipality to follow the the rules and
regulations of 91a but yes you would you
would ultimately find out what occurred
could you just clarify for me
um in testimony we had over this issue
of profiling and race
um I I was of the impression that it's
not required on a driver's license it's
not on a driver's license and that there
was difficulty in determining the race
and and all those kind of things
is is there a requirement like it
sounded to me like your testimony was
that in that example even if they got a
warning there was a there was somewhere
on what they report for warnings and
traffic stops that the race has to be
recorded is that or am I
misunderstanding that there's
information there's demographic
information that our records and
management system requires the officer
to input so that we obtain demographic
data on Motor Vehicle stops including
warnings right so that demographic
information is there we run those
reports on a routine basis consistent
with accreditation standards to ensure
that the department is following its
policies and procedures
representative Murphy
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question can you tell me I'm separate
from warnings or like the issuing of a
ticket is there documentation of every
stop regardless of whether or not uh
like a warning or you know if nothing if
if I'm pulled over
um and for whatever I don't wind up
getting a warning or a ticket is there a
record of me being pulled over and if so
is there documentation as to the the
um you know the race and and
Etc
if there's no summons issued and there's
no written warning issue there still is
a record of the motor vehicle stop uh in
the Department's computer-rated dispatch
system that would include the data that
is included on your motor vehicle
operator's license right so that would
be the data that would be reflected in
that particular case
and of course uh
individuals are not required to submit
data with respect to race and ethnicity
on their driver's license and that's
where the problem of subjectivity comes
into play right without
self-identification in many many cases
officers guess and when they're not
certain right they're they're simply
going to place unknown
right and so that's typically what
occurs when an officer is not able to uh
factually discern with ease the race and
ethnicity of an individual it's listed
in the database as unknown right so
that's that's where we come into the
thank you but if I just want to clarify
so I understand so on um in the instance
where I was we've pulled over and not
given a ticket or a warning and the the
there is a record made with the whatever
information is on my driver's license
there is no as as there's no race
designation on my license that's not
part of the the the record correct okay
thank you for your testimony thank you
chair recognizes Marco Dwayne of the New
Hampshire Troopers Association in New
I was going to say good morning but I
guess it's good afternoon I think we
just went over the notch there into the
noon so my name is Mark Bodwin I am a
retired sergeant from the New Hampshire
State Police and I'm here to speak in
opposition to uh this bill uh and just
so uh for the beginning of this
um we're not opposed to the idea of the
bill which is what reporting misconduct
to uh you know supervisors that you
might see a fellow police officers the
only issue we have with the bill is and
I think we've talked a little bit about
it here before is where it says a
misrepresentation of a material fact and
a police report
it's our belief that the word
intentional should be in front of
misrepresentation because if I put
something into a police report that I
misperceive something and it actually is
incorrect but I didn't do it on purpose
we don't want to hold that police
officer accountable for that honest
mistake
um and the same thing for I think with
the misidentification of race I think
that that has to be an intentional
misrepresentation as well uh because I
think uh you know you've tried to parse
that out a little bit here with the
prior Witnesses but again you know a lot
of uh these uh are now going to more
computerized uh warnings when I first
started it was handwritten and there
wasn't any place in super State Police
anywhere to put you know what the race
of the person was on the handwritten um
uh warnings uh now it's all computerized
and with computerized they try to make
it easy for you which includes drop down
menus and if you accidentally select the
wrong one and you didn't notice it and
you kept going to the next box we don't
want to hold a a police officer or at
least I don't think you want to hold a
police officer accountable for that but
at the end of the day what you're
looking to do is you're looking for
those officers to report these
intentional infractions that they see
their fellow officers doing to their
supervisors and then I think that
there's also other statues as you heard
the chief speak to that can play a role
behind the scenes afterwards to also
include 106 L colon 2 which is the
misconduct uh uh with the police stands
and training Council where you're
brought in front of them for your
certification status
uh so with that I want to keep it brief
so our only concern was the words
intentional in front of both of those
sections and with that I'd be happy to
take any questions you might have
representative Rhodes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question if if an officer was
made aware
that the wrong waste was was put on the
person comes in front of you and you can
clearly see that would it be corrected
and would it be noted yes
thank you for your testimony thank you
have a good afternoon you as well
feel as though I'm at a disadvantage
anytime I'm testifying afternoon
so I will keep this very brief my name
is Joe Ebert it's e-b-e-r-t I am a major
with the state police overseeing the
Investigative Services Bureau Chief
profansky retired Sergeant potum brought
up the same issues that I was going to
address with the committee so I will
keep this very brief but it I think the
the bill itself very well intentioned uh
in speaking with representative Muse is
no doubt in my mind that he is looking
to address an issue that he sees and
he's looking to do that with the best
intentions in mind uh the concern I had
was the term demonstrable I did I like
the representative I looked that up it's
not a term that we typically see in
legal jargon so clearly apparent or
capable of being logically proved and my
concern with that is uh if you look at a
report in which somebody does select the
wrong drop down uh is it clearly
apparent it is clearly apparent is it
readily provable absolutely you can
prove that the person chose that because
you can see that they filed that report
so I think that sets up a scenario where
that's an administrative error that
should be dealt with and internally in
that police department and it is on a
regular basis we deal with our Troopers
and we say Hey listen we've reviewed
your report we see that you have made an
error in that report you need to be more
keenly aware of what it is that you're
doing
having said that I think that changing
if the committee were open to the uh the
possibility of changing this uh this RSA
or this bill to read intentional
misrepresentation of a fact in a police
report
there's no doubt in our mind that
intentionally uh misrepresenting a fact
in a police report is misconduct that's
not something we would tolerate I think
the chief addressed that that is already
in statute as a a prosecutable crime and
we wanted to come out in
significant support of that notion and
we didn't want to leave I left on my uh
my card I left it as no position no
position because I did not want to come
in an opposition to a bill such as this
where I know it's very very very well
intentioned but we would have trouble
supporting it we're not uh word to move
forward with the demonstrable
terminology in there as it relates to
the race and ethnicity
I think that that was addressed by the
the chief I think that is likely best
left uh not identified in this
particular Bill until the credentialing
of race is determined whether it's in
this committee or by the legislative
body as a whole
but again I think it's covered by the
notion that if you intentionally
misrepresent a fact in a police report
that covers uh the race and ethnicity of
that person as well
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
representative Newell
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I just am wondering
we're talking about like a clerical
error right a drop down menu has that
example has been used and I'm I'm hoping
this is just because I haven't gotten a
ticket in a while but I don't remember
those uh a ticket that's being written
on the spot is actually being written
not entered into a computer am I right
or am I have I just has it been a while
I thank you very much for the question
and uh congratulations on uh not making
the acquaintance of Troopers lately uh
so uh it has been a long time since I've
written a summons uh but what I can tell
you is that uh there is a change to a
computerized system where uh the the
license is actually scanned at this
point the information populates in a uh
a summons is printed with that
information that comes from the scanned
license so are there still departments
that are handwriting the information in
yes there are but I know for the vast
majority of Troopers that is done in a
computerized mechanism
thank you
representative Newman
I I just have a question about the RSA
and the intention of the RSA I think
we're spending a lot of time on the
first section that that changes the
definition and tries to Define
misconduct
and we might be ignoring the rest of the
bill and and it's in the section that it
says reports of misconduct by law
enforcement offices and and I'll just
read the first sentence of section
number two it says it shall be the duty
of any law enforcement officer who
observes misconduct by any uh by another
law enforcement officer to notify notify
the chief law enforcement enforcement
officer of his or her Department in
writing immediately or as soon as
practical will after observing such
misconduct then the rest of the law
talks about what happens after that
so I think that even if the definition
is not quite understood if the person
perceives to have seen misconduct I
think this law is just trying to get
people to report that misconduct within
their Department without any penalty
it's civil so I'm I'm not sure that
we're approaching this from the right
direction and if you have any comment
so I wanted to take a second to collect
my thoughts there because I want to make
sure that I address this in the uh uh in
the best possible way uh
I think by
I don't think this was your intention
but by saying that this was uh this is a
civil process that it's just a review
process I think that's downplaying uh
what is being alleged in a misconduct
allegation so I I don't think that any
allegation of misconduct it was
discussed earlier that well there is a
remedy by which you go through a process
and you would be able to say uh listen
this was an honest mistake and maybe
that's borne out and uh the the hearing
is found that
um you know you didn't intentionally do
something I would submit to you that
going through that process for what
could be a clerical error
or uh anything other than intentionally
done would be I think a detriment to the
morale of law enforcement we want to
hold law enforcement absolutely
accountable for actions that they're
intentionally doing
for actions that are them being human
beings that should be in in our opinion
that should be dealt with within the
agency that they work for
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
anyone else wishing to testify who has
not submitted a pink card
seeing Nana hereby close the public
hearing on HP 156 and open to public
hearing on HP 376
and recognize the prime sponsor to
anyone
okay represent Pratt will do it for
thank you
representative Troy here is a not only a
representative but he's also a police
officer he's in court today so I'm going
to present his bill I have some
knowledge on it but not complete
knowledge
but I do know those people behind us
that represent uh Elijah communication
centers in the state that will have a
lot more information for us
so this bill is a um establishes a
committee and they study the current
education training requirements for
personnel employed as emergency
dispatches 9-1-1 telecommunicators for
police via an emergency medical
organizations
lines three through ten is a makeup of
the membership of the committee
you can read that and then lines 11
through 20 is a committee's duties and
what they're going to be doing when
they're put together
and they have to start within 45 days
and at the end they have to report so
lines 21-24 they're going to report to
the speaker of the house before November
any questions
can you tell us the impetus for this
bill what
um this is brought forth by um he's a
police officer and the other fellow is
also in emergency services and
basically across the state of New
Hampshire the training of dispatches and
Communications people is different in
almost every community of every dispatch
area there is some things like Power
phone that is a training organization
that most of them use but not all of
them so it's kind of looking at all the
training that all these people use to
see if there's some way of having a
standardized type of training that all
of them would be using the same thing
and to see what level training
everybody's doing and of course the
communications difference for police
fire and ambulance service so there's
medical trainings some dispatches get
medical training and do medical uh over
the phone
some don't so so I think they're trying
to find some uniformity or some
standard the policemen the firemen they
have standardized training so the state
through the state of New Hampshire
but dispatching Communications is kind
of open right now
representative Newell
um I'm I'm wondering if oh thank you I'm
sorry thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm wondering if
there is a concern with the current
standard or what what is the status of
the standards that we have now
I think most of the communications do a
great job it's just a little bit
different and I think they may be
looking for a certification or maybe
looking for a standardization in the
training that you get okay so just to
clarify currently there is not a a
standard for that is for the entire
State what we're trying to do is just
make sure that we have uniformity
correct okay thanks yeah uh police and
fire they have their standards through
the both of the academies and dispatch
doesn't even have an academy so it's a
if you take makers thank you for your
testimony
oh I'm sorry did you want to ask him a
question I'm sorry
as anyone here who has to testify who
if you want to testify you have to pull
up one of those pink oh yeah you got to
give that to us otherwise I I have no
foreign
thank you to chair recognizes Mark Doyle
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I appreciate you giving us the
opportunity to speak with you
briefly I hope this afternoon to talk a
little bit about the bill which is in
front of you to establish a committee to
study the standards and training and
certifications at all associated with
Public Safety dispatchers and
telecommunicators across the state it
was already alluded to that there's a
lack of consistency when it comes to
um
acceptable and mandatory trainings and
certifications for a public safety
dispatch Communications Personnel I've
been in the public safety field going on
39 years now both as a police chief in
the law enforcement side of the house
and as well as my current position as
the Director of the division of
emergency services and Communications
here with the New Hampshire Department
of Safety in my current role I oversee
the 9-1-1 system in the state of New
Hampshire
having worked in that role currently and
in my previous life I've had the
opportunity to see an evolution of
training when it comes to
standardization in both the Fire EMS and
as well as the law enforcement worlds
and that continues there's a number of
standards that law enforcement officers
that fire service Personnel Emergency
Medical Services Personnel have to
continually meet to maintain their
certifications and credentials as well
as to get their foot in the door to
become certified in those respective
professions and that's what we're
talking about today our personnel as
Public Safety dispatchers and Public
Safety telecommunicators are no
different when it comes to the
profession that they represent and in
terms of that profession we need to make
sure that they're as well trained and as
well credentialed in many respects when
it comes to the Life Safety Services
that they render every single day of the
week they are in many respects
considered our first First Responders
they're the first people that you handle
with and communicate with and they
conduct warm transfers to a publicity
Public Safety communications center
personnel which are located across the
state who in turn make sure that that
information that those services are
rendered to our Public Safety First
Responders in the field whether they're
police fire or EMS Services Personnel to
render safety when and where it's needed
everyone in that Communications
Continuum shares the same Mission it's
to locate communicate connect people in
an emergency with the help that they
need when and where they need it and
it's so critical to make sure that we're
not skipping a beat and don't get me
wrong when I say that there's a lack of
standardization that equates to a lack
of training that's not the case you will
find should this bill pass as you
conduct your research that the data you
receive will show some marked
differences in the level of training
across the state depending upon a number
of things of course cost time involved
standards and requirements associated
with those respective agencies that have
different Scopes and responsibilities
and I bring that up because you might be
asking about what is that
differentiation much of it has to do
with the role and scope of the
responsibility of the communications
center that you as a person as a citizen
as a resident or visitor to this state
has to interact with or engage with I'll
give you an example and I have
colleagues behind me that will talk to
their respective agencies and what they
do at 9-1-1 we are a call reconciliation
agency we are what we consider a
transfer agency every 9-1-1 call that's
initiated in this state or hits a cell
tower in this state goes to our Public
Safety answering point it does not go to
your local Communication Center and a
lot of folks don't realize that the
person they're talking with is located
in one of two locations here and those
folks have standards that they must meet
that are
foundationally built into administrative
rules so that when they come out of
their training which can last up to 16
weeks they all have that same level of
training they all have that same level
of credentialing and they have to
maintain that training and certification
based upon the accreditation standards
that we have to comply with because we
are an internationally accredited
emergency medical dispatch agency we
also comply with in terms of our
training and our recruits when they go
through training and complete their
training APCO certification which is the
association of public Communications
officials across the country
so we're making sure that our standards
our consistent level of training is the
same level of training that everyone
gets in the state regardless of where
they are
or when they call 9-1-1
what we end up doing when we get that
call whether it's a police fire or EMS
call depends on the nature of the call
those calls are all transferred but some
are held on to our telecommunicators
because we also provided a value-added
service to that Communications piece and
to the people in the field who need
immediate
assistance first aid and for people who
are on scene to render patient care we
will then conduct an emergency medical
dispatch triage based upon established
protocol again pursuant and compliant
with our accreditation standards to
render assistance to folks in the field
prior to the arrival of First Responders
we stay on the phone with those
individuals as long as it takes
sometimes that could take up to an hour
or more
before First Responders arrive on the
scene during that period of time that
transfer is already made Downstream to
the local communications center so those
folks can then transfer that valuable
information and give First Responders in
the field time and minute by minute and
second by second in some cases updates
to what's happening because we still
have a connection with those folks that
are in the field we do not do radio
dispatch at 9-1-1 we're not dispatching
police officers we're not dispatching
firefighters we're not dispatching
Emergency Medical Services Personnel or
ambulances to a scene we leave that to
the 67 communication centers that we
actually have a live connection with 24
7 365 days a year
when I talk about the level of
standardization and level of consistency
it's based upon the need to make sure
that the only the highest level in
quality of service that our
telecommunicators rendered is the same
across the board regardless of where you
might be when you make that 9-1-1 call
that's not to say that that's the same
case everywhere else if you don't make
that call to 9-1-1 but you reach out to
your local police department or
sheriff's department or other
communications center because you need
help that may not be an emergency yet
it's still going to require a police a
fire or Emergency Medical Services
response now that's not to say again
that the training is any less or
non-existent again it all depends on the
nature and scope of the training but
there should be some minimum standards
that are established across the board
when it comes to
the expectations that our citizens and
residents have of all of our Public
Safety First Responders and again our
telecommunications Personnel whether at
the 911 Center or the weather in your
local Communications centers are the
first First Responders and we require of
them to maintain the only highest degree
of professionalism
and talent
and continuing education and training we
do the folks behind me do and you should
expect no less and that's why I'm in
support of this bill because if nothing
else comes out of this it's going to be
some transparent look at what it is that
we're doing across the state to try to
make sure that we're rendering only the
highest level and quality of service
that not only our citizens expect but
also deserve
I have testimony as well from Cecily
McNair that'll be able to pass out
Cecily is a long-standing 40-year
veteran of our Public Safety dispatch
community and I also have testimony that
I'd be more than happy to email because
it has some hyperlinks in it that might
be helpful to you as you start to do a
little bit more research and I am
available for any questions that you
might have
thank you for that in-depth testimony
um I noticed that the bills requesting a
study committee
do you think that this in-depth look is
something that could be finished between
you know now or actually between July
and September or do you think that it
would be better off to be made a
commission with a Sunset date
um that would Sunset after
um the study was finished
as I read the bill there's a lot in the
bill that you should be looking into
that will take some time but you do have
a lot of folks here in the room and out
there in the telecommunicator public
safety dispatch
Consortium that are willing to step up
and help an assist in any way that we we
can so it's not to say that you won't
get that level of cooperation we're
ready to serve do whatever is we need
um I don't know if I'm the best person
to ask of that because I think it would
all depend upon the resource
restrictions that you folks would have
as well I I just don't want to sell the
the issue short because when things are
committees we have to have an answer out
by the fall and if we aren't done at
work it's not going to do it justice
understood thank you for the question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
I'm just looking at the definite of the
words in line two and three of the uh
the bill that says emergency Dispatchers
in 911 telecommunic caters
and can you just tell me the
differentiation one is your set of folks
and one is the uh the set of folks that
are associated with the people behind
you in simplistic terms that's exactly
the case and when we talk about 9-1-1
telecommunicators they're call
receptionists they're reconciling
reconciling 9-1-1 calls 9-1-1 calls do
not go to your local public safety
communications center if you are in I'll
use my own example if you're on the town
of Merrimack and uh for years I was a
law enforcement officer in Merrimack we
have our own Public Safety
communications center that dispatches
for police fire and Emergency Medical
Services
we were also connected by virtue of the
larger Network that our division
currently here at the division of
Emergency Services Communications have
set up so that when we do a transfer we
transfer that call once we receive it at
9-1-1 to the local communications center
they do the physical dispatch along with
a number of other things that depending
upon the role and scope of that Dispatch
Center would also do in addition to
receiving the 9-1-1 call and all of the
data that flows along with it
follow up
follow up and I believe you talked about
staying on the phone for an hour and
dispatching additional information to
the person that made the call
is that in both of those places and do
they transfer information or how does
that work
anecdotally we have a number of cases
where as you know New Hampshire is a
diverse State meaning there are a lot of
geographical and topographical issues
associated with the nature and
timeliness of a response for example the
time that you're going to get in in
terms of a response within the city of
Manchester or the city of Nashua or an
urban area is going to be markedly
different than it would in an area
that's
a little less served from the public
safety
perspective such as in the town of
Colebrook or in Grafton County for
example and that's not to say because
that they are any less equipped but they
have fewer resources to allocate but
there may be occasions where we're on a
9-1-1 call where we're rendering patient
care during that time it takes for an
individual to arrive whether it's a
police officer whether it's a
firefighter whether it's emerging
Medical Services personnel and some of
those calls can last many minutes some
of those calls can actually last if it's
our search and rescue and we've had
these occur where they've lasted several
hours we've stayed on a phone with
somebody in the field for a few hours
waiting for an emergency rescue
chair recognizes excuse me leave the
testimony here or you could bring it up
to the
excuse me good afternoon Mr chairman
my name is John golden I'm the chief of
the Lakes Region Mutual fire Aid
District based in Laconia New Hampshire
I'm speaking in support of house bill
376.
I'm also the president of the New
Hampshire emergency dispatchers
Association
Lakes Region Mutual fire Aid is a fire
Mutual Aid District comprising of 1800
square miles protecting 35 communities
in one of the most heavily recreated
areas of the state lrmfa is Staff
profession by professionally trained
emergency communications personnel
because as an agency we believe in
training and developing our team members
commensurate with their level of Public
Safety responsibility
there are currently no training or
certification requirements to perform
the work of New Hampshire's Public
Safety telecommunicators or dispatchers
some agencies like mine go above and
beyond and others provide minimal
training at best for their personnel
on any given day and at any given time
Public Safety telecommunicators and
Dispatchers in New Hampshire including
the team at lrmfa are making critical
life-saving decisions regarding the
safety and response for the public and
our state's First Responders
they're managing multiple emergency
response resources throughout the state
oftentimes simultaneously with multiple
life and death emergencies occurring at
the same time
there's currently no state standard
regarding the level of training or
certification that these men and women
must undertake to perform these job
functions that are vital to New
Hampshire's Public Safety success
some agencies offer minimal training
before their telecommunicators or
some agencies provide extensive training
like mine
in my 27 years of professional Public
Safety Communications experience and as
a leader in this profession not only in
New Hampshire the region and nationally
I believe strongly in National standards
and best practices as they relate to
emergency dispatching
lrmfa is one of only three agencies in
the state that have voluntarily
submitted their new hire and continuing
education training programs to the
association of Public Safety
Communications officials which is APCO
for their agency training program
certification APCO atpc is an American
National standards Institute standard of
certification of an agency's training
program that certifies 111 individual
standards have been met or exceeded
pertaining to the national minimum
acceptable standard
which does exist nationally
as a state we train our police officers
and our firefighters to a Statewide
standard so that they're trained the
same and the expectation of service from
the public
with such a disparity in public safety
telecommunicator training and dispatcher
training in New Hampshire I believe that
we're doing a disservice to the public
and the Public Safety First Responders
we all go to barber shops or salons for
service such as colors haircuts hair
styling my wife's a hairdresser so I I
can speak to it she went through 1500
hours of training and schooling before
she could submit to the Board of
Professional licensure to be licensed as
a hairdresser but there's no regulation
regarding training for New Hampshire's
first First Responders
I strongly believe this is a subject
that should be studied to determine if
we are in fact providing the utmost
professional Public Safety and emergency
services to our state's residents
visitors and public safety personnel
again I am in support of the Bill thank
you for your time and I'm happy to
thank you for your testimony
are you envisioning some type of an
academy style training or are you what
do you put your folks through new hires
so the 111 standards that APCO has has
deemed to be the minimum acceptable
level of training nationally now
obviously those aren't recognized in
this state there are states they are
recognized in
my staff goes through about a 12 to 14
week training period there's organized
course structure the certifications that
they have to obtain
obviously there's on the job training
that they have to that that they go
through eventually when they're when
they're um capable and have passed all
of that requisite training they're
released from training in such in such a
way that they can now effectively work
um they are never my staff is never
allowed to work
um
we have two people on duty 24 7. so my
staff is never part of that Staffing
Matrix until they've successfully
completed the program
and
do you have an approximate because what
we in other words what will this cause
municipality to adopt this
per per service that's a great question
and and if I could go back and I didn't
fully answer your previous question what
I would Envision is is is a standard
probably meeting or exceeding what's
already existing at the national level
that the state adopts
I would love to see an academy style
I've written new articles for for
journals on that
um I would love to see that I don't know
that we're there what what would
probably be more palatable is here's the
standard that your agency needs to to
meet they're the the dispatch world is
is
as small if not smaller than public
State than police and fire right there's
enough people in the state that are
active in this profession that could
offer whatever trainings need to be
offered I'm an instructor for one of
those courses that I think would be
absolutely important there's no reason
why we wouldn't build a Cadre of
instructors and I don't mean that you
need to meet the standard tomorrow
before you work maybe there's a
lead up time six months you know
something like that
um but I think that there's the ability
to to construct some sort of a standard
that that says you need to do this
in a reasonable amount of time I ask
because we have to be cognizant of of
our duties not to make unfunded mandates
so if we're going to propose something
we need to know how much it's going to
cost so I'm trying to and perhaps that
would be the point of the committee to
figure out what that what that would be
um further questions
Representative no
just thank the chair for addressing both
of my questions
and if I may the cost is obviously a
concern
my agency and and the previous agency so
the three agencies that I mentioned that
have this level of certification or
myself my agency uh New Hampshire 9-1-1
and dairy fire
um
because I my
governance structure if you will hired
me to to manage the agency they knew
that standards and best practices that's
that's my um my my bread and butter if
you will it's important I can tell you
my people do the best job but unless I'm
adhering to some sort of National
Standard or best practice I don't really
have direction to give them the tools to
do that I think it's important that that
sure
agencies absolutely
are there's going to be there's going to
be a need for for some sort of funding
right but we're already training our
people we're already doing some sort of
new hire trading this could just be an
expansion upon that this could be as
Staffing allows there's there's ways
that you can get around that
um
Cecily McNair whose testimony you have
in writing many many years ago actually
created a New Hampshire dispatcher
Academy
um and it was held typically at police
standards and training every year uh and
tons of people went and it was great it
was geared towards you know you can
teach somebody about dispatching in
Florida and it's very different than New
Hampshire because of the infrastructure
and how we do things but that particular
Academy if you will was it was a great
opportunity for for that Baseline level
of training I think it's important to
recognize we don't handle police officer
a set of keys a gun and a handcuff and
say go go enforce the law we don't
handle firemen keys to a fire truck and
say go put out fires we have an expected
level of service for them and I think
this third level of service if you will
this emergency communications component
we should absolutely expect the same
level of service and training
commensurate with the responsibility
that these Personnel are executing on a
daily basis
thank you what about do some departments
um in the state cross utilize in other
words they'll have police officers
handling some dispatch firefighters
handling some dispatch how would your
program take that into account or
there are absolutely some agencies that
do that
um there are some certainly on the fire
side that do that and and there may be
some on the police side
um
you know back many many years ago before
I realized that smoking was bad it was
not uncommon at the time to say hey can
you watch the desk for a few minutes I'm
going to step outside
in a perfect world I would love to say
no more right but I think you have to
give agencies some flexibility to manage
themselves I think this would be if this
is your primary job or your your part of
your if you're a firefighter or police
officer that's able to work in dispatch
not necessarily fill in for 10 minutes
while somebody goes to make a phone call
but you're going to sit there for a
shift or a period of time and be
expected to answer these these emergency
calls from the psap or from the public I
think you would have you should go
through this
thank you for your testimony thank you
oh
foreign
so to your knowledge most
departments that have a Dispatch Center
there I would have to say yes I mean
there has to be basic training and it it
could be as simple as this is how we put
calls on hold this is you know the rate
the button to transmit on the radio it
could be as simplistic as that when you
say basic training or it could be a 16
or 14 week training program when when I
first started in New Hampshire back
years ago I literally sat with the
senior dispatcher for 40 hours
and then on Saturday night I was told if
you don't kill anybody tonight you're
going to be on your own and you're going
to be released from training my very
first call was happened to be a stabbing
in a vestibule of a supermarket
I wasn't I did fine but I wasn't
prepared for that and and to what
director Doyle's point about Evolution
right that was 25 years ago the the
evolution
in the industry has changed to a point
where we shouldn't sit back any longer
and allow that here's the keys here's
the map
good luck
follow up follow up
so your idea is that if you're going to
do basic training
this should be the standard that you're
you're training them to every EMT basic
in the state of New Hampshire is trained
to the basic level of the National
Registry of EMTs
let's do that if an agency wants to
spend more money or create higher levels
of training or or
have their people go through higher
levels of training to make them more
proficient at
you can have a basic level of training
and then you could be really proficient
at law enforcement dispatch and really
proficient at firing EMS dispatch but
everybody should start with that basic
level
thank you thank you
thank you for your time
thank you chair and representatives I'm
Tom ambross I'm currently the director
of communications for the Grafton County
Sheriff's Department
as director Doyle referenced I'm one of
those rural folks who have to man manage
responses a little bit differently than
some other more populated places
I don't have uh I don't duplicate a lot
of the information you've already heard
from the director and the chief they've
done a great job in covering our
industry I am excited to look out to the
committee and see Public Safety folks
because I think you know that what we
are asking for here
um is the right thing and it could be a
good starting point
the public safety dispatch folks are the
only ones in public safety who don't
have formalized certification and
training
um those those that do police fire and
EMS the reality is they don't go
anywhere until our people tell them
where to go
um
I would like to highlight the very first
question that I heard of the very first
speaker
what is wrong with the current standard
is how I took the question
the answer is we have so
few standards to meet we cannot none of
us can tell you how many of us there are
today
that's how less
how little we track the public safety
Communications industry in our state I
think the study is the right thing to do
I think it's great that our industry is
asking for it and is supporting it I
believe that the associations of those
other disciplines who already enjoy
excellent training and certification
programs will support it
and
thank you for your testimony
is there anyone else who has not turned
in a pink card to wish to testify on
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on HP 376 and the
130.
foreign
okay
good afternoon one being 1 30 I will
open up the
public hearing for
for House Bill 481 relative to arrest
warrants and search warrants committee
recognizes representative yokilo am I
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee
um this bill uh HB 481 I'm here to
present to you today and it the purpose
of this is to essentially
um
uh allow for more clarity to the
decision makers and whether or not
search warrants and arrest warrants are
appropriate
um and and to not allow
um used in
um by by like judge shopping and going
from one judge and and asking for a
search warrant and then if it gets
denied going to another judge and that
other judge doesn't know that the the
another judge has previously denied the
request based on the same evidence
um and so what this would require is if
you're using
um if you uh request either a search
warrant or a arrest warrant with a
specific evidence and that request is
denied that if you request that a search
warrant or arrest warrant again that you
have to notify that judge or submit that
evidence that it was previously denied
so that the judge can make an informed
decision and maybe talk to the other
judge if if necessary about the reasons
why
um a specific warrant was denied and so
that that give gives that um
uh judge kind of like the understanding
that they could be able to have that
conversation with the other judge and
understand where what's going on with
this case
um also that if um
that in this bill it
the
that the state shall disclose
um that same information if they're
presenting information to the grand jury
so you can't go to the judge ask for an
arrest warrant it get denied and then go
to a grand jury and ask for
um
ask for charges without saying hey we've
gone with this evidence this exact same
evidence over to the grand jury and ask
for
um the the charges that way to kind of
circumvent the um
the judge's decision without and and be
able to do that without those the grand
jury knowing that that was the case so
representative Pro
thank you for the question
um I don't have I don't have that
statistics for you but more than zero
times and that's what's of concern to me
thank you
follow up
have you ever heard of it happening yes
I'm aware of at least one time and that
is
enough for enough of uh abuse of power
for me
representative Newman
thank you I'm just kind of scanning over
the language here and I and I read uh
paragraph number two
and I'm just curious it talks about
having one one uh request and then you
submit another request does the first
one have to be completed and adjudicated
and denied or or could this be happening
simultaneously that they're going to one
or more judges
thank you for the question
um I'm not sure the reason why they
would be asking for multiple uh
for the exact same person based on the
same evidence as if you're either gonna
arrest them or not but
um I don't think that this language will
require you to disclose that you've
requested it four times
um but you have not received any answer
back because maybe they want maybe that
judge is let's say not responsive or
whatever and they wanted to to talk to
someone that would be more responsive if
they haven't made a decision yet then I
don't see any reason why they would need
to this
um this is only saying that they um
uh
um so a
um
right
I'm not sure that the language is
reading it with your kind of your your
question in mind I'm not sure that it's
100 clear that because it does talk
about pending requests and you can you
just uh a state that dates that the
prior request was
um like the data for the request the
judge that reviewed it and the
particular evidence submitted and
whether or not the search warrant was
granted based on such evidence it
doesn't seem to say that you shouldn't
necessarily be required to disclose that
it was previously requested if you in
the example that I gave if you requested
four times
all listing all four but maybe they
wouldn't have the
um the whether or not it was decided
that last
um factoid I guess that's that's listed
in that sentence wouldn't be included
because you wouldn't have the answer to
that
um but
so I don't I'm not sure that it's clear
that you don't have to but I I would not
be opposed to them having to say like
yeah we requested it four times I'm not
sure why they would ever do that though
thank you for your answer yeah
I I have a question um I'm looking at
line 24 and 25 about the thousand dollar
fine would that be to
you know the department as a whole would
it be to the to the officer in charge
exactly what does that how does that how
would that come into effect
so the
the the uh it would be the law
enforcement officer that was violating
it right so on if you say like
um line 11
it's it's the lawn law enforcement
officer or the agency so so whoever is
the official like requesting it so if
it's coming from the agency I guess that
would that would be able to be not the
actual person but I don't think that
um I think it's more of the officer
that's that's requesting it in on behalf
of the agency and not the actual agency
requesting it but I'm sure officers will
be able to tell you as far as that but
my intention is just that if the officer
is knowingly violating the law
um that they get they get punished so if
they don't know that that the that the
information was
um previously used then they shouldn't
be held accountable but if they are
knowingly violating the law it should be
uh should be uh held accountable for
representative Newell
thank you madam Sharon thank you my
question so I think the way that I'm
reading it and correct me if I'm wrong
um this would be using this if it were
using the same information
um the judge who would be approving the
arrest warrant would know that as well
right so this wouldn't just be I mean
I would think that this would be beyond
the officer themselves is what I'm
saying so it's putting all the liability
on the officer but it seems in order for
this to for something like this to
happen
um it would kind of have to go through a
few different people at that point
thank you for the question so
in so like judge shopping is what is
kind of what what we're talking about is
like if you if the law enforcement
officers goes to judge a and the judge a
says this is not appropriate or you
don't have enough evidence go get more
evidence and then they use the exact
same information and go to judge B
I guess maybe this would be a question
for somebody else but you know for oh
I'm sorry okay sorry
um but
there would be a record of that right
you would follow the the process would
be there would be a record of that
process so judge shopping I would think
would be pretty difficult because it
would be on file that you had brought
the same evidence to the same person
what I'm what I'm trying to get at is in
order for something like this to
actually happen and accomplish what you
know if if someone had ill intent then
in order for them to do that I feel like
there would be checks before that in
order for that I'm sorry I'm not I'm not
posing the question right
I I'm sorry I mean wouldn't these things
be on record so that this wouldn't be
able to happen is my question thank you
for the question
um so we're when I'm talking about
different judges that it wouldn't
necessarily be this they wouldn't have
the knowledge because you would be going
to judge a versus judge B and so they
wouldn't necessarily have talked to each
other about that those different
requests
um however there is new technology
getting put in that that they're
requesting these more and more through
online portals and those
would essentially have some record of
the request being made but wouldn't
necessarily
um
may not document like what the actual
evidence was and so
um really it's the requesting officer
that would know like this is I I
requested this because I'm kind of the
lead on this case I've requested this
with this information and then I've
requested it again with the the same
information so okay thank you
representative Manion
thank you madam sure thank you for
taking my question
I've been in law enforcement for some
time and I'm a little bit confused as to
how this could happen
would you be able to speak to that one
specific incident about the facts of
that so I can understand how this could
um I think there will be other testimony
here today that that would be more
helpful as far as the line that line of
questioning
Sharon thank you for taking my question
uh
specifically in law right now
um
is we're not talking about just Circuit
Court judges issuing warrants
justices of the peace can do that so how
thank you for the question I believe
that
whether they're requesting it from a
Justice of the piece or they're
requesting it
through the Circuit Court I think the
requirement is the same for the law
enforcement to notify those people
either way
follow-up yes thank you um so I think
what I'm driving at is if you're dealing
with a police officer dealing uh
interacting with the justice of the
peace that is not uh using electronic
means they're not at the Circuit Court
they're not Circuit Court judges they're
talking to each other all the time and
you're talking about a Justice of the
Peace sitting at home so
how would you know that a police officer
had gone to several justices of the
piece rather than going to the circuit
court judge
I think that thank you for the question
I think that would be
um something that uh
would require investigations and and
um may not always may not always become
apparent unless
um
unless someone was doing some research
and and knew
um let's say that they knew the Justice
of the pieces or something like that
um they wouldn't there would need to be
an investigation I don't think that you
would just know
um
and so you would have to bring that that
evidence to the the D.A to to charge
or or the D.A do with the investigation
there you go
thank you
good afternoon thank you madam chairman
members committee thanks for allowing me
to speak here my name is Jason Smith I'm
a captain with the Salem Police
Department I've been full-time officer
in New Hampshire for over 25 years and
um the nhpa the New Hampshire Police
Association asked me to speak on this
bill today and that is why I'm here I
believe this bill's attempting to solve
a problem that does not exist in this
state
the proposed language to amend RSA 595-8
colon two
the requisites of Lawrence statue and
RSA 592-a colon 8 is problematic in a
number of ways the proposed paragraph
two
of the requisites of a warrant statute
States the law enforcement officer or
law enforcement agency requesting the
search warrant
well
that's in direct contradiction
to RSA 595 A4 written statement under
oath in support of application for
Warrant it states a person seeking a
search warrant shall appear before a
court of justice it speaks nothing about
an agency every arrest warrant and every
search warrant that is applied for in
this state and granted is done by one
officer there's not a team of officers
there's not an agency why is that
problematic well excuse me it's
problematic because the language is now
making it sound like the entire breadth
of the agency has knowledge that one
officer may or may not have
so are we going to punish an officer for
something another officer may know that
didn't tell him if the agency knew it we
don't know
um
and then it talks about they shall
disclose exculpatory evidence who is
they
the agency how can the agency ex
um how can the agency put out
exculpatory evidence when they're not
giving out the evidence it's only a
single officer so that's a problem with
the statute itself it's flying in the
face of how the search warrants and
arrest warrant process works
um
this also applies to RSA 592 A8 under
the warrants
that only one officer will sign out a
warrant so next the definition of
exculpatory evidence does not exist in
the RSA code we all know that
exculpatory evidence is evidence that
tends to show that a individual charge
with a crime did not commit the crime
we know that but it means different
things to different people it means
different things to a police officer to
a prosecutor to a defense lawyer to a
judge into a jury
so how are we going to expect an officer
to know what is exculpatory evidence
when we don't even Define it it's not
defined anywhere in the statute
and what I mean by that is I've had to
sit through many trials
and I've watched as a police prosecutor
for many years members on the defense
side ask questions of officers or of me
while I'm giving testimony in a case
that they believe is exculpatory that I
know or I believe is not so now it's
subjective
so now we're going to punish officers
for a subjective definition of
exculpatory evidence because we haven't
bothered to Define it in the statute
um
so
will the verbal protestations of a
criminal defendant that the pants he was
wearing that we seized for a search
warrant were not his is that exculpatory
do we have to put that in a search
warrant and if we don't or do we face a
thousand dollar fine
if a person of witnessed victim or
suspect was crying or failed to cry
while giving a statement to the police
is that exculpatory because a defense
lawyer would argue that the lack of or
showing of emotion could be exculpatory
depending on the facts of each specific
case is that exculpatory we don't know
the purpose of an affidavit or a
statement of probable cause is simply to
outline whether probable cause exists to
conduct a search or to arrest the
defendant everything else that has to do
with exculpatory evidence occurs
post-arrest it occurs during the defense
council's attempt to mitigate or to
prove not guilty a criminal defendant it
has nothing to do with law enforcement
in the investigation of a crime I'm not
saying we ignore exculpatory evidence of
course we document it of course we make
notes of the protestations of Defense
but
to say there's going to be a fine is
going to have a chilling effect on
officers going forward trying to get
search warrants and arrest warrants
because they're going to be is it worth
it I don't know maybe this is
exculpatory maybe it's not now I'm going
to delay what I'm doing to talk to a
supervisor or an attorney
before they even go for that warrant
where in the past they would just go and
get the arrest warrant or the search
warrant or apply for the search warrant
um the Brady rule requires prosecutors
to turn over any exculpatory evidence
they're aware of if it's a long-standing
federal practice and it applies in the
state even if that exculpatory evidence
is evidence that they're not aware of
through the normal Discovery process for
example they get proof that an officer
was lying they're required to provide
that evidence I would argue the same is
for a police officer they're required to
give that evidence
there's no Provisions in this statute
for an emergency what do I mean by that
we could have an individual who's been
the subject of multiple ongoing criminal
investigations who's out on or he's
released on PR bail and there's an
emergency situation and we're outside
his home and we need to get a search
warrant to go in
and some of the facts of that case are
going to be related to Prior cases that
we're already doing
it's midnight it's 2 A.M we got to get a
search warrant to get in there is that
midnight officer that's working on a
search warrant gonna have to call in
that officer and scan his brain to
figure out everything in custody of the
agency that might be exculpatory or with
the dates and times of Prior search
warrants or arrest warrants it doesn't
make sense all it's going to do is delay
what could be an emergency situation
um
and finally
who determines what a violation of this
chapter is
the the
member that
just spoke before me I I don't recall
his name at the moment talked about
knowingly he added a men's Raya to a
statute that doesn't exist it's not in
there I don't see knowingly in there so
it's just the way that's written is
anyone I guess the judge will be like ah
you should have known that thousand
dollar fine
there's no is there an appeal process
what it just doesn't make sense for
these reasons the nhpa is opposed to
thank you very much
we're all good all right thank you very
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Christopher ice 159
10 Rod Road in Rochester I'm here to
speak in
approval of this bill I believe that
this bill is a good bill uh to lay the
framework to fair and honest policing
and keep our judges Injustice of the
pieces accountable myself is a justice
of the peace and in my previous
profession before I became a small
business owner
was served several times with arrest
warrants misdemeanor arrest warrants but
arrest warrants nonetheless
and in my profession I had denied
throughout the course of my career
probably seven to ten of those because
they didn't have enough evidence that I
felt was reasonable enough
or I felt that they committed the crime
and officers have said to me in that
moment well I'll just drive down the
street to the next Police Department to
have a bail commissioner or justice of
the peace sign that warrant I think that
the previous testimony that you received
about exculpatory evidence they were
mixing the two
um about what is exculpatory evidence
versus this becoming exculpatory
evidence
how the bill is laid out it states
that the denial will become the evidence
to the next judge
okay so that is the evidence that would
be exculpatory
going forward past that point of going
to the first judge or Justice of the
Peace in addition there was a question
earlier about how Justice of the pieces
track this information well I have my
own tracker so that way if I ever get
questioned why did I sign this warrant
or who did I sign that paperwork for I
have all that information personally but
there's no State system there's no
system through the courts there's no
system through law enforcement agencies
there's no system through the Secretary
of State's office which I received my
commission from to track
what paperwork I signed for who I sign
it for
so that might be something that comes
later in the process we have a state
system for campaign Finance we have a
state system that you can search
business names and LLC names why don't
we have a system online that has a
justice of the peace or a judge can log
into and see last name rice oh I see
that
Mrs Smith I'm using a generalized name
here
denied that application for a warrant
we're talking about fair and honest
transparency in the police world and in
the judicial system
I feel that this bill would start that
framework and start that process going
forward to
making sure that we hold everyone
accountable
um
I I'd be happy to take any questions
representative Newman
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
and I just want to make sure I
understood the testimony that you just
gave and I believe it was that you had
denied
um requests for an arrest warrant and
then you became knowledgeable or or able
to determine that that
arrest warrant was issued then by a uh a
justice of a piece and could not only
you be able to use that method that you
used could Justice and pieces can
justices of the peace can they could
they determine that if that happened in
just that thank you yeah thank you for
the question representative so uh the
agency that I worked for specifically we
had seven Justice of the pieces work in
the same building
so if I
denied it right then and there they
could go to another Justice of the Peace
just down the hall
or they could go to another agency
across town
I knew of Justice of the pieces that
worked in the same Police Department as
the officer that was applying for the
arrest warrant and I felt that it was a
conflict of interest but that was just
hearsay communication that was me
speaking to you and you speaking back to
me or I hear an off-the-cuff remark or
comment that is not a bona fide
legitimate system and what I'm and I
have no right to propose anything but if
I were to propose something this online
system I would have to establish what
the grounds are on that system
and I haven't completely read all of the
bill this bill does not propose such a
system as you are just that is that that
is correct representative the bill does
not propose a system that is just my own
internal thought
um you know reading the bill this would
lay a groundwork to such system later
down the line
thank you madam Sharon thank you for
taking my question yes thank you when in
that specific instance that you're
referring to and I don't know if it's
just that one but let's just pick one
um were you able was there some type of
accountability because you knew that
that officer was was going to ask
another judge Justice of the piece or
something like that were you able to
report that and was there some process
mechanism by which you know it was
addressed in that in that instance that
you're talking about so the short answer
is no
um but I will say as a justice of the
peace and the reason why I became a
Justice of the Peace was not for my job
it was a benefit that I was able to add
on to my job to serve in that capacity
however
um
you know could I make phone calls
absolutely but that's not the place to
in my opinion interfere with
um the Judgment of an arrest warrant I
made the decision to deny it that's my
decision and I had my grounds for such
reasons
um but a different JP or a different
judge could feel differently
um or they might have had new evidence
that came forward before them applying
to a different JP or judge
okay thank you you're welcome
representative Manion
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question absolutely thank you
this is just more of a clarification
um because of the the other question
sure you you testified earlier that you
heard that the person made an off the
coffee Market if you go to somebody else
and I'm confused did that actually
happen they made the off the cuff remark
after I had denied it and it was days
later that they went to a different JP
to get that arrest warrant signed okay I
just wanted to make sure they're
actually heard yep that's what I had
heard days later after I had denied the
first that request thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
madam chair and thank you committee
do I need to push this I forget it's
my name is Rich Clark
so it is on if it's red or it's off
sorry so it's kind of backwards red
means go here
so my name is Rich Clark I practice
criminal law for the past 15 years
my experience is primarily in Rockingham
County
the the state
the state policemen had and I respect
them but my opinion is is quite
different
um from what this state police officer
had mentioned earlier
exculpatory evidence
is simply evidence that benefits the
defendant
it doesn't matter whether you're a judge
a juror an attorney it all means the
same thing
he said that it's a problem that doesn't
exist well it certainly is a problem and
I can tell you from practicing for 15
years it's one and I can also tell you a
story that it was a problem for me
personally
the only thing that this bill is
proposing is just to be transparent the
only thing we were that we're seeking is
that
if it's if an arrest warrant is denied
you give notice to the next JP if you
present it that's all
if an arrest warrant is denied and the
person is is indicted that you give the
grand jury the information if they're
aware of it that this was denied by a
court or
it's fair and it's honest that's all
we're trying to do or that's what this
bill does is it creates accountability
and honesty
and there was testimony also by the
state police officer and he said well
what if one person didn't know do I got
to call the other one at two in the
morning the way this the language is
created
it's for the benefit as well for law
enforcement because it creates a
standard and that standard is here
mentioned many times and that's simply
that that officer has to have knowledge
they have to have knowledge of something
if they don't know they don't have to
pick the phone up and call someone else
at two in the morning it's if they have
knowledge that this has been denied
before simply that they give it to the
next person they propose it to
and if they have knowledge
it'll create its shell disclose whether
they know that's one example shell
disclose if they have knowledge
they don't have knowledge then they
don't have any burden to disclose it the
it says well does that relate to the
entire agency that was another question
posed
it doesn't say anything about agency it
just says if they have knowledge this is
the person that's filing the arrest
warrant
in in my instance I was involved in a
divorce
in in my case
um
my now ex-wife who I'm friends with
again had tried to preclude me from any
contact with my son
he was 11 years old at the time
so every time there was an allegation
against me personally and it failed in
court she would step it up and there
would be something worse and worse well
the second to the last worst one is that
I allegedly beat my own son which was
ridiculous
when that failed in court she said she
went to the police in Portsmouth and she
said my husband started molesting my son
a month ago when he filed for a divorce
which was absolutely ridiculous and you
could see each thing Step Up
so Portsmouth Police went to file an
arrest warrant for me an innocent parent
a father of a son who is also an
attorney and well-known and respected in
a city
that arrest warrant a judge makes a
determination whether there's probable
cause to issue the arrest warrant a
court determined there was no probable
cause in my situation and denied the
those that that Police Department
circumvented the Circ the district court
order finding no probable cause and
indicted me through a grand jury for the
same thing an innocent parent
someone that was innocent of these
allegations which were clearly
false
at this point you know I'm over it now
but I can tell you I wasn't happy then
what this would have done is simply
to tell the grand jury this is on
section three
that this issue came before a court and
it was denied where Court found probable
cause was lacking that's all this does
is just require law enforcement to tell
the next person when they're Forum
Shopping and doing something
inappropriate like this and as the
testimonial you heard before me just to
so during my case dcyf did a formal
investigation they also found the
allegations were unfounded
for one year and 11 months I didn't get
to see my son now if any of you have
kids and your children are 11 I can tell
you when you get them back when they're
14 they look quite a bit different
they might have grown four inches their
voice sounds different and they look
totally different I didn't even get to
see a text message for my son during
that time
and why because something simple as this
occurred to me and it's all it created
was transparency to the person that's
trying it
it puts the burden of law enforcement to
if they're not what happens to them
not really that much
they can get up to a thousand dollar
fine
they could get a dollar fine the judge
has discretion to hear the case and he
can determine whether or not the person
violated it and to what extent
so when they say it's going to take
money out of the pocket of innocent law
enforcement
people a judge will look at this
objectively and decide was this person
deserving of a fine one he could say
there's no fine he could say there's a
dollar and certainly he could say
there's a thousand
this would ensure
basic Integrity in our system that is
clearly lacking from my testimony and
you heard someone else before me a
Justice of the Peace here in our state
where if one arrest warrant fails it's
proposed to another one and I wonder in
as in my case and what he has testified
how often this happens we'll never know
because there's no track record we have
nothing in our system that accounts for
all of these multiple petitions for
somebody
in my case ultimately my mine was Noel
Prost withdrawn
and the finding was insufficient
evidence
well a year and 11 months I didn't get
to see my son
because I got indicted and was that
disclosed to the grand jury
it should have been exculpatory
information should have been disclosed
that in my instance this is a father
that's fighting for the for the custody
of his child and anything that was
exculpatory should have been discussed
with a grand jury
and here we are for me I can tell you
the degree of frustration that I felt
that this is just dropped for
insufficient evidence after a court of
law already made the decision in the
representative Newman
thank you madam chair
um if you look at line two uh line 11 in
section two and you talked about I
believe you said
um all I have to do is if they if they
have knowledge it says whether they have
knowledge I want is there a problem with
that and it also says they and there was
previous testimony I believe that said
it would be impossible and I believe
that they refers to the enforcement
agency and I believe there was testimony
that said that how could the agency know
so is there a problem with that and so
I'm just curious as to your your
I think the way it's worded is it's
discretionary
the first word is the law enforcement
officer
and it does say or law enforcement
agency requesting a search warrant shall
we'll look at what happened to me
if some if they have knowledge whether
it's one person filing it or there's two
before they file they should make sure
that they're being honest and they
disclose whether it's multiple people
that are working on the case because the
person that's filing an arrest warrant
they're submitting the facts on what the
person did they should be competent
enough to review the file thoroughly to
make sure that the facts go forward
including
those that are exculpatory
that are known
they review the file that's how the
these arrest warrants are done and if
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I actually have a 14 and 15 year old
boy and I I can't imagine spending a
year and 11 months without them my
question is when you were explaining
just talking about the story you were
saying that it escalated each time which
to me I would interpret as there was
more evidence the next time around or
there was something that changed the
next time it came around but this seems
to be talking about if the evidence is
the same could you kind of clarify that
hmm
well
if so so in my instance it was the same
evidence it was I was in Family Court
so you know it's common because I
practice family law as well so if one
thing fails quite often a a parent
that's trying to preclude
um custody with another parent they'll
step up so like first the in my instance
and I'll tie to my case rather than my
clients dcyf showed up because they said
I wasn't my wife then was saying I
wasn't feeding my son which he was
overweight so if that doesn't work then
it gets stepped up
and it gets stepped up again and again
but in this instance how it ties
to the
the evidence was always the same
so that's a it's a family court issue
that is separate from the criminal issue
the criminal issue they they will
have what they do is they talk to
Witnesses
um
and that's what creates the body of the
majority of what ends up in the arrest
um the the facts
thank you
thank you for your testimony is there
anybody else wishing to testify this
bill that has not turned in a pink card
foreign
I will close the public hearing for
house bill 481.
at this time we will open the public
hearing for House Bill 585 and the
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is representative David love I
represent Rockingham 13 which is Derry
and uh let me preface this whole thing
that uh you know I'm uh I'm a
a strong supporter of law enforcement my
grandfather was a a cop in Lawrence
Massachusetts and uh and I understand a
good chunk of what these guys have to go
through they when they get get called uh
somebody there doesn't want them there
and uh you know it can make for an awful
difficult day
um anyway
um this uh I put this bill in because
um
there's uh I I well I went to a seminar
and it was put on by Americans for
Prosperity and uh they were they were
talking about uh trying it's going after
qualified immunity and uh that one of
the big things was uh you know police
brutality and you know cops that are on
steroids uh uh you know guilty of it
more than more than others they
administer a a much nastier beating and
what have you but uh
you know I I don't want to see
police officers lose qualified immunity
uh well it would would uh would
certainly have chaos in the streets and
uh you know they wouldn't be able to
hold on to a cop so anyway uh you know I
I Look to remedy the problem I I don't
you know with with roughly 4 500 law
enforcement people in the state of New
Hampshire I don't think everybody's
squeaky clean you know and uh you know
if uh
if a cop's clean
they should have no problem with this
you know if they don't do steroids uh
that they'll have absolutely no problem
and steroids are the anabolic steroids
are an illegal substance just like
heroin
um so uh you know what it does is uh it
takes a a
testosterone level prior to employment
and uh you know then uh you know say if
you at 22 years old your testosterone
levels here and if you're at 40 years
old and you're all poofed up and all
muscle bound and you and you you know
you rub somebody up and you testosterone
levels are up here something's going on
and uh you know we want to stop that
um you know it's um
once again it's a it's an antidote to a
problem that uh that doesn't exist in a
big way in New Hampshire but I'm sure it
does you know there's just way too many
thank you representative over there I
don't see any questions representative
Murray
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um if I heard you correctly I think you
said that officers who are on steroids
are more likely to partake in violence
yes it's pretty well proven okay yeah I
was just curious if there was like data
that backs that up that you could share
I I was actually thinking you were still
answering her question representative
Newman
thank you madam chair and so it's just a
follow-up to that question so if from my
reading of this bill it means that if
they are if the officer gets a does it
does not detect that he's using steroids
or if he is using steroids he has a
medical prescription for that and that
person who would just be deemed that the
force that he used was not excessive is
that correct yes um you know if it
medically supervised animal anabolic
steroid use or even just regular steroid
usually for something like Ed you know
it happens with a lot of guys uh you
know you you start
your testosterone levels don't go off
hello Madam chairman members of
committee thank you again
um the nhpa New Hampshire Police
Association asked me to speak on this
bill
um
so there's two parts to this bill the
first part that I'm going to speak about
briefly amends 106 L6 talking about
hiring at the Academy
to test for anabolic anabolic anabolic
and testosterone boosting steroids the
nhp doesn't have a position on this
however
I will state
um that any competent background
investigation is going to detect or I'm
sorry the background investigator is
going to learn that a person's on
anabolic steroids well in advance of
them even getting to the drug screening
and probably disqualify that candidate
but I'll leave that we don't have a
position on it the next portion is the
creation of a new RSA
RSA 105 colon 20. drug screening for the
use of excessive force complaints
this bill proposes to require drug
screening for anabolic steroids and
testosterone boosting steroids for any
officer who's the subject of an
excessive force complaint
the statute doesn't Define what an
excessive force complaint is
um I would say that any Force any use of
force complaint is an excessive force
complaint whether someone believed they
should have been arrested or not and
they file a complaint that he handcuffed
me roughly that's now an excessive force
complaint that's going to have to be
investigated and now vis-a-vis the
officer is going to have to have a
steroid test we don't know who's going
to pay for it I'm assuming the town will
um
does that mean well let me continue I'm
sorry
um even those complaints that are
demonstrably false so law enforcement
agencies are required or they should be
in taking complaints whether they're
Anonymous or not and investigating them
so an anonymous complaint sent in on a
handwritten letter that no one signed
saying officer x uh punched me is a
complaint that we're gonna have to
investigate now we're gonna have to send
officer acts to get a steroid test or
officer y uh punched me we look at the
body cam footage he didn't even touch
the person now we have to go send them
to get a steroid test there's no
exception here if it demonstrably false
complaints what about a Google review
what if someone gets on Google and says
Officer Jason Smith at the Salem PD
punched me
well now I'm gonna have to go get a
steroid test because this bill doesn't
allow for any exception now that we're
going to investigate it
um
so let's bring it down to the logical
conclusion
a subject outside a bar spits in the
face of an officer it takes three
officers to tackle that person bring
them to the ground
he's not hurt
all three officers the suspect defendant
files a complaint against them they used
excessive force whether it's
demonstrably false or not because
there's no exception in this language
all three officers including one that
might be a pregnant female is now going
to have to go get a steroid test
um and there's no exception for that
um
unlike the language to change 106 L6
there's no provision
in the proposed statute that deals with
people that have a prescription in 2004
I was diagnosed with a pituitary tumor
I've had two surgeries in radiation and
I'm on testosterone for the rest of my
life among other drugs so if I have a
use of force I'm gonna go get a test
that's going to prove I have a medically
included
prescription that I'm taking what's the
point of that there is no point
um
finally I'm just going to end with this
prices square root law
states that the number of people
involved in a project or business
um will be the square root of the number
of people are responsible for 50 of the
work if you equate that to law
enforcement
every agency has a group of officers
that are perhaps more productive or
engaging with the criminal element
these are individuals with the most
arrests the most activity
and they're also the usually the ones
with the most use of force complaints
does that mean
they're on steroids no
does that mean they're bad officers no
does that mean they're doing anything
wrong no
what it actually means is that these
officers are making a difference in
making New Hampshire safer
all this bill does is to seek to crush
their spirit
of these hard-working officers and
that's why the nhpa is adamantly opposed
representative Murray
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I was just curious I
have no idea what a steroid test entails
is that something that's like personally
invasive and is it also something that's
costly
I appreciate the question ma'am I my
brother's a doctor I am not I would
assume it's urine maybe blood I honestly
don't know I I do know that drug
screening tends to be expensive but I I
I don't want to speak out of something I
don't know
thank you
I can call my brother
we have a couple other people testifying
I'm sure I'll be able to get that
question answered uh is there anybody
else though see no further questions
thank you for your testimony
thank you madam chair uh thank you uh
committee members uh for the record my
name is John skip I'm the director of
New Hampshire police standards and
training and with me is Captain Adam
Hawkins of police sandwich and training
and uh uh I'll start by trying to answer
your question representative Murray uh
to test first uh testosterone or uh
anabolic steroids it would require blood
draw and the cost of that test is right
around
uh
I am here to uh we are here to uh
testify in opposition to this bill as it
is written
uh let me take the second part first and
then the the first part uh second
with regard to the uh proposed amendment
to RSA 106 L6 Roman numeral 4.
it uh asks that uh
the drug screening shall include
screening for Annabelle anabolic or
testosterone boosting steroids uh with a
caveat that it does allow the officer to
or the candidate to be prescribed those
drugs in which case it's not an issue
I don't believe that this needs to be
captured in statute
police standards and training Council
has statutory authority to set the
hiring standards to include physical
fitness tests medical tests any other
requirements to certify a police officer
so we can very easily include excuse me
include anabolic steroids and
testosterone boosting steroids as part
of our existing drug screen that would
be very easy to do by just capturing it
in our administrative rules and
uh the last part of 106 l
six Roman numeral four which is proposed
in this legislation
asks that the council shall forward the
results of the drug screening to the
officers employing agency and the
employing agency shall rescind the
employment
and to be clear New Hampshire police
citizen training does not receive the
results of any drug screens that we
mandate now
and this proposed legislation would
require that now the council would have
to receive that medical information that
we we don't ask for right now
and uh and then it's it's kind of
written in a way that it proposes that
this officer is then going to be fired
from their job
because of that uh
I guess positive test
the reality of it is we police citizen
training does not get involved in
employment issues we get involved with
regulatory issues with the licensing the
certification of an officer
and so it would be more accurate to
reflect that the certification would not
be issued in the first instance
again
I can work with representative love to
to work this into our administrative
rules I don't think it needs any
legislation
um
and this would be for hiring purposes so
we would just add this schedule 3 drug
which is uh anabolic steroids are
considered a schedule three drug they're
illegal unless of course you have a
prescription
with regard to the addition of 105 20.
and much to the captain's testimony from
Salem
it does create
a situation where there is no due
process
for the officer that has had this
allegation made against them
and in fact uh it is a very invasive
requires a blood test
and I think it's important for the this
committee to understand that uh if it
were the other way around where the
police had a reason to believe that
maybe you were under the influence of
uh alcoholic beverages and you got in a
car accident
we cannot unilaterally just bring you to
the hospital and say roll your sleeve up
and we're going to take a blood test to
to check your alcohol level because
we're alleging that you were you're
probably driving drunk
we have to either get your permission to
do that or we have to get a warrant
based on facts and circumstances that
would lead to believe that there's
probable cause that you have this in
your system and we're trying to gather
that as evidence
finally I would suggest this
if there is an allegation of a police
officer using excessive force
the investigation is going to
concentrate on
the facts and circumstances
of what that
excessive force may have been we're
gonna we're gonna talk to the people
involved we're going to talk to
Witnesses we're going to talk to the
officers we're going to look at body
camera we're going to look at other
cameras from other areas
at the end of the day
whether any of the officers have
anabolic steroids in their system or
whether they have insulin in their
system or whether they took a
multivitamin that morning
uh is not going to have any real direct
bearing on whether the investigation
will bear out or sustain that the
officer or officers used excessive and
unnecessary Force if that if that makes
sense this bill is suggesting that uh if
this then that and uh I don't know that
uh
determining that
the officer had any level of anabolic
steroids in their system
is going to help
substantiate or exonerate an allegation
of excessive force
I just wanted to offer uh
that information I certainly stand ready
to answer any questions and again I look
forward to working with representative
love on the in the first part of
um
Senator Newman
so thank you madam chair and I just have
a quick question for the example you
gave about DWI and obtaining the results
of such a blood test and it might not
pertain exactly to this bill but if if
in that example that you gave if the
individual that you were alleging was
guilty of DWI
was injured in the hospital drew blood
from that individual with the police
would the of police or whatever have
access to that or where they need a
warrant for that or how does that work
they would need a warrant in order to
obtain those medically drawn samples to
saying no further questions thank you
is there anybody else wishing to testify
in this bill that has not turned in a
we will close the public hearing for
House Bill 585
and we will now open the public hearing
for House Bill 593
thank you
and
ladies and gentlemen if you wish to
testify
all right excuse me if you wish to
testify on House Bill 593 we are going
to ask if you would please turn your
card in now so that we can see how many
people wish to testify so we can find
out if we have to limit testimony
foreign
except for the for the prime sponsor
we've discussed it and we are going to
limit testimony to three minutes for um
each person that wishes to testify at
this time the committee recognizes
representative McGuire
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dan McGuire I represent the town of
Epsom I will try to meet your
three-minute limit as well
um for those who are not familiar with
asset forfeiture in drug crimes what it
is it's a section of the law and
specifically RSA 318b colon 17b
um the concept is that when someone
commits a drug crime not only are they
subject to criminal penalties but also
we don't want them to keep the the
fruits of their crime the money they
receive maybe from selling drugs and and
also the the instruments of the crime so
typically uh it's often a car right if
the typical example is someone is
arrested in a parking lot sitting in
their car selling drugs and they're
arrested with a bag of drugs and
um and some cash and so they these law
enforcement officers in that case will
seize the drugs seize the cash and seize
the car and arrest the person and so the
question is so our law provides that
that
upon conviction those those items will
be forfeited obviously the Contraband
the drugs is always
forfeited but
um there's a there's a legal process to
Forfeit the cash and the vehicles and
whatever else might be involved in the
crime
so
um this bill so so about uh six or seven
years ago we changed State policy such
that what originally was the case was
that the forfeiture action was a civil
action separate from the criminal action
for the drug crime and so they were
tried separately they had different
people involved Etc and so we we put in
a policy that you can all forfeiture can
only occur when conviction is achieved
right because forfeiting your property
losing your property is a kind of a
penalty and so the concept is somebody
shouldn't be penalized when they're not
guilty of a crime and so in current law
in this particular section in order for
forfeiture to take place there must be a
conviction
okay however the problem is because of
the way the process works people
frequently don't even contend the
forfeiture process so so there's certain
details about it that that make it so
that forfeitures are often just not even
contented they're not nobody they just
happen by default sort of and so what
this bill does is it perfects the
criminal Pro the the court process by
which forfeiture takes place so it it
instead of two separate kind of Court
hearings two separate cases it combines
it into a single case in the same court
with the same judge and the same
prosecutor in the same defense and makes
it makes it kind of a a Serial process
that that it goes in order so you first
convict the person of a criminal offense
and then you deal with the forfeiture in
a similar way that you would deal with
the penalties for the criminal offense
assuming there's conviction the bill is
quite detailed and long
because there's a lot of special Corner
cases right what if the car is owned by
somebody else and not owned by the
person who was arrested you know how do
they prove their their innocence of the
crime Etc et cetera so
um so there's a lot of detail here
looking at all those kind of cases
um
so
the the this bill
um also
instructs the uh prosecutors to make
greater use of State law versus Federal
law so drug crimes are crimes both of
they're both federal crimes and state
crimes and in some cases
um the law enforcement has the option of
charging somebody federally or charging
somebody with State crimes this because
we've improved our state law with this
bill and others
we want state law to be used and so this
bill also directs a little bit less
a little bit fewer prosecutions to be
used in federal court and a little bit
more to be used in State Court it still
allows federal court to be used on the
larger cases where federal agents are
involved but in in cases where only
state law enforcement has involved this
bill directs that State Court be used
um now the reason I have I've just
handed out a very long amendment to a
very long bill and I again I apologize
for that but
um we got the bill the original draft of
the bill kind of late in the drafting
process and since then
um we've spent extensive time talking
with representative of the Attorney
General's office representative of the
Judiciary uh Representative Bob Lin who
you'll hear from who's the chair of the
house Judiciary Committee and others and
so we've made extensive revisions not to
the goals of the bill which is again a
single streamlined court process but to
the details of exactly how that's done
because we talked to a lot of people who
have a lot of experience in this area
and so on so just to conclude this bill
does not affect law and what law
enforcement officers do they still
arrest people the same way they always
did they still seize drugs and property
and so on exactly as they already did
this bill is about what happens in court
after the fact how does the court
process it makes it more efficient makes
it fairer and comes to the right
conclusion at the end of the day and I'm
representative Gendron
thank you to the chair and and thank you
representative for taking my question uh
I seem to remember remember in 2019 a
very very very very similar bill
before the house Judiciary Committee is
this pretty much on that same premise
um yes thank you for the question I I
would say yes I was not a member of the
House at the time but as far as I know
in general yes although as I said this
is a very detailed Bill and all of that
discussion with all the various parties
had not taken place at that time so so
there's a lot of detail here that's more
amenable to the attorney general and and
represent
ative thank you I have a question
how do you determine when the federal
government and the state government gets
property seized
many times both of them will be involved
in the arrest well seizure that's up to
law enforcement right so the question is
when do you use federal law to prosecute
these crimes and when do you use state
law so basically what this says is if if
at in involved in the case if no federal
agents are involved in the case then use
state law so if it's only local police
state troopers Etc then we use state law
if federal
agents are involved in the case then
they can make a decision whether to use
you know all of the law enforcement
involved it's typically kind of a joint
state federal activity they can make a
decision as to whether you say law which
they frequently do in sort of smaller
cases and in bigger cases they tend to
use federal law
representative Muse
uh yes uh nine page Amendment
um and uh will you or anybody else who's
testifying actually be able to walk us
through some of the key changes and
differences
um yes and I would I would prefer that
not be me
but the answer is yes
um and and just to let you know Madam
chair
um my committee is about to have an exec
session on Senate bill one which deals
with the sununu youth center it's very
important so I'm going to have to leave
after my testimony and I would request
that you take the other member of my
committee my co-sponsor representative
popovichi Mueller second it's because
he's going to have to go as well so
all right see no further questions thank
uh what will you show up
thank you very much I really appreciate
it and I'm planning to stick to less
than two minutes but I'm gonna use a few
of the seconds that I'm saving by not uh
using my third minute by thanking you
for somehow miraculously going back on a
schedule because the way this morning
started that took a Hercules so I
appreciate it for the record I'm a
representative Daniel Popovich Mueller
winham represented Rockingham 17 and I
just want to bring your attention to a
specific portion of the bill that would
be on page 11 it's in paragraph in Roman
numeral five the amendment or the actual
bill in the amendment thank you the
language is described the same but I
would prefer obviously that we talk
about the amendment that suggested that
portion actually is unchanged in either
and it's about what happens to the funds
that do end up being
um you know
seized being forfeited the current law
has a rather complex formula in which
out of the first six hundred thousand a
hundred thousand goes to a specific fund
then you divide the remaining of the 600
in three pieces then you look at the
remainder and you break it into two
parts and then you have some statutory
limits above which everything goes in a
general fund
the intent of the language changes here
is to simplify the process and to also
eliminate some conflicts of interest
there we want to remove the language
that specifies that the first 100 000
goes to the police psychological
stability screening fund
this is just not the right way to fund
that for a couple of reasons first we
don't know exactly how much is needed
every year that's really something that
the legislature should appropriate
correctly in every year
and also if police you know depends on
those money that creates an incentive
for them to engage in maybe more
forfeiter than whether they are they
otherwise would and while every law
enforcement officer is trying to do the
right thing every time it's just not
good practice to give them incentives of
that nature it also just simplifies the
structure of our overall in the proposed
language
there wouldn't be you know two separate
you you wouldn't have that you just
split that
um entire amount in the way described
there with 45 percent to the uh agency
10 to a non-lab single count and 45 into
the revolving drug for future fund the
rest of the language is unchanged except
for housekeeping changes with paragraph
numbers and everything so it's a
reasonably straightforward portion of
the bill and uh you know obviously if
you have any questions only try to be
seeing none thank you for your testimony
oh thank you madam chair and members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Ross Connolly I'm the deputy state
director for Americans for Prosperity in
New Hampshire
here to voice our support for HB 593
this bill should be familiar to the
members the committee that have been
around for a little while a very similar
bill came before this committee last
year and really one of the biggest
issues was was really trying to make
that shrinking down from the two-track
uh process and forfeiture to the one
track process uh it was a lot of the
complication last year was really around
how we adapt that into the New Hampshire
court system and I know the the sponsor
of the bill the co-sponsor and uh has
worked with the Attorney General's
office and the court system to really
tighten up that language and make it
work for for New Hampshire system
um so just to briefly describe you know
how this process currently Works uh if
an individual is suspected of a crime
they can have their property seized by
law enforcement if they have probable
probable cause to believe it was aided
or gained by the defendant in the
commission of a crime the the defendant
then goes through the criminal court
process if they are found not guilty
they still need to go through a civil
court process uh to for the case against
their property that that was seized
um this holds a different standard and
Criminal Court uh the or then Criminal
Court the the defendant is not able to
have a lawyer provided to them and in
most cases the property of uh that was
taken is of such low value that it does
not make Financial sense to go through a
legal process to try and get it back
which ends in what's called default
which many many forfeitures end in
default because it's just not worth
going to get your property back even
though you were found not guilty of the
crime that you were accused of
um
this bill simply takes those two
processes and and merges them in into
one uh so the process would be
streamlined uh for our court system uh
it would provide that that
representation uh for for the defendant
uh through the court system uh the the
judge would be familiar with the case
the criminal case and be able to easily
execute the the case against the
property
um there's lots of Provisions in in the
amendment to really uh give leeway to
the courts of when those things happen
uh so so that's really at the discretion
of the Court uh and then the last part
of this bill uh restricts the use of of
uh the federal adoptions program through
the Equitable sharing program of of
Department of Justice uh this
legislature uh back in 2016 I believe uh
from the leadership of Representative
McGuire decided to end the practice of
civil forfeiture uh there are loopholes
in that uh and one of them is is the
federal adoptions program uh where you
can go around the the law that this body
agreed on uh and and get a forfeiture
proceeding without uh a conviction uh so
Joint Task forces are excluded from this
uh just to give a pers perspective uh
the Equitable sharing program through
Federal adoptions is 19 of of
forfeitures Joint Task forces account
for 81 percent of forfeitures between
2018 and 2020 uh and those are excluded
uh so uh we believe the ends shouldn't
justify the means uh gaining money
through cases where an individual is
found not guilty uh it cannot be
justified uh and luckily this bill would
only impact this portion of the bill
would only impact around twelve thousand
dollars uh over the course of three
years
behind me I'm happy to take questions
representative Newman
thank you madam chairman thanks for
taking my question uh and I'm just
curious about online on page two line 23
and it has enumeration for cash and uh
value for the vehicle I'm just wondering
what that is there for and what they're
trying to accomplish
we said page two two numeral three uh
right at the bottom of the page
um I I I'm not to be honest I'm not sure
so I'll defer to those those be
following me uh that have more details
on some of the the language changes the
amendment
we will just remind everybody that we
are limiting Our Testimony to three
minutes
thank you madam
thank you so much to Tess for the
opportunity testify my name is Frankie
Knack policy director with the east of
New Hampshire
um representative Newman to get to your
question
um and I'll give it a little bit of
context first but answer your question
so kind of thinking back about the
origins of forfeiture it was sold to the
public as a tool to get the oh gotten
gains of drug kingpins you know back in
the 80s 70s 80s think Pablo Escobar
people who are beyond the jurisdictional
reach of the US government and therefore
because we couldn't get them as an
individual we could go after their
property
and so fast forward to today forfeiture
is is much different and so forfeiture
has really turned into a tool that often
goes after people with little wealth and
so because so often the amount of
forfeiture is so little
um it creates a perverse incentive so
that people when you're talking about
low dollar amounts like a thousand or
below
for people with wealth who can hire an
attorney will cost them more to hire an
attorney to get their money back and and
so they'll just do a default judgment
and won't challenge it for people
without wealth they can't hire a
different attorney so they lose that
money and so if the concept is really
going after the ogotten gains of drug
kingpins having this threshold of a
thousand for cash and five thousand for
a vehicle which mirrors the AG
the way the AG is enforcing it right now
is just a way to get back to the core
concept of forbature which is to get the
oh gotten gains thank you
um and again you know why we also really
love this bill is is because it's
creating a more uniform process a more
streamlined process through the criminal
system which again ensures that everyone
including internet people are able to
get access to council and so if you
qualify for a public defender for your
criminal trial you're convicted they
then execute a forfeiture proceeding
your criminal defense attorney your
public defender will stay with you and
so people aren't forced to make this
ridiculous decision between having to
choose between their property and
forfeiting their property or because
they can't afford an attorney or
challenge even if it's not a legitimate
forfeiture and so we're just trying
again to make sure that this is a fair
system and again going after the
ill-gotten gains of of uh illicit
activity and not just people because
they don't have wealth to defend
themselves
um
and I know my colleague Lee from IJ will
get into the Weeds on this so and I know
there's not a whole lot of time but
representative Muse
yeah one question is
um it sounded like
um Mr Conley may have answered this
before but um what percentage of
forfeitures are we talking about in New
Hampshire it's my impression is it's a
relatively a relatively small amount
part of the overall amount
yeah so I've worked on this issue in
multiple States now
um and New Hampshire it definitely is
lower than most States in terms of the
total amounts
um and so I know my colleague Lee from
IJ has I have the specific figures but I
got them from him so I'll let him
testify as to his figures
thanks
so you know further questions thank you
foreign
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Miles Madison
I'm the chief of the criminal Bureau at
the Department of Justice
um
we appreciate the engagement with
representative McGuire and the
co-sponsors of this bill for our input
on some of the content or technical
questions relating to criminal
forfeiture that the Attorney General's
office takes no position on this bill or
the utilization of in-rem civil
forfeiture versus criminal forfeiture
would just testify in a few of the
content or issues raised for
consideration by this committee today
so to make clear there was reference uh
in a previous testimony relating to the
attorney general's policies relating to
civil forfeiture in the current regime
as it exists civil forfeiture is not
pursued if there is an underlying
acquittal on the criminal charge uh and
then there are also our uh limits on the
the amount of forfeiture or a threshold
by which the Attorney General's office
would pursue forfeiture the Attorney
General's guidelines relating to
forfeiture are a public document that
are on the Attorney General's website
I would note that there are reciprocal
costs just in in managing the judicial
proceedings relating to forfeiture so
the description of now there being a
criminal process and then a separate
civil process that is true that's still
a Judicial proceeding that would require
resources so just for consideration by
the committee even if it's the same
public defender who's handling the
underlying criminal offense and then a
corresponding criminal forfeiture
there's still a resource Demand on any
defense
representative or attorney for managing
that process it's not it's not without a
cost
um would note two areas for
consideration by the the committee as
well one would be the review process or
in the language of the amendment uh who
is initiating or conducting the
forfeiture proceedings the prior
testimony including the description by
representative mcquire McGuire was
describing a streamlining of the process
by trying to ensure that the same
Prosecuting Authority the same
prosecutor is handling both the criminal
case and then the criminal forfeiture
the language is as drafted appears to
consider the Attorney General's office
and still intensely involve the Attorney
General's office in that process I don't
have suggested language relating to that
but would put it to the committee for
consideration of
um if there is a streamlining of the
process having the Attorney General's
office still involved would still be
keeping the same number of of parties
involved in a forfeiture proceeding it
may still be brought by the uh the the
prosecuting Authority so potentially
County attorney but if the Attorney
General's office is still involved in
that proceeding then there are still
because it's not perhaps streamlining it
to the same degree that may be the goal
in this legislation
um I would also note just some practical
considerations based on the operations
of the the current forfeiture law
on page
for line 19 relating to time
um
this legislation currently envisions
only a limited possibility for extending
uh the time that's talking about a party
by agreement or for good cause may move
for one extension of no more than 30
days would suggest just making that at
the depression of the court or a party
may move for extension to allow this
process to play out consistent with the
underlying facts the the demands of that
particular proceeding rather than having
a strict timeline on that with that I'm
willing to take any questions from the
committee
representative Jennifer
thank you to the chair and thank you for
taking my question my recollection from
discussions I had when I was on
Judiciary Committee debating this very
uh subject matter my recollection is
that at one time there was a criminal uh
process and it was a civil process so
effectively a police department
would go and make a seizure make an
arrest and prosecution would not
prosecute no process and then they would
pursue a civil forfeiture through the
federal court system is that still an
opportunity for that our Police
uh you I I don't believe so I think that
this is contemplating current policy uh
where the uh guidelines and process
would not pursue a civil forfeiture if
there is an an acquittal on the
underlying criminal charges this is this
bill would transition from a civil
forfeiture of a civil and criminal
proceeding to a criminal forfeiture
process to to try to combine those legal
proceedings and it would uh it's my
understanding would have the same
effective current policy of requiring a
conviction on the underlying felony
offense before any forfeiture would be
authorized
um my recollection is the the current
policy of waiting for a conviction in
order to pursue that was in place when
we had that discussion on that committee
and again it wasn't the prose prosecutor
uh County attorney or the Attorney
General's office was pursuing the Civil
forfeiture it was actually the police
department that was doing that through
the federal process and I I believe my
question is
if this bill were to pass would that
would that process of civil forfeiture
under the federal system still be
available to that Police Department
uh represent I believe that there was a
some discussion uh earlier in earlier
testimony relating to that it would be
toward the end of the legislation
um or the amendment I believe the
language would be on page 10 relating to
guidelines
and uh
the utilization of forfeiture as it
relates to State versus Federal
forfeiture so
um I wouldn't speak specifically on the
operation of of that language there but
I believe that this language in the
prior testimony was that it would be
limiting the ability to essentially go
around State forfeiture proceedings uh
anymore
Richard
I'm not exactly sure what this last name
is
my name is Richard Sam perrel I'm the
acting executive director at the New
Hampshire judicial Council
um
sure
uh the judicial Council oversees the
delivery of indigent defense services in
criminal cases I only wanted to testify
to clarify the fiscal note that was
provided on this bill we take no
position on the bill itself but this
would be a new area of legal services
that are provided by defense lawyers in
criminal cases that would just
necessarily mean that there would have
to be some training and consideration
given to the resources that currently
exist to be able to provide those
Services
the other concern expressed in the
fiscal node is the length of time to
close a case this may affect that length
but that's really uncertain from the
process that's being proposed but other
than that I have no other comment I'm
happy to take any questions if you have
them
representative Muse
the effective date is January 1st 2024
would that be enough time
to conduct the kind of proper training
you think would be required
yeah I think that that would be a
sufficient time to at least have some
training provided to lawyers who are
all right thank you for your testimony
uh thank you madam sure my name is Bob
Lynn I'm a state representative from
Windham and as representative McGuire I
mentioned I'm a co-sponsor on the bill
and I did work with uh representative
McGuire at Mr McGrath who you will hear
from uh shortly uh Mr head from the
judicial branch
and I I think this amendment
is is a good work product
um and I'm and I'm very much in favor of
it I think that you've heard some of the
abuses that have
sort of happened in the past with uh the
forfeiture uh regime
and I think that that this is designed
to correct it I I know I and I know my
time is short you've got a lot of other
people to hear from and I guess the one
thing I wanted I just want to say is
I know Mr head is concerned and will I
think we'll tell you
that the judicial branch is is somewhat
concerned about
um
sort of some of the of the like how are
some of the processes if you will of
making
forfeiture part of the criminal case and
I I'm you know I'm sympathetic to that
but I I also think that if you read
through the amendment it it is it is
really fashioned
to give a great deal of discretion to
the court as to how it as to how it um
sort of implements this in other words
it's you know there's in many places as
you'll see it says the court can you
know can do something in this way or
that way or this or the other way or at
its discretion and I think the the the
uh the intent is to give the court
a great deal of discretion in how it
implements this
um and I and so I you know I believe
that that will I'm not saying that there
won't be some bumps in the road there
always is with a with a new uh process
but I do think that this is a process
that can work
um uh because the court is the courts
are given so much discretion to uh uh to
handle I mean let me just give you one
example I know I know one of the things
that he and I talked about in the hall
outside was was
um the issue of you know what happens
bear in mind as that that
there's a there's a seizure that occurs
first when the property's actually taken
let's say a car when the property's
actually taken and then there will be
some time before the state decides
whether they are going to move forward
and actually try to Forfeit it so you
gotta distinguish seizure from
forfeiture
um the seizure is when the property's
actually taken and now it's being held
it may end up just being turned back to
the to the to the property owner but at
some point the state will decide we're
going to either move to Forfeit this or
not and for example one of the things
that attorney Ed raised with very valid
point is what if the um someone uh who
isn't who is who claims to be innocent
or is an innocent owner as an example a
lien holder what if they
um uh want to get the property back
after it's seized but before it's been
forfeited and for example that could
happen when the case is still before the
Circuit Court uh and his question will
have very legitimate question so what is
the you know this this bill contemplates
that these proceedings will happen in
the superior court so what do you do in
that kind of situation
um and very valid concerned you know I
can understand it completely so just as
a suggestion if you look at page four of
the amendment online
uh nine this uh it's paragraph three
dash a parenthesis a one three what you
could do there may be better ways of
doing it but I'm just off the uh you
know off the cuff as I thought about
what he raised you could add another
sentence at the end of line 10 that
would say
if such
um
if such emotion is filed
uh
uh with uh if such emotion is filed the
case if then pending uh in Circuit Court
shall be transferred to the superior
court for all purposes I mean that uh
you know I think that even without that
the superior the given the other
language in the bill the circuit the the
judicial branch could do that on its own
but if you wanted to sort of uh
you know put more language in there to
be directive to of how the judicial
branch should handle it you could do
that
um so I you know that I think I guess
what I'm saying is
this is a new procedure it would you
know there will be some bumps in the
road I understand the courts the Court's
sort of concerned but I don't think you
uh for you know how do we what are all
the steps we have to go through to
implement this I fully appreciate that
but I I don't think that that should be
a reason for not going forward with this
because it really does serve very
important uh purposes and so I hope that
that's the conclusion you'll come to
also
thank you representative are there any
questions
uh Madam chair members of the committee
my name is Lee McGrath I'm an attorney
at The Institute uh for for justice and
I've had the honor of testifying here in
New Hampshire for a number of years and
building upon past past efforts I'm I'm
hopeful hopeful that three is a is the
lucky charm uh uh here
crime should not pay
it is legitimate for the State of New
Hampshire to confiscate the fruit and
the instruments of crime nothing in this
bill changes those core principles
this bill into a large extent is a real
estate bill
it puts this question of transferring
title into a different place
today that litigation is done in Civil
Court should you enact this bill it will
move to Criminal Court
this bill is based on many of the
processes that the attorney general has
promulgated in a 2007 doc document
except it moves it to a different court
system
so to be clear
this bill does not change the work of
police officers on the street
they can continue to seize property
if they have probable cause of its
association with a crime
this bill changes a different
New Hampshire official the work of
lawyers State prosecutors in New
Hampshire's New Hampshire and gives them
the responsibility to litigate the
transfer of title as part of the
Criminal
prosecution
it is consistent with work that laws and
principles that New Hampshire has
already enacted New Hampshire's current
Law requires a conviction
before civil
this bill requires a conviction in
criminal in criminal court so we are
really just taking the Forum the venue
the real estate
of where this litigation takes place and
puts it
in the criminal prop in the criminal
process
how much money are we talking about
in the last two years New Hampshire
under state law has forfeited annually
230 thousand dollars
we are not talking about a large amount
of money on any law enforcement's budget
but we are talking about what it means
to the individual to lose a 800 or a
thousand or thirteen hundred dollars and
then and when that individual does have
the possibility of losing 800 or 1200 or
1300 dollars
they rationally give up
they walk walk away
they do not they they do not invest in a
lawyer that might cost them four
thousand to try to get back one one
thousand
because today
the forfeiture takes place in Civil
Court the good people and the public
defender's office can't represent them
they are prohibited Mr McGrath we we are
limiting testimony and very good we've
gone over about 30 seconds thank you so
the question about the federal the
federal government
the federal government has dual New
Hampshire and the federal government
have dual jurisdiction
all of the 99
of this discussion is about state law
but there is a component of federal law
there are Joint Task forces there are
adoptions
there in the last three years there have
only been nine adoptions this bill would
stop those nine adoptions that
constituted 85 000 over three years it
would leave the more than 95 percent of
the forfeitures done by Joint Task task
forces tiny tiny tiny restriction on the
use of federal adoptions
thank you for your testimony thank you
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is John Cunningham
I'm a police officer with the city of
Manchester I've been there for a little
over 22 years
um my current role as I'm Patrol
Division commander and prior to that I
was in charge I was the EXO executive
officer of our special enforcement
division which encompasses our drug unit
an interdiction unit violent offenders
unit and so and during all that I
oversaw our asset forfeiture program uh
we are testifying today uh in opposition
of this bill as introduced I do not have
the amendment in front of me and I'm
happy to get you a copy of my testimony
for your review as an email
we are opposed to the bill because of if
passed out will have a negative effect
on our ability to conduct our counter
drug operations it will have an harmful
impact on our enforcement operations and
it will cut funding that was intended to
support our drug enforcement
the primary purpose of the asset
forfeiture is to support our enforcement
role and its mission to stop the flow of
illegal drugs into our state
uh this I'll talk about both the state
and the federal process both the state
and the federal process I work closely
with the Attorney General's office when
I was managing the asset forfeiture they
have a very
um effective way of doing this right now
due process is in place for the uh
offenders when we do seize funds if it
is going to go to forfeiture there is a
process in place that ensures due
process on both levels
um in regards to uh just a testimony
that was given a minute ago
um reference to Federal asset forfeiture
I I do have some numbers in front of me
uh since and this is just Manchester but
since 2017 on the federal side
we've seen we've forfeited to our agency
uh about 1.37 million
um on the state side since 2017 we're
about 207 thousand dollars in change
just to give you an idea of kind of what
we've seen over the years
um this amendment uh as introduced would
prohibit any adoptive federal seizures
and prohibits uh accepting payment of
any kind or distribution from the
federal asset forfeiture program that's
concerning to us for numerous reasons
our federal state and local Partners
work jointly to better serve the granite
state
and our investigators result in legal
seizures and assets from drug
traffickers this bill would make it cost
prohibited to participate in federal
drug task force and this bill bars local
agencies from entering into adoptive
forfeiture with federal agencies this is
extremely concerning because it's common
for our agency to conduct investigations
into offenders who initially might not
be considered high-level traffickers and
these investigations often do not
include our federal Partners at the
onset or even during the initial
investigation itself
we cannot often predict the seriousness
of the drug trafficker until the
investigation is well underway or even
at the final stages and it's very common
to request assistance from our federal
Partners during the later stages of the
investigation to adopt the case once we
rationalize what resources we need to
further the investigation and what
courts are best suited to hold drug
traffickers and violent offenders
accountable for these actions
the federal Equitable sharing program
seizes and redistributes money directly
to from criminals to New Hampshire law
enforcement agencies the majority of the
money goes back to the New Hampshire
communities and allows us to carry out
our drug enforcement Mission if passed
this bill would have a negative impact
on the majority of law enforcement
agencies throughout the state and should
our federal asset forfeiture funding
become unavailable the burden for
funding drug and Drug Enforcement could
shift away from the drug traffickers and
the profiteers to lawful taxpayers
and the Manchester Police Department
relies on federal asset for asset
forfeiture funding to remain operational
this is the bottom line if you restrict
access to asset forfeiture funding to
you're effectively defunding our drug
enforcement and will allow drug
traffickers to distribute more drugs in
the community community so what we're a
lot we're asking is to inexpedient to
legislate this bill
happy to answer any questions thank you
for your testimony
representative Noel
thank you madam Sharon thank you for
taking my question
um so the the amounts that you gave were
since 2017 can you tell me how long this
has been going on for
when we started forfeiture
I don't have a start date or when we I
don't go I don't have anything past that
um I I was in the drug unit itself and
from 2013 I was doing it then and we
were doing it long before so I don't
have an exact start date for you I'm
sorry I can find out for you and get
back to you thank you
representative wheeler
chair representative Lynn and a few
others who testified in support of the
bill were fairly clear that this doesn't
impact Federal uh forfeiture and the
practice of forfeiture so I'm I would
just like you to elaborate a little bit
more on how this would affect your
Department's ability to enforce
forfeiture sure and as I testify I'm I'm
I'm testifying as the bill is introduced
I do not have an amendment in front of
me if there is one and I apologize for
that
um
I'm gonna go off what was Andrews that's
before I started reading through all
that but if anything's changed
um
the way it's worded in the current in
the bill that was introduced is no State
local or law enforcement agency she'll
transfer or offer for an adoption
property seized under state law to a
federal Agency for the purpose of
forfeiture under Federal controlled
substance ACT public law 91-513.
so
Our concern is that if we if we do not
have these federal agencies we have
numerous Task Force officers at a
Manchester police officers assigned to
federal agencies if we do not include
the federal agencies right off the bat
with the initial on-sar onstart of the
initial investigation we will not have
the ability to Forfeit property through
the federal government
and take that case asset forfeiture-wise
through the federal government it's not
uncommon for us to start a case
into a drug trafficker or small level
dealer and we expand the case as we go
we arrest people we conduct more
investigations interviews do our thing
and then as the case expands we realize
that this might be a cross-border
initiative this drug trafficking
organization might be larger in scope we
might need additional resources through
our federal partners and that's when we
bring it to the federal Partners not
always from the OnStar to the
investigation
and we also obviously look into
sentencing guidelines and whatnot that
might be more effective when targeting
follow up and you're saying this
restricts your right to go to the
Captain we have an extra copy of the
amendment if we somebody gave it to you
would you be as kind to review the
amendment and if your opinion or your
stance changes could you let the
committee know would you be willing to
come back and and talk with us after
that of course okay
representative Pratt thank you
as anybody can answer that because it's
a complete rewrite of this bill so the
people that we wrote to Bill can they
I don't think that he can speak for oh
you wanted somebody else that yes oh
okay
this is a complete rewrite of the bill
well that would be that would be
yeah
and they can do Joint Task of course
hey thanks thank you for the question so
so if I understand the question you want
to know
um the relationship between Federal and
and local law enforcement how has it
changed by the bill right so first of
all
nothing about operations has changed
right this is about what happens in
court later on right so
um adoptions is specifically a case
where
um the state level uh state troopers
local police Etc
decide what to do with a case they
decide to call up the Federal prosecutor
and say how would you like to to
prosecute this case or they call up the
County prosecutor or their local I
assume Manchester has their own
prosecutor but
um to prosecute the case right so
this has those kind of cases have gone
to Federal prosecutors nine times of the
last three years
as opposed to the million dollar stuff
that's where federal agents and and
local police have worked together all
along through the case and and they go
to Federal Court frequently right that's
the million dollar stuff the other stuff
we're talking about is Small Potatoes
kind of thing and and this bill does
take those nine cases out of federal
court and puts them in State Court
Senator Newman yeah I just have a quick
question could somebody look at the the
Amendment and just point to where
adoptions are in there I'm trying to
I think
and can I just offer something in
rebuttal to that
um so the the Federal Form I've been
doing this for the last couple years for
the agency in Manchester he says only
nine instances of uh Federal adoptions I
think is how we put it that we that I
guess as a state he can track US taking
through the federal government I would
say that is extremely not accurate and
and only because when we file an
adoption through the federal government
they have obviously a long process to go
through too before the adoption is
either finalized or ruled on and the
wheels of Justice sometimes are not
fast on the federal side either and the
um so we I can tell you that Manchester
I and I'm just I'm ballparking it right
now but probably has well over 50
pending Federal asset forfeiture
adoptions that are still being in a
pending State and I've probably filed
I'm guessing don't hold me to it but
probably 20 or 25 in the last year or so
maybe a year and a half alone I would
guess through the federal government
through the federal agencies as
adoptions
thank you and then just to give you an
idea of what's going on
everybody good
okay seeing no more questions thank you
gentlemen
they weren't answered maybe they can
provide it later on uh
I'm just looking representative Lynn did
you have anything that you could add to
help with the questions that seem not to
doesn't look like
okay it's okay I I was just questioned
oh I'm sorry I I thought the the
question was more about the the
amendment my question was only about
where is it in the bill that discusses
adoptions yes from the federal
government I just would like to be able
to read it if I could find it yeah no no
that's a good one hang on one second I
just had it
um
right yes that's right of the uh of the
amendment it's of the amendment it's
it's on page nine
um it begins on line 33 with subsection
S as in Sam one yep got it okay thank
you great thank you thank you
representative
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Richard head
I'm the government Affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch the judicial
branch has no policy no position on the
policies underlying this bill we have
very strong position relative to the
bill as drafted we opposed the bill is
drafted and believe that the bill is
drafted uh introduces significant
procedural barriers that if it were to
be implemented parts of it would simply
could not be implemented by the judicial
branch and I will explain explain some
of those uh briefly
first though I do want to uh express my
appreciation to the to the sponsor and
the people who've been drafting this
they have been working very hard and I
appreciate that
but at the end of the day it is still
substantially far from a a bill that we
could Implement in the judicial branch
as at least as written
in addition
because I didn't want to simply be
negative about this bill and it's a bill
that's been around for a couple years
now I've been trying to express some of
the concerns that the judicial branch
has I did try a draft of of an amendment
to the current law that I thought at
least implemented a lot of the policies
that we're trying to be implemented
through this bill so I drafted and it's
relatively short a bill that would
change it from being an attorney general
process to a prosecutor process that
would require the public defender to
continue to participate in this where
they are not currently participating
that the forfeiture could not occur
until conviction that the that there be
a minimum value of the property that is
subject to forfeiture and that there be
noticed to interested parties and I
circulated that bill because it was a
version of the bill that we could have
implemented and I was told no that's not
what we want to do it's okay so I went
back to the bill as as their their uh as
they proposed it in the comments I have
will be on the version of it that's the
amendment not the version as as
introduced
and one of the problems is that as as
representative Lynn said you know what
are all the steps can be worked out
essentially that that there's a lot of
discretion given to the courts and there
are Provisions where the court is given
a lot of discretion the problem is this
bill implements through statute specific
steps so we cannot change those steps
through a policy because you are
building into a very long Bill very
precise steps and each of those steps
now has to be followed because it is now
it would be a statute so while there are
Provisions that give discretion such as
timing of certain hearings there are
other things that say okay the statute
says x x is now the law and that's what
has to be done
uh in light of the three minutes I'm not
sure if those were a lawyer three
minutes I would have plenty of time but
I don't I assume you did not mean a
lawyer's three minutes uh I will stick
to although it was a fiscal committee
minute I would have a couple hours or
even days but um
I will I'm just going to identify a
couple of the procedural issues with the
understanding that I can go through
multiple pages in within a page find you
know 10 12 problems that simply have not
been addressed and Mr head if it helps
you I do believe that uh chairman Roy is
going to make a subcommittee for this
legislation it would probably be a great
idea for you to come to that and I'm
always happy and I'm absolutely happy to
participate in this process if there's a
way of improving this bill I'm happy to
to be involved in that process just a
couple of of examples and then I will
stop talking page four beginning on line
seven is a process that is about seizure
so really not even into the forfeiture
process here but we're talking about the
seizure and it gives the right following
seizure for a defendant which is
interesting or any other person with an
interest in the property to have a right
to file uh to a right to a post seizure
hearing okay in and of itself that is
fine
um and then it goes on to parag line
nine it says a person with an interest
in the property May file a motion with
the Superior Court a motion is something
you put into a case
depending on when somebody tries to file
that motion this case may not be in
Superior Court there may be no criminal
case in the Superior Court you go to the
electronic filing system I want to file
a motion and there's nothing to stick
that in because the case might be in the
circuit court it's just a a it's a
technical defect but it is a a process
that is written into the law so the law
has to be accurate and I very much
appreciate the sponsor and Mr McGrath's
efforts to take what was in the original
Bill where put a lot of stuff in the
circuit court and put it in Superior it
is not completely there yet
the other aspect of even just this part
about seizure because it is the
defendant who is who has the right to
opposed seizure hearing that one of the
criteria which is on line 23 would be to
say that the court May order return of
the property if the by a preponderance
of the evidence it finds the seizure
wasn't valid that is in the criminal
case essentially the motion to suppress
hearing the defendant has the right to
file a motion to suppress hearing to say
that the evidence that you gathered was
unconstitutionally got whatever it may
be that is a a
motion to suppress hearing that is now
being heard through the separate process
in Superior Court where that may not be
you know it really should just be that's
a part of the Criminal Case itself and
not
a separate doesn't need the separate
statute
another part of of and I'll make this my
last example understanding there are a
ton of them page four still this is
beginning in line 28 where the forfeits
are part of the of the bill starts and
it says that the motion
um in a case in which the state seeks
forfeiture of property the state shall
file with the court emotion for
forfeiture that motion shall be a
separate document and accompany the
initial or subsequent indictment or
information so in Superior Court the
indictment process doesn't have a motion
filed with it and it normally wouldn't
because the indictment is a grand jury
process so prosecutors working with the
grand jury ultimately gets to a point
where the prosecutor
provides the grand jury with a proposed
indictment prosecutor leaves the
proposed indictment then is discussed
and voted on by the grand jury if they
decide to indict Foreman signs and the
clerk then picks up the indictment and
it becomes a court case the prosecutor
doesn't have a motion to file in that
proceeding at that stage but it is
required that it be that by Statute that
the motion shall be a separate document
and accompany the initial
indictment so it is it is in the current
process not something that would be
contemplated I could do it Page by page
I won't
um uh and I will end my comments with
that and be happy to answer questions
representative you have a question I
just have a question for you I'm just
wondering if you could explore the
possibility that since this is a public
hearing probably not the place to do all
of this that whether there's a
subcommittee or not a subcommittee that
at whatever hearings we have here we
would be able to get information from
the appropriate people to answer our
questions about things that are as
complicated to this thank you thank you
representative Newman so uh before
chairman Roy left for this afternoon he
did tell me that if this got to be as
interesting as it did that he certainly
would be be willing to create a
subcommittee I do not feel that I'm the
best person to say who those members are
going to be so when we all meet back
here tomorrow morning at 9 30
I will ask him if we can just address
this quickly so that we're all here and
I'm sure at that time people will point
one and we will be in contact with the
stakeholders to be sure that you guys
are invited to any kind of work sessions
that happen with that thank you very
much thank you is there anybody that
wishes to testify on this bill that has
not turned in a pink card
seeing none to close the public hearing
for house bill
where are we at
um 593 and we will open the public
the chair recognizes representative
so
um Hello I'm
Eric Gallagher the representative from
Concord Ward 6 which is Merrimack County
District 20.
I'm here to introduce House Bill
589 prohibiting state and local law
enforcement from participating
in the enforcement of copyright claims
against free and open source software
projects so um
one of my
one of my top issues is software Freedom
the freedom basically to
use computers the way you want to
without being controlled by
governments or large corporations
um so um I say software freedom because
if I say free software you might think
it's just a matter of price but it's
free Us in Freedom as in a matter of
being able to do with it as you wish
um
in other languages that's the uh it
would be free would be translated as
Libre rather than gratis
so last term I had
a bill the securing our freedom to write
and read everything or software act
which was a big Omnibus that contained a
lot of different things
I wanted to do to print out software
Freedom
um
since it was an Omnibus it went before
Edna
and uh
their feedback was that I was trying to
do too much in a single Bill and
recommended that I
split it up into separate bills to try
again this term so that's what I'm doing
um
so most of the
uh most of the bills
that it got split up into
went before Edna again but a few went to
different commands like this one is the
criminal justice part and then there was
also another part that went to Judiciary
so
um
this part is
specifically
yeah this part is like the one small
part of it that intersects with criminal
justice
um
one of the issues that it came across
when
um trying to think about how to protect
software freedom is that a lot of
a lot of the law relevant to it is
actually Federal level legislation and
there's not really much
that we can do about that at the state
level but
um we have had other bills
previously
to um
express our state level opinion on
federal laws so for example
um we had if you're on the right think
of this like the
bills to
prevent law enforcement from helping to
enforce
firearm executive orders or if you're on
the left think of this more like a
sanctuary
City type
in this case it's specifically for uh
developers of
free and open source software so
a lot of the times
one of the big barriers to contributing
so these are
these are software projects that are in
the public interest that everyone
benefits from so like some of the big
ones uh
would be Linux or Firefox or Wikipedia
and one of the things that makes
developers reluctant to contribute to um
these sometimes is just fear of
persecution from the uh
big tech companies that might come after
them
um
so
this bill is
just kind of a way of sending a message
to those developers that
well okay New Hampshire is
a safe place for you to contribute from
without having to worry about big Tech
um coming after you I know there's been
a lot of frustration with big Tech on
both sides of the aisle
um you know on the left it's more just
for being big on the right it's for
claims of censorship or whatever so I
think
um
this bill could be a good way to uh
send
a message to big Tech that we're not
going to be helping them anymore so
um
so it doesn't actually
it doesn't make anything
that's currently illegal into something
that's legal
um it
um so it violating copyright would still
be illegal under this since that's the
federal jurisdiction it is just
a way of sending a message that we're
not going to
help the federal government in their job
of Prosecuting it
um
so
yeah looking at the fiscal note
um
so
the municipal Association the
association of County said that local
law enforcement doesn't do that any
anyways so you could
you could could hear that and think okay
well why do we need this then
well I think even if it doesn't
necessarily have a practical impact I
still think it's worth passing just to
send a symbolic
message that
um
we support
developers of free and open source
software and that they should
feel welcome to come here and contribute
to free and open source software
projects from here without having to
worry about big tech companies coming
after them
um
so
yeah it's a
um
yeah one other term
so yeah I guess I um
representative could you just in like
one sentence sum up what exactly what
this bill does for us please so
um yeah it just says no no member of law
enforcement in the state of New
Hampshire or any of his political
subdivisions to assist federal law
enforcement and any investigation or
prosecution of copyright claims or other
claims of intellectual property crimes
brought by makers of proprietary
software against makers of competing
free and open source software projects
so
um free software often defines itself in
opposition to proprietary software which
is
ones where um the big tech companies uh
claim IPO over it
um so
um
basically it's it's saying like if you
want to contribute to Libra office then
um and you want to contribute to it from
New Hampshire and Microsoft wants to
come after you because they think you're
violating their IP then New Hampshire is
not going to help Microsoft in that case
that's basically just it's going to be
up to Microsoft and the federal
government to
pursue those claims on their own
um so yeah that's the bill and I'll take
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so just to clarify
essentially what we're saying is that
New Hampshire is not going to help
what is essentially weaponizing uh our
our law enforcement against smaller
companies that are considered
competition for larger companies or well
yeah they could be companies
um or they could just be hobbyists
people
um contributing to these projects in
their spare time or
non-profits or
representative Muse
since the the software projects you're
talking about are free and open source
one of the things I'm curious about is
how often is copyright an issue with
open source software projects I thought
the whole idea of Open Source was open
source
well yes
um so
um
yeah so
a project can be
um open source and also have its own
um
copyright document
saying
how specifically you're allowed to copy
it um there's this form of copyright
called copy left for example where it
says basically if you're going to copy
it you have to let anyone else
have the same
rights as you're granting them
so yeah oftentimes
oftentimes
um
where it comes into effect in affecting
these contributions uh is just
influencing developer Behavior as to
whether they want to contribute or not
in the first place
um oftentimes developers will just be
afraid
to contribute um
because of proprietary software
companies
um
like I've seen developers say oh yeah
I'd love to fix this bug but I can't
because I've seen the source code of
um this
com this other competing product
um so yeah um
yeah it kind of ties in with
non-competes a bit one of my other parts
of one of the other bills that this was
broken up into was to
focus specifically on the interaction of
non-competes
with free software but um that's a
separate bill so
thank you for your testimony
good afternoon my name is Jeff Charles
and I'm associate attorney general's New
Hampshire Attorney General's office
I'm here to answer any questions you
have about this but also to oppose the
bill and I'll explain why
um we pose a bill because of the
collateral consequences that will that
will stem from this bill and it starts
with the understanding that
you know the term big Tech was used big
Tech doesn't prosecute cases or as the
bill says I think at one point bring
crimes
crimes are charged and investigated by
law enforcement agencies and prosecutors
they're the only arm in our state and
federal government that can bring
criminal actions and so this bill is
targeted at the actions of federal law
enforcement authorities in New Hampshire
and because it's so Broad in its
parameters it would mean that if federal
law enforcement authorities were to come
to New Hampshire and investigate one of
these cases try to execute a search
warrant or an arrest warrant that local
New Hampshire authorities could not
participate in any way shape or form to
do the most basic things they do with
regards to safety whenever another law
enforcement agency comes into New
Hampshire which is they would coordinate
with that agency just to provide basic
safety like traffic control
um
to help them in case somebody were to
try to escape or commit other crimes in
this process so essentially this would
say that Federal authorities could come
into New Hampshire would not have to
coordinate at all with New Hampshire
authorities essentially not even give
them notice because that might violate
this provision of assisting and would
would not have any idea and suddenly get
a phone call that there's you know
Men In Black SUVs breaking into a home
and
and then obviously the locals would go
there and who knows what could happen in
that situation so normally when one
agency whether it's federal or state or
local goes into another jurisdiction New
Hampshire that agency gives that local
agency a heads up
um they often coordinate with them and
they may have to again assist them with
basic Public Safety things just like
crowd control and scene control and this
bill would prohibit that completely and
so we just want to bring that to your
attention that it actually would create
potential public safety issues because
of it's such a broad reach and again the
bill talks about
uses the term intellectual property
crimes brought by makers a proprietary
software
private citizens can't bring criminal
actions like this it has to be brought
by a law enforcement agency or or a
prosecutor they can certainly make
complaints that hey somebody's doing
something and that may violate the law
but private companies can't bring
criminal actions so not sure that this
bill sends the message that it's
intended to send but it definitely would
have collateral consequences against New
Hampshire law enforcement agencies state
and local and their ability just to do
the basic things they would need to do
to assist another agency here even if it
wasn't something we agreed with again we
wouldn't want our folks just to not get
noticed and not be able to participate
if something goes sideways that's their
job
and that's all those are all the
comments I have I'm happy to answer
questions
do you have any comment on we have a lot
of bills this session it seems like
where the state of New Hampshire shall
not
use any funds to assist federal law
enforcement to do X Y or Z is this
similar to that is this different than
those kind of laws that we that we're
going to be seeing this year this is
this is different because it's not
directed at funds directly I guess maybe
indirectly it is because you're saying
law enforcement can't do certain things
in New Hampshire so maybe indirectly it
is this bill is actually more focused
and then it says you know what it says
is you know about you know no member of
law enforcement in the state of New
Hampshire shall assist and again that
word assist is very very broad so at
least in this context it's because the
limitation is so Broad and again
just the way that law enforcement Works
in New Hampshire where if somebody goes
someone else's jurisdiction you get
noticed you assist them and it wouldn't
be hey help us with the search warrant
it's just like hey can you make sure
that a bunch of people don't come on the
property or if somebody tries to escape
you can block that road off basic things
like that that they would not be able to
do here so it's a little bit different
than those bills maybe some would argue
it gets at the same thing but it's a
little bit more targeted here
thank you very much is there anybody
else wishing to testify on this bill
that has not turned in a pink card thank
you
seeing none I will close the public
hearing for house bill
the committee recognizes representative
Siebert if you could just make sure you
fill out a pink card after you after
done introducing the bill that'd be
great yeah that's good thank you thank
okay
I forgot it was 30 on
it all right thank you
um sorry
um I just first of all want to thank
um all the members of the committee for
being here today
um to hear the proposed legislation
hb624fn
um
so the first point I want to make is
this minimizes the burden of federal
immigration checkpoints on New Hampshire
motorists
it would when informed by a federal
agency require state county or Municipal
law enforcement to provide the public
with up to 24 hours notice that a
federal agency intends to conduct an
immigration checkpoint
the notice shall disclose if known the
date municipality and geographical area
in which the checkpoint will occur
in recent years CPP has ramped up
temporary interior Border Patrol
checkpoints in Northern New England
staging at least 10 temporary
checkpoints in the interior of New
Hampshire from 2017 to 2019.
during seven checkpoints in Woodstock
New Hampshire
CBP agents inspected each vehicle with a
canine test with searching for drugs
it is essential to note
this took place throughout the height of
the tourism season including holiday
weekends and events that played a
critical role in the economy
of nearby municipalities and communities
these include during Father's Day
weekend Memorial Day Weekend along with
the second point I want to make is that
this notice helps to minimize the
intrusion and negative impact of
checkpoints on New Hampshire motorists
so during Federal immigration
checkpoints federal agents stopped and
seize thousands of individuals traveling
through New Hampshire's roadways without
probable cause a reasonable suspicion
that a crime has been committed this
legislation would bring immigration
checkpoints under similar notice
requirements to those already required
for sobriety checkpoints
under New Hampshire law advance notice
is provided for sobriety checkpoints in
part two as the Attorney General
indicates in
New Hampshire law enforcement manual
minimize motorist surprise
apprehension and inconvenience end quote
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
looked representative Siebert if you
could
um you're reading what you just handed
out to us yeah right if you could just
summarize basically what this says and
will we have this to read that oh okay
thank you all right well I mean
generally that all we're asking for is
so
um
it's an undue burden on the motorists on
on the locals as well
um tourism here let me sum up the end
part
is also this legislation mirrors another
that overwhelmingly passed in the house
and I strongly urge you to support
hb624fn to help minimize the burden for
all New Hampshire motorists and Aid in
the recovery of our Statewide tourism
are there any questions
so hi I'm uh representative Gallagher
again
um I would like to testify in support of
this bill
um it's
similar to a bill
that uh this this body passed last term
and I thought it had actually already
gone
into law and when was surprised to
discover that no it had actually
um
so I think it's worth giving another try
um yeah I have
um
I I have encountered these
checkpoints might so often would
definitely have uh appreciated the
notice of them beforehand
um and yeah I'll keep it short and
Sebastian Fuentes
thank you Mom chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Sebastian Fuentes movement politics
director of horizon democracy an
organization the advocates for fair
housing Equitable Access to Health Care
responsible climate initiatives and
public education and also immigration
and racial justice but I'm here to ask
you to support hb624 because otherwise
we'll be violating our fourth amendment
rights the Constitution to the four
amendment protects people from a
reasonable searches
by the government
I'm in front of you as one of the many
U.S citizens and New Hampshire residents
that stop under no suspicion by border
patrol here in New Hampshire
I lived in Thornton just miles away from
the Woodstock Thornton area where border
patrols are set on I-93
I travel that way to go to work I travel
that way to go grab my children from a
school to do errands some from a simple
as grocery shopping
as you some of you guys might know CBP
has authority over 100 miles from any
border that includes the coastline of
New Hampshire a hundred miles from
Canada going south and 100 miles from
Portsmouth going west
to be more specific border patrol can
stop you while you're riding your
motorcycle on your way to Laconia Bike
Week
like that happened before they can stop
you Nasha while going to your local
Market Basket they can stop your hand
over while driving to get Medical Care
at Dartmouth Medical Center they can
stop you while grabbing a cup of coffee
at your local Dunkin Donuts all in New
Hampshire
now when these checkpoints were
happening
I was performing a whole completely
different job than what I have right now
I was working in the hospitality
industry up in the north country
numerous times I received phone calls
from guests and co-workers asking me if
these checkpoints were happening during
specific holidays
holidays like the Labor Day weekend
Memorial Day Fourth of July and
sometimes during Laconia by week
during that week CBP detained drivers
carrying a small amount of marijuana
thus far from enforcing immigration
during one of these stops
one of the officers told me that they
were going to have the state police
arrest me for obstructing the flow of
traffic even though they stopped me
they didn't have original suspicion for
they pulled me aside for after that they
put me aside for a secondary inspection
they run my tax and they left me go
after a brief 10 minute episode
during another occasion I was to stop
close to an hour with a couple of
friends
one of them of Muslim Muslim Origins was
wearing a hijab
we didn't comply in following our
further memorize
CBP officers told us to stay in our
vehicles windows up while they were
processing
mind you this was in the middle of
summer with the windows down
with the windows app I'm sorry it gets
really hot inside a vehicle I told the
officer the border patrol officer that I
have breathing issues because I suffer
from chronic asthma
and you need to get some fresh air my
request was ignore keep your windows up
right before the right before the hour
the CBP officer came back with a
clipboard
and in that clipboard you can see that
Facebook profile picture of the driver
my Muslim friends a photo a personal
photo that she does not use for any
purpose not her driver's license or no
her citizenship leadership forms this
was her Facebook profile picture
CBP sets these checkpoints with the
purpose of immigration enforcement that
do not work
we stop and detain people for minor
marijuana possessions
and not for being here illegally
these checkpoints are detrimental for
businesses especially in the hospitality
industry
but most importantly these checkpoints
leave a mark of unfairness
for those that go abide by the law
I traveled to I-93 regularly
I live just miles away like I mentioned
earlier
fortunately enough all these stops
happen while my family including my
children were not in the vehicle I pray
to God that they never get to experience
the level of harassment from federal
agencies
it happens aborig Crossings and other
points of Entry
but it can also happen in any point in
any New Hampshire town inside the 100
modu jurisdiction
by that means every time that you also
serve
if Americans do not continue to
challenge expansion of federal power
over the individual we risk for feeding
the fundamental rights and freedoms that
we narrated including the right to
Simply go about our business free from
government intrusion harassment or abuse
I also want to mention that on one of
the main plaintiffs on a federal lawsuit
case
that we have file with the uh the folks
with the SLU against the U.S Customs and
Border Border Protection Agency that is
currently in the U.S District Court in
New Hampshire we're challenging the
constitutionality of these checkpoints
so I ask you to please support hb624 to
improve their relationship between law
enforcement federal or estate and to
give the granite Staters the freedom to
travel and bother thank you so much and
I will take any questions if you have
any
what would you say to people
who would maintain that the experience
that you and your family go through is
part of the price that we have to pay
to secure our borders in this country
you know I I
acknowledge that our boards needs to be
secure that's absolutely uh you know
something that is fundamental four hours
Homeland Security uh a hundred miles
from the border I find it a little bit
more intrusive if you do a border
checkpoint maybe 10 miles 15 miles from
you know from the Canadian line Derby
line the Newport line I find that
acceptable that's more reasonable but a
hundred miles that's all the main all of
New Hampshire half of Massachusetts
is most you know two-thirds of the
population in the U.S Leaf in the 100
mile jurisdiction so that's that's
that's my concern so why is happening
you know these checkpoints happen in
Portsmouth and I-95 it happens on 993 it
happened in Clermont I don't remember
the is like Clermont exit Windsor exit
it happens all the time uh it hasn't
happened for the last since Kobe
happened but in the past in the past he
did many times
so
thank you so much thank you for your
testimony
thank you madam chair and members of
this committee my name is Carlos Cardona
and I am from Laconia New Hampshire I'm
also uh here as myself but I figured
also worth noting that I'm also
commissioner of the New Hampshire native
American Affairs
I am in favor of this bill I think it is
the right thing to do
um
as being from laconian as it was alluded
to earlier has an impact on tourism of
course in The Lakes Region but I also
have a letter here that I would like to
read to you all from the New Hampshire
immigrants rights Network which I do not
represent but I have the uh the honor to
read to you all and it's short quick
uh dear uh chairperson Roy and member of
the House criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee we are submitting this
letter on behalf of the New Hampshire
immigrant rights Network a coalition of
New Hampshire organizations and
individuals working with and within
immigrant communities to improve the
lives and ensure just treatment we
support hb624 Dash FN which would
require a state county or Municipal law
enforcement agency to give timely public
notice when informed by federal agency
of its intent to conduct to conduct an
immigration checkpoint we urge members
of this committee to support hb624 FN
and vote ought to pass
immigration checkpoints in New Hampshire
have been used for unlawful purposes
some of the background from 2017 through
2020 the U.S custom and Border
Protection conducted at least 10
immigration checkpoints in Northern New
England including New Hampshire most
were conducted on major highways and
several were carried on during high
volume holidays such as Memorial Day
Weekend Father's Day weekend and
laconian Bike Week thousands of people
were waylaid and forced through the
checkpoints it is questionable whether
CBP even had an expectation of
apprehending unlawful border crossers of
that of the relatively small number of
people detained the largest number of
detentions was for lawfully percent
present people who were arrested for
State drug drug law violations the
number of migrants detained for alleged
unlawful presence was quite small and
there is no evidence that any had
crossed over the Canadian border
the checkpoints caused Great
consternation within immigrant
communities among civil rights and
immigrant immigrant rights organizations
lawmakers and many others a significant
number of New Hampshire residents and
visitors and visitors to our state were
prevented from going about their
business and were subjected to Long
delays and inconvenience a number were
unlawfully detained or arrested people
perceived to be immigrants were targeted
concerns were also raised about the
effects on local businesses the
situation was sufficiently troubling
that in Num in November 2019 members of
the Northern New England Congressional
Delegation wrote to the acting
Commissioner of CBP
demanding and accounting in August 2020
the New Hampshire ACLU along with
Partners filed a lawsuit asserting
constitutional rights violations on
behalf of two U.S citizens who were
detained
adding New Hampshire checkpoint with one
being subjected to a search arrested and
charged with a state law drug crime the
lawsuit is still active and ACLU is
seeking relief that would that uh that
would determine that its clients were
subject subjected to unlawful seizures
prevented CBP from conducting
unconstitutional checkpoints activities
and declare that any enforcement
benefits and checkpoints are outweighed
by the harm to individual rights to our
knowledge no additional immigration
checkpoints have occurred in New
Hampshire since the ACLU lawsuit was
filed the sole legitimate purpose of
immigration checkpoints is to prevent
unlawful entry into the United States
both the New Hampshire and U.S
Constitution prohibits unlawful searches
and seizures
which generally must be based on
probable cause one highly regulated
exceptionist in U.S Customs and Border
Protection border enforcement
checkpoints immigrant immigration
checkpoints are permitted for areas
within 100 miles of the U.S border for
the sole purpose of preventing unlawful
entry into the United States immigration
checkpoints may not be used as fishing
Expeditions of any sort including
searching for drugs or other Contraband
they should not be used as a tool to
locate undocumented immigrants or
migrants within the U.S unfortunately
CBP immigrant checkpoints in our state
have been used as a dragnets Rife with
potential or actual civil rights
violations
the decision to conduct an immigration
checkpoint must be balanced against the
harm it opposes protocols must be put in
place to ensure that the checkpoints are
not used for unlawful purposes such as
drug investigations as they apparently
were in the most recent checkpoints
operation and discriminate and and they
indiscriminate use of checkpoints also
increase the risk of racial profiling in
other civil rights violations as people
perceive to be immigrants are subject to
heightened scrutiny and detention in
fact there is no evidence that
conducting checkpoints in New Hampshire
will ever yield results sufficiently to
justifying the harm they cause
for this reason we urge you to vote for
hb624--fn as ought to pass sincerely
Maggie forwardy Grace kindeki American
friends and services Committee in
Concord New Hampshire Eva Castillo New
Hampshire Alliance of immigrants and
refugees in Manchester Sebastian Fuentes
New Hampshire rights and democracy
Conquer New Hampshire Maha Smith
Canterbury citizens for democracy in
Canterbury the Rubber and Hayes Junction
Episcopal Church of New Hampshire in
Milford New Hampshire
Sarah Jane Noe Granite State organizing
project Manchester New Hampshire
Veronica Colby Granite State organizing
project in Lebanon New Hampshire Judith
Reed
Keen immigrant and Refugee partnership
in Keene New Hampshire Melissa heimbach
Kent Street Coalition in Concord New
Hampshire Enrique F Mesa Junior Esquire
Mesa law in Manchester Reverend Heidi
Carrington health I mean SAR Heath New
Hampshire Council of churches in Exeter
Christine Wellington New Hampshire
immigrant of Rights and new rights New
Hampshire immigrant rights Network in
Derry and Carolyn Gordon share in
good afternoon Madam chair thank you for
good afternoon my name is Mark Hall I'm
a major commander of the operations
Bureau with the New Hampshire State
Police
we don't
take a bill a
position on this bill at this time but
I'm here to provide some educational
testimony as to how the bill is written
we're not responsible the state police
is not responsible for Federal Highway
checkpoints or immigration enforcement
we are responsible for Highway Safety
as far as managing managing highway
safety when these checkpoints are
conducted they do can they do uh
create a highway safety concern
particularly on the interstate highways
and our job is to continue to provide
Public Safety on those highways during
the the events
also to provide backup when requested
and also enforce state laws
something to consider with this bill is
the notification from border patrol we
don't we don't often have an exact time
frame of when border patrol would notify
us that they're going to do a checkpoint
however uh
complying with this bill border patrol
would likely not notify us
in the future of these checkpoints which
would further limit our abilities to
provide Public Safety on the highways
when we don't know about the checkpoint
taking place so it has asked that you
consider that with the way this bill is
written
we are generally notified but
it's very likely that we wouldn't be uh
under this bill that's all I have them
it'll take any questions if you have
them
representative wheeler
Madam chair
um so you're saying the federal
government wouldn't notify the New
Hampshire state government of a border
patrol checkpoint if this legislation
this is all in my opinion is
um there's no requirement necessarily
for them to notify us when they do
notify us that there's a checkpoint
taking place we're not assisting them
with the checkpoint we're just ensuring
that there's Public Safety however I
would assume that us notifying the
public ahead of time of those
checkpoints would only cause them to not
want to notify us
they're going to do the checkpoints
regardless of whether we
participate or help them in any way
they're going to do the checkpoints and
quite honestly I would rather be
informed that the checkpoints are going
to take place so that we can provide
what our mission is and that's highway
safety Public Safety
so the federal government could have a
checkpoint on our roadways without the
knowledge of the state police
I could see representative Eaton nodding
his head back there thank you okay
just a quick question
is the is the public still notified if
there's going to be a sobriety
checkpoint
thank you is there any more questions
representative Muse
are you aware of any other states that
have a provision like this
uh no sir I'm not I'm not aware of any
uh that doesn't mean there isn't but I'm
not aware of any
see no more questions thank you for your
testimony thank you
uh Madam chair members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is Frank connect
policy director with the ACLU New
Hampshire and I'm here with my colleague
Jill Bissonnet our legal director nice
to see everyone thank you
and Geo came he's actually litigating
the case that was referenced earlier so
in case there's any questions we wanted
to make sure that we could answer those
um
so I want to touch on on a few things I
have a handout and you'll see in the
handout there's an attachment to that
which has the
um law enforcement Manual of the State
of New Hampshire which includes the
sobriety checkpoint language and so the
intent of this bill is really to mirror
the sobriety checkpoint language and if
you look at the manual that I attached
in there the attorney Attorney General
indicates in the manual that the the
importance of sobriety checkpoint notice
is to quote minimize motor surprise
apprehension and inconvenience and we're
just trying to bring that same standard
in that same notice and protection to
immigration checkpoints that are
happening here
um I also really want to I would like to
flag that this bill came out of the
house last year with a vote of 254 to 85
with overwhelming bipartisan support
this is an issue that's been looked at
heavily by this committee by this body
and so we are optimistic and hopeful
that you all will
consider that
um when you're when you're debating this
year
so as you heard
um
we've heard the primary purpose of of
these immigration checkpoints is is to
try and get
um to stop
the screening for immigration violations
and so we've heard that over and over
again as the justification for that and
so fortunately through litigation you
don't have to listen to just what you
know we at the ACL you have to say we
can actually look at what a judge the
judge found and so
um in a case
um New Hampshire versus McCarthy
um in the second circuit
um this is directly from the opinion
quote this court finds that while the
stated purpose of the checkpoints in
this matter was screening for
immigration violations the primary
purpose of the action was the detection
and Caesar of drugs and the reason that
that's important is because New
Hampshire's Constitution unlike our
neighbors in Maine for example
protects it says that the Supreme Court
has found that when employing trained
canines to sniff a private person's
vehicle in order to determine whether
controlled substances are concealed
inside is certainly a search in these
terms and that therefore there has to be
an articulable and reasonable suspicion
of criminal activity to engage to use
the canine and so because under our
state law under the state constitution
we can't use drugs in that instance to
just pull people over and search without
any reasonable suspension
border patrol are able to do that and
get and run around New Hampshire law and
if you notice about how this has worked
in practice it'll often be coordinated
with local police and so CBP will do the
searches they'll have the dog sniffs if
they find drugs then they will actually
turn that over to local law enforcement
the prosecute under state law so what
you're really seeing here is a complete
end run around our Constitution which we
think is wrong and shouldn't be
happening
and again when when we when we heard
from CBP is that this is really about
trying to get uh people coming over
illegally and so again looking at the
opinion
um they know in the opinion that the CBP
officer testified quote that he has
never located a concealed human in a
motor vehicle in his 17 years of service
and so this is not happening again this
is really about searching for drugs it's
about and run about the around the
Constitution
um and you know finally this is not
putting any real burden on local law
enforcement there is no affirmative
obligation of law enforcement to go out
and seek information about whether or
not these are happening if they find out
there's they're happening then they're
required to provide notice but they're
given wide latitude on what type of how
they provide that notice so we're not
saying they have to do X Y or Z they can
use any of their multiple tools at their
discretion to provide that notice um and
so the you know the notion that as we
heard from State Police that they're not
going to find out about this well you
know the court found that this is really
about finding you know and run around
the Constitution around finding drugs
and so it's it's unlikely that that's
yes I would just note that I
I think it's clear that whenever these
checkpoints occur State Police is
notified they could be given a
significant time duration a lot of
notice or they can be given a little
amount of notice
um but regardless under this legislation
all it's just saying is when you find
out whenever it is it could be one
moment before the checkpoint starts
right or it could be a week before the
checkpoint starts just provide notice on
a timely basis to the population we do
know at some point in the process the
state police is going to become aware of
a checkpoint right because they're
obviously Traffic Safety implications
that the state police testify to so
again all this is saying is once they
become aware whenever that is
send out a tweet or do you know
literally you don't there's there's no
massive requirement here on the state
police to do anything or any law
enforcement body that that uh becomes
aware of a checkpoint so I just wanted
to make that clear thank you
thank you
representative Newman
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I'm looking at the state law for
sobriety checkpoints and the requirement
is there that the court issues and
orders authorizing sobriety checkpoint
after determining that the sobriety
checkpoint is warranted and the proposed
method of stopping Vehicles satisfies
constitutional guarantees
so that's for that's for sobriety
checkpoints
um and I've heard you now say that there
are state laws that would apply to you
know you quoted court cases that said
there are state laws that require
notification
is that in procedures or rules or I'm
confused because I can't find it in
state law there's there's a reason it's
actually it's it's part of the
Department of Justice law enforcement
manual
so uh and I believe I don't know if that
was attached it it should be attached
and that's that's where the 24-hour
figure comes from again trying to as
closely as one could try to mirror that
process
so there is no state law that
specifically either for DWI checkpoints
or
or for these checkpoints would require
what what is I mean it puts a lot of
detail in here that detail is in that
handbook
yes okay thank you and what we've done
is we've circled the relevant provisions
of the handbook that deal with sobriety
checkpoints
um and that's that's is what we use as a
benchmark here and trying to draft this
legislation
thank you
are there any more questions
oh
representative Murray thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I was just wondering if either
of you had any comment on what the
commander mentioned earlier about you
know if say this passes and now um you
know currently it seems like federal law
enforcement does notify State Police
when they're doing these checkpoints so
that they can ensure highway safety and
so say this bill passes and now they no
longer give them notification because
they want to get around this public
notification that the state police would
be required to do I was just wondering
if that you have any comment on the
impacts that could have respectfully
with all due respect the state police
that seemed like more of a hunch to me
than anything else I mean I I think it's
an opinion my opinion is that in
practice they are absolutely going to be
notified at some point because they have
to be because they are the relevant
state agency that is managing the
traffic safety implications of the
checkpoint so
um respectfully I just fundamentally
disagree at some point during this
process whether it's with significant
notice or small relatively small amount
notice they will be notified they have
to be notified and all this bill again
says is once that happens let the public
know
representative Muse oh sorry can I just
follow up on that real quick and also
just to to reiterate what the um State
Police said in their testimony they said
this is I wrote down notes and not
verbatim but that these checkpoints
create a highway safety concern and so
the notion that the federal government
wouldn't provide notice when something
the state police is saying is creating a
highway traffic concern would be
problematic in in its own right
representative Muse
yes um
the bill that is in front of us today is
this essentially uh HP 579 from 2022 as
amended by the committee
so there should be an amendment that I
think will be brought before you that
would make it mirror the original intent
was to have it mirror the amended
version from last year there's an
amendment that will make sure that they
there is I think there was an issue with
OLS but they'll be
I think there should be an amendment
before you for that thank you
good
thank you very much
thank you
is there anybody else wishing to testify
on this bill that has not turned in a
pink card
seeing none I will close the public
foreign we will open the public hearing
for everybody that is here in the public
we have quite a few people that wish to
testify I I think we have 10 cards so
after the sponsor is done taking the
time that he needs we are going to
implement a three-minute time limit on
the testimony
representative Barry the floor is yours
thank you uh chairman Rose I like that
chairman I like that
um a good afternoon uh late afternoon my
name is Ross Berry I'm the state
representative for Hillsboro 39
representing uh the South the south end
of Manchester and the Far East Side
wards six eight and nine I'm here today
to introduce House Bill 653 which deals
with personal cognizance bail for uh
repeat Baileys and violent arrests so I
don't need to probably with this
committee explain what PR bail or
cashless bail is I'm sure you all know
what it is but I'd like to start off
this Committee hearing with two numbers
uh the first one is eight eight uh eight
is the number of times my constituent
Daniel Whitmore was stabbed to death by
a man who was out on double PR bail so
let's talk about Mr Whitmore Mr Whitmore
was a resident of Manchester ward 8. he
was out at 10 30 in the morning on
Friday out by nut Pawn in Ward 9 which I
also represent he was a 75-year resident
of the Queen City a veteran of the Armed
Forces and on his walk down nut Pond he
met a homeless man from Mississippi who
had been arrest tested twice before and
this man stabbed him to death eight
times
that's relevant because this man was
arrested recently before in Nashua for
resisting an altercation he had with the
police a violent altercation he had with
the police but he was out on bail on
cashless PR bail before that for
threatening to stab someone
so he was out on PR bail for threatening
to stab someone and then he stabbed
someone to death eight times in Cold
Blood he then ran to the Walmart on Gold
Street traumatized God knows how many
children covered in his victim's blood
so if you don't think we have a PR bail
problem we have a PR bail problem
the other number is 700. you've heard
this number before 700 is the number of
arrests in the last year in Manchester
alone for people who were already out on
Pay on bail
we have a serious problem
the language you have in front of you is
the result of the product of last year's
work so the bill that sailed through the
house two to one the Senate modified and
it died in Committee of conference
effectively due to a drafting error so
you have it passed it passed Committee
of conference but it died to a drafting
error so here we have the hopefully
corrected language
um
uh something needs to be done
people cannot wait anymore it's not just
a Manchester problem uh it is a problem
throughout the state it obviously
impacts Manchester disproportionately
given that we are the state's largest
city and we have the county jail
um in our city
um
it's very straightforward there are
certain crimes that are listed I'm happy
to kill it through some of them if you
think people should be given cashless
bail for the distribution of child
sexual abuse images
um good on you I disagree and the other
part of obviously is if you're already
out on bail you will not be given cash
bail cashless bail again you will see a
judge the judge May issue you a bail for
a penny that's the judge's business but
you're not going to be walking out
scot-free
the state has a compelling interest to
protect the community
we must balance that with people's
rights that they are innocent until
proven guilty but bail is not just about
are you going to show up to trial
there is a compelling State interest to
protect the community so that's what
this is trying to do it's trying to find
that middle ground of how do we respect
what are the good parts of PR bail right
because the good parts of PR bail is we
do not want to hold poor or Indigent
people
in jail for low-level crimes that they
may not have committed right we could
probably actually all agree on that but
when you start com you start getting
accused of certain serious crimes or
you're being arrested repeatedly in a
short period of time we have to take a
better look for you and PR bail is not
the appropriate solution
I I gave an interview the other day and
I said I hate to be that guy but people
are literally dying uh it's was really
um upsetting to me that
it was my constituent and we had a
meeting
um we had a safety meeting in ward 9.
and we got up there and of course you
know people are playing politics and
trying to pass the blame and I got out
there and I said no this is actually the
state of New Hampshire's fault Mr
Whitmore would have been alive had this
been in law that man would have not been
out on double PR bail
um
he'd be alive today so this is a serious
problem I respect those of you who
support the concept of PR bail I try to
protect
the core principle that we can all agree
in but balance in the issue of the
safety of the community and I would be
stunned if there weren't questions so
oops
so we were so close representative Muse
representative news you recognize ask
your question thank you um uh you
mentioned that your current bill is very
close to HB 1476
um and I do know that there were there
were issues with the bill at the end
which is one of the reasons it didn't go
over the goal line are there are there
any differences between the bill
um that is in front of us now and uh
1476 the last time we saw it in the
house
um it's very similar it did get amended
and 1476 to get amended so we brought
back this is basically the hybrid of the
original 1476 and the hybrid of the
original uh Senate package
this is a two this is arrested on second
for all offenses one of the compliments
prizes last time was we dropped it down
to three arrests for class B
misdemeanors uh I have since pulled that
off of the table given that one of my
constituents was murdered so
sorry I'm sorry I'm not sorry about that
but I I pulled that off that was a
concession we gave honestly I don't
believe it got us any more votes than it
would have originally so I didn't feel
representative Newman
I don't want to see you be stunned so we
got two questions
um
um in in the particular case that you
mentioned
um was the person was that it was the
case that he got uh didn't have bail on
and the first one was that adjudicated
was he convicted of that or was just it
was just a charge and the second was
also was just a charge is that the
correct correct he was charged with
threatening to stab someone and fighting
a police officer okay but he was charged
thank you correct and he was out on
cashless bail and so now on the second
one he was just charged oh sorry
follow-ups
I was trying to hurry
correct and I I appreciate the the
underlying what you're trying to get to
the underlying concept it hasn't been
proven guilty right that's what you're
trying that's what you're I love to do
that in election law too so I appreciate
it
um
once again there's a compelling State
entrance to balance the right of of
pre-trial offended a pre-trial the
accused pre-trial right with the safety
of the community
I don't think anybody up here would
think that we hit the balancing act with
thank you representative actually
relatively short all right cool this is
the benefit of a four o'clock hearing
good afternoon again Madam chair thank
you my name is John burfonski I am the
chief of police in Bedford and
representing the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police more
than 150 Chiefs throughout the grand
estate and under President of the Chiefs
Association this year the Chiefs
Association is staunchly in support of
this uh Common Sense bail Reform Bill
that would require a decision by a judge
instead of a bail commissioner for the
most serious violent crimes that occur
and are committed in the state of New
Hampshire
the recent data shows that unfortunately
2022 was the most deadly year for
homicides in the state of New Hampshire
since 2002 so if we are to remain one of
the safest states in the state in the
United States then we need to make some
common sense bail reform that speaks to
the issues that the sponsor just brought
up there is not a week that goes by
ladies and gentlemen that there's not a
case that comes up in which an
individual who was repeatedly arrested
and released and then goes on to commit
another serious crime if you query the
online digital version of the union
leader today you'll see a case again in
Manchester of an individual who was
arrested after repeated release from
arrest and released on his own
recognizance on a Saturday on a Tuesday
and on the Saturday he conducts a
robbery completes the robbery and then
leads the police on a chase and crashes
his car which obviously imperils the
city of Manchester the residents as well
as the police officers involved this is
a common sense
fine-tuned strategical change to the
current bail law here in the state of
New Hampshire this is not going to
result in mass incarceration that's
hyperbole used by people that fear
Monger frankly the effects of this
particular build is not no evidence to
suggest thankfully because we don't have
a significant violent crime problem in
the state of New Hampshire that this
would result in mass incarceration this
simply places the initial decision for
bail not in the hands of a bail
commissioner at two o'clock in the
morning in a police station with scanty
information about the background the
history and the nuances involving the
particular case and moves it before a
judge in Superior Court that allows the
defendant as well as the prosecuting
attorney to bring forth the information
necessary to allow an independent
neutral judge to make the appropriate
decision with respect to bail
that's the place where those decisions
should be made and of course in this
particular
statute as proposed it would require the
judge to use clear and convincing
evidence which is a high standard just
below proof Beyond a reasonable cause
reasonable Reasonable Doubt rather that
an individual would continue would be a
danger to the community so we strongly
strongly support in the interest of the
victims of crime those people who can't
speak for themselves anymore because
they're not here with us had this
particular law been changed and these
one of the things that has always
confused me a bit and I know it's
confused other people when it comes to
uh to bills like this
um is the fact that our current bail law
um actually
does seem to allow people uh who are
dangerous to be held and one of the
things that we've heard in other other
hearings
is that the issue is less a problem with
our current bail law than it is with
consistency of training the availability
of prosecutors to make decisions on
second bail requests
improper or inadequate training of bail
Commissioners so when we talk about the
balance I'm I'm curious about your
opinion on this on the one hand we have
the constitutional rights of people who
are accused of crimes and we have what
appears to be a breakdown in the system
um how do
is this type of change in the law in
your opinion the best way to balance
this
thank you for the question uh
representative
um I I sit here before you with a lot of
gray hair after 45 years of continuous
law enforcement service
and one thing that I'll tell you with
respect to just about any Bill and any
law that comes before me the association
or you is to look at it in with a
perspective of Common Sense
what would your constituent on their
front porch in the afternoon ask the
question should a person who just shot
up the streets of Manchester be released
on a on a cashless bail
by a bail commissioner I would venture
to say that your constituent would tell
you no the common sense notion here is
that people that pose a danger to the
community that commit the most violent
crimes that the state of New Hampshire
has on its books should not be
immediately released until there's a
more deliberate review of what is
involved in a particular case let the
Judge review let the balance of time the
defense bring forth whatever information
that they may conjure up to encourage
the judge to release the individual or
to make a finding that the person is not
a danger to the community
I urge you to use common sense
representative Newman
just to follow on up on that with the
common sense the thing that gets to me
is
have there been any judges that have
released people on uh personal
recognizance bail and then it's been
followed up by
by a crime being committed and then is
is that why we're waiting for the judges
to make the decision as opposed to the
bail commissions that both have to
follow the same standards
there had been so the answers to your
question yes there have been instances
where judges have released I believe
that the the case that the sponsor
brought up with respect to um his
constituent that was killed involved a
judge's decision to release someone on
on a cashless or uh release on their own
recognizance so yes
um but we also have countless numbers of
of instances right involving bail
Commissioners that release people if the
judge makes a wrongful decision that
results in the death of an individual
right
um
there there should be some Reckoning uh
of the judge's decision what Reckoning
could take place
whether it's uh simply
um
bringing forth information to the judge
in camera with respect to the the
results I'm sure every single judge
the judges that I know both in the
federal and state side are fully aware
of the mistakes perhaps that they make
and I think that they'll say that they
made the decision based on the best
information or the law that they had
before them
this provides for clear and convincing
evidence and again the common sense test
would be
if a person just shot up the streets of
Manchester should that person be
released or if that person threatened to
stab someone and assaulted a police
officer should that person be released
follow-up
thank you and I wasn't meaning to demean
the Judgment of the judge but but the
bail Commissioners are held to the same
standard so they would have the same
Reckoning so I just don't see why this
law that puts all these bills
makes a difference well it makes a
difference uh representative because uh
it it takes the decision out of the
hands of the bail commissioner where
there have been a number many many cases
in which the bail Commissioners have
released people
um on their own recognition since
um as they say two o'clock in the
morning in a police station which is not
the best place to make that decision
humid
you just said that they do
and the bill bill commissioner says
um I really want to release that person
with the officer you say no because this
person is a danger to society okay don't
we already have those laws in place
to stop that person from getting bail
the bail commissioner decision excuse me
I'm sorry today
I'm sorry that uh I'm sorry for
interrupting the bail commissioner's
decision is final I oftentimes and I do
make sure that my patrol supervisors
when there's a violent crime involved in
Bedford that if they learned that the BC
or the bail commissioner is going to
release that individual on their own
recognizance that they inquire with uh
and plea and make the case with the bail
commission but the bail commissioner's
decision is final at that moment
yeah
so what is your recourse at that point
if the bail commissioner says um you
know
I'm sorry we're going to give them that
bail
what requests do you have as an officer
at that point we have none that person
by another chief of police that said
there was that you do you do have a
recourse and that you would contact I
think it was a judge or someone you
would contact under those conditions
no I'm not aware of that and I would uh
dispute that that would be a factual
rendition once the bail commissioner
makes that determination we can plead
the case before the bail commissioner
but unless there is a procedural error
for example uh perhaps if the individual
is being held on a warrant that uh
requires no bail in other words if it's
an electronic bench warrant that
requires that individual to be
incarcerated and the bail commissioner
is going to release them right then
perhaps that may be an instance that
would fall in the contextual scenario
that that Chief might be talking about
but if if it's not a
a warrant that requires incarceration
so
Chief as you're probably aware we have
several of these different forms of
these these bills that we'll be hearing
and I one of the questions that our
chairman asked and he's not here and I I
think I would just like to kind of make
sure that I heard the question right if
I may he had asked that
if a person
the person does a crime in Manchester
and they get it on bail and then they
get in a car and they drive up to say
Conway and they were to be arrested
again that same night is there any kind
of a system that would let a bill
commissioner know that that person
has just been released on bail
uh no not uh not within that scenario uh
if the individuals
um arrested and then uh released and
then within a short period of time is
rearrested again on another independent
charge uh it would take some time for
that arrest to appear in the ncic uh
Interstate identification index so when
that Conway police officer runs the
person's arrest record
um or criminal history it would show up
um it depends on whether or not the
police department that arrested them has
an automatic fingerprint identification
system which puts the data directly into
ncic digitally immediately or whether
it's followed up later on after some
period of time so if there's there is a
lag
oh maybe that's the bill we need guys
um are there any further questions
thank you very much for your testimony
representative your last name has um
created a conversation between my
haha
thank you
I'm representative Heidi Hamer
Manchester Ward 10. I'm a lifelong
resident of Manchester's west side
Manchester needs Our Help House Bill 653
would be a good start to improve the
safety of the public
this is about violent crimes this is
about repeat offenders
a person who violates the terms and
conditions of bail by reoffending
numerous times should be held without
bail pending arraignment
rear fenders need to be held accountable
this bill is making sure that a person
who has already committed crimes and who
reoffends over and over again be held
until their cases have been heard
this legislation will make our community
safer this legislation will help our
police departments and this legislation
she obedient eye-opener for other
offenders
so please help our police our residents
our business owners by supporting House
Bill 653
I also
following the chief of Bedford he talked
about this robbery suspect on February
4th 5 a.m Manchester police responded to
Speedway at 311 Queen City Ave for a
reported robbery
the clerk told the man walked in the
store had a gun handed a bag demanded
cash got his money he walked out of the
store got into a white sedan and drove
away
later on a couple hours well an hour
later Manchester police spotted the
vehicle traveling in the Union in
Somerville Street's area they attempted
to pull him over he finally crashed they
foot pursuit and he was taken into
custody
his 51 year old
male from Manchester
through the course of the investigation
police learned that he was driving
a stolen car
and he had just been arrested last week
after failing to show up to court on
multiple charges from 2022.
those charges included robbery burglary
armed robbery theft of a motor vehicle
felony theft by deception felony
receiving stolen property falsifying
physical evidence and credit card fraud
all of which he was out on bail for
so he was had a bail hearing on February
1st in Hillsboro Superior Court North
and was again released on PR bail
for Saturday's incident he now faces
charges of robbery Reckless conduct
falsifying evidence receiving stolen
property resisting arrest and disobeying
this has to stop
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee my name is David Rochford I
represent Grafton one I'm from Littleton
and within my district I have four
Chiefs of police and I was able to
connect with three of them and and and
they all are in favor of 653. in fact
this morning I got an email from the
chief from Lisbon and he said if this
should pass it would make New Hampshire
a safer place there's no doubt in my
mind
so
I want to be respectful of the time but
I want to share with you
a story of my own we're we're fortunate
in this state as we've heard already
this is a a very safe State uh our
quality life is excellent and
fortunately most of us will never be on
the receiving end of a crime
in 2014 I bought a commercial piece of
property in Littleton it was a blighted
piece of property I made a significant
investment where I relocated my Pharmacy
I'm a pharmacist by profession and we
built a state-of-the-art
specialty pharmacy in Littleton also on
that spot was a laundromat so I also
became the owner of a reluctant owner of
a laundromat so uh
um fortunately I still have that with
the salary we're getting today but uh so
in 2014 I made an investment in made a
huge Improvement to that end of town
and it was a it's a wonderful place to
to live and to work and up until
February of last year I owned the
pharmacy I sold that but I still own the
laundromat in the summer of 2019 it was
early mid-morning we looked out our
window of the pharmacy and we noticed a
car a suspicious looking car out in our
parking lot
and we washed it for a few minutes and
we realized what was going on there this
gentleman was selling drugs out of his
car he would stay there and a car would
pull up we'd watch the transaction uh
there was no there was no effort to to
disguise that a few minutes later
another car would show up and it would
keep going on I want to remind you that
or point out the fact that our Pharmacy
our business is directly across the
street 150 feet away from the Littleton
Elementary School Lakeway Elementary
School
so this process went on for about an
hour we called the police the police
showed up they said you did the right
thing
they took the guy off
two hours later he was back selling
drugs
doing the same stuff that he was doing
two hours before
and
we were flabbergasted by it and as you
can probably understand that it caused a
lot of consternation and concern for our
employees who are working in a pharmacy
having drug Seekers coming to our
parking lot to transact their business
so we called the police again and you
know I laid into the police a little bit
about what what's going on
and they apologized they said we're
sorry we're really sorry there's nothing
that we can do in the way the system is
we can't hold these people
so this went on for two weeks and they
they did say please call the police if
it happens two weeks this went on all
day a constant stream of drug activity
in our parking lot one morning we woke
up to a guy overdosed in his car
when we showed up for work
so we called the police again and the
guy actually woke up before the
ambulance got there and tore off down
the street and what kind of state that
was I I can't even imagine
but the point that I'm trying to make if
you haven't got it now we've got a
problem here I mean the the the the
position we're in was certainly to
protect rights and I
very much believe in that but what about
my rights what about my rights to to
provide for my family what about the
rights of my employees to provide for
their families in fact during that time
I had an employee quit because she said
she didn't feel safe because
three minutes all right pretty much stop
it there so I I urge you to take action
I urge to support 653 in any other types
of bail reform that you can you can
consider so thank you
Victoria I do see that you have here um
that you have written testimony so if
you handed out your testimony we would
just ask that you summarize it but if
you haven't handed out and it's just for
you to read it that's that's completely
different
usually people can hear me without it
but I I respect
thank you for having me here today my
name is Victoria Sullivan and I am from
Manchester New Hampshire
almost immediately after Senate Bill 556
was passed in 2018. there were calls to
revise the law five years later the law
has proven to be more damaging to have
more damaging consequences to the
quality of life issues of my city of
Manchester than any other law this
legislature has passed at least in
recent history this law is certainly not
the only issue the Manchester faces poor
leadership has led to significant growth
in homeless encampments those
encampments provide hiding places for
Very Bad actors and provides them a
cover to go to commit additional crimes
that's part of the reason why you're
hearing about some so much of it
happening in Manchester
I had the honor of serving with some of
you my voting record supports the fact
that I am a liberty-minded person I
believe in bail reform but I also
believe in consequences for actions
however this law created a catch and
release program which has resulted in
repeat offenders going on to commit
violent acts let me be clear no person
should be held simply because they are
too impoverished to pay the bill all
people are innocent until proven guilty
however there is a clear pattern of
systemic abuse of this bail Reform Bill
which is endangering our citizenry this
has been a frustration for police
departments around the state who work to
get dangerous people off the streets
only to have them back there within
hours last year it came before this
committee and I ask that you passed that
bill that was before you one similar to
this bill that's here today I warned a
very the very serious impact that this
was having on the city of Manchester I
know you did your part but I need you to
fight for this on the house floor on the
morning of Friday September 3rd Daniel
Whitmore 75 year old army veteran was
walking through the trails on
Manchester's South End when he was
viciously attacked and stabbed to death
by Raymond Moore Moore had been arrested
in both Manchester and Nashua the weeks
before the brutal attack both times he
was released on PR bill this murder was
in the trails that the children used
daily the trails that lead to the soccer
and Little League fields my own son had
been in those Trails 24 hours before
with his friend riding his bike
are we supposed to lock up our children
because people who do not believe in the
rule of law are too weak to lock up
dangerous repeat offenders because that
is what we're talking about here
dangerous repeat offenders
please do not let Mr whitmore's death be
in vain I don't want to be sitting here
before you night this time next year
pleading with you to change the law
because more people have died as a
result of it your fellow Representatives
that live outside of the cities of New
Hampshire outside of the Cities may not
understand the gravity of the situation
please share Mr whitmore's story with
them when you whip the votes for this
bill to see if you have enough votes if
you're coming up short call me reach out
to me I'll help you make those phone
calls so that I can explain what's
happening in my city and get people to
understand the gravity of this situation
I ask for an ought to pass
recommendation on hb653 and to fight
like heckford on the house floor as well
she didn't put that I was calling her
Miss
Mrs
okay thank you for that Victoria because
you didn't put that on there and I'm
here defending myself and you just threw
me under the bus thanks thanks
appreciate that just kidding just
kidding but just kidding just having fun
Madam chair thank you
um although I object to the
um impossible burden you've placed on a
law professor to only talk for three
minutes
um one I want to say something that's
bothered me for a long time
the term Catch and Release refers to
fish it doesn't refer to human beings
and I resent the fact that this is bail
reform is called Catch and Release
that's not what it is it's a very
sophisticated complicated effort to
balance Public Safety and uh and the
rights of individuals so let's talk
about uh how uh representative Barry
misled you
the problem that came that uh that
caused uh Mr whittlemore's death was not
the failure of the bail statute the
problem was the failure of several
prosecutors to do their job what
happened is Mr Whittemore was arrested
for an attempted first degree assault he
had been surrounded by a group of
homeless people he pulled out a knife
and was waving it around like that it
wasn't an individual threat to a
particular person the police were called
he was arrested and he was charged with
attempted first degree assault he then
saw a judge he was held by the Bell
commissioner he then saw a judge that's
in accord with uh with the statute as it
currently exists they had a hearing the
prosecutor said I want him preventively
detained or if you grant PR bail I want
some conditions not a overwhelming plea
to have him held uh the defense attorney
made their uh made their pitch and the
judge said
I'm not going to hold this guy I'm going
to have PR bail with conditions because
this is a very tribal case
I've I've gotten access to the
transcript of that hearing I've read the
hearing that's what the judge said
that's why he got PR bail because it is
not uh it is something less than a a
vicious threat of killing people
that is in early July in early August uh
uh Mr Moore is uh arrested and charged
with failure to leave McDonald's a
criminal trespass
there's no uh there's no hearing at that
point in early September or late August
later August he's then arrested for
resisting arrest
uh on two uh two times in the same
incident one of the resisting arrests
was he failed he was resisting putting
his feet in the police cruiser so I to
characterize that as a violent crime I
think is is a bit of a stretch
he then goes in front of a judge in
Nashua district court
now here's the key part the prosecutor
there
asked for PR bail personal recognizance
bail made I've read the transcript of
that hearing made no request
made no mention whatsoever of the fact
that Mr Moore was out on PR bail on an
attempted first degree assault no
mention whatsoever and it's because of
that failure on the prosecutor's part
that he was released
second thing that didn't happen that
caused the death of Mr Whittemore is the
prosecutor in the superior court case
back in early July
he never filed find if if he ever found
out about these subsequent misdemeanors
that he was charged with he never filed
a motion to revoke Baal in Superior
Court the bail that Mr Moore was on so
Mr Whittemore would be alive but for the
abject failure of the prosecutors to do
their job if they had done their job he
would have been held under the current
bail statute
so I appreciate deeply what a compelling
story Mr whittemore's Case is but it's a
compelling story not about the failure
of the bail statute it's a compelling
story about the failure of prosecutors
to do their job
um this bill is a is a mix of two bills
from last session
two bills uh uh from last session one
representative Barry's original bill
that made it through the house but
failed in the Senate
and Senator Bradley's bill that made it
through the through the Senate and
failed in the house it then went to uh
uh it then went to a committee of
conference in the Senate where
representative Berry was there and they
were mushed together and it fell apart
so each component of this bill has
failed in one chamber of the legislature
um
I will uh last thing I'll say uh the 700
arrest
uh for people who are already out on
bail
to use a formal legal term where the
heck are the prosecutors if people are
committing are being arrested for a
crime being arrested being let out on PR
bail and committing another crime the
current bail statute as it exists allows
the prosecutor to file a motion to
revoke bail it appears they're not doing
that
will you answer will you answer a
question
any question I have and I I agree with
what you said
the
he also said that we that we're we're
looking at the jails are going to fill
up and I that's not my point my point is
does this bill
is there a potential for this bill to
capture people that that commit a crime
that doesn't have any jail
punishment and then
I'll be charged with a crime and then be
charged with a crime that also is not
one that has any uh thing for jail
to be caught up in this especially on
the off hours on the weekend and when
the bail commission is nowhere at least
there to give them the due process
is it possible that a lot more people
who get caught up in that kind of thing
and be harmed by this bill as opposed to
the obvious horrendous things that we've
heard that were a result of the kind of
circumstances you just described yes
that's very possible I at a another bail
hearing that many of you were at I
produced a study that indicated that uh
of the 508 cases we looked at so far
we're continuing with that 38 percent of
them
the charges were eventually dismissed
and some of those people were held uh
after several months
um and uh yes you can be arrested for a
Class B misdemeanor
and then and bailed on that and arrested
another Class B misdemeanor and
preventively detained under
and that preventively detained according
to this bill would be mandatory even
though they were the two charges and
neither one of them that had a jail
possibility well I think under this bill
they could set up high bail they could
set some kind of bail but
um more often than not the judge would
preventively detain them
foreign
are you okay to ask are you okay for
another question oh absolutely
representative Murray
thank you madam chair I had um one
request and one question
um the request is just that if you could
send the committee
um that kind of rundown you gave us of
the different points in which
prosecutors failed to properly deal with
uh Mr Moore I will do that thank you um
just for the members who aren't here
and then my question was just uh
representative Berry and introducing the
bill mentioned that there have been 700
arrests in Manchester alone for people
who are already let out on bail I don't
know you've talked about you know your
studies with the 507 cases that you've
been looking at um I was just wondering
if you've heard that statistic or if you
have any idea I read it I I heard it uh
from Chief holdenberg at a hearing in
the Senate and I read it in New
Hampshire Journal so I'm aware of that
uh the the suggestion that Chief
holdenberg made when he testified in the
Senate uh is that uh all of a sudden
we're arresting more people who are out
on bail last year
um you will hear from Mr Knack that the
crime rate in Manchester for the most
serious crimes has gone down 14 percent
in a since Bell reform
it's not that paler form caused the
crime rate to go down but it's clear
that bail reform did not cause the crime
rate to go up so that's context number
one context number two is if in 2022
they're now arresting 700 people who are
out on bail but the crime rate has been
going down the cause of those 700 people
being out on bail four years after bail
or reform was passed is not bail reform
it's something else the obvious
conclusion is the end of the pandemic or
the the
diminishing of pandemic restrictions in
2022 caused an uptick in those kind of
crimes has nothing to do with the bail
reform statute second fact is uh we
don't know whether those are as
representative Newman uh question uh
hinted at we don't know of those 700
whether they're Class B misdemeanors
that they're out on bail on where you
can go to jail whether they're Class A
misdemeanors how many of them are
serious crimes how many are are not
serious crimes and then finally
where are the prosecutors
um you know where are the prosecutors if
people are being arrested let out on PR
bail arrested again why aren't
prosecutors being in motions to revoke
bail
thank you for taking my question very
late uh in the afternoon one of the
things that representative Barry brought
up was the purpose of this bill is
basically to rebalance the rights of
defendants pre-trial with the rights of
the community
if if this isn't the way to do it
um and I know this may not be a fair
question this late in the day but but
what would you suggest as a way to
achieve a better balance than what the
current law is is now providing
I have I have always testified that last
year when we were we had these long
hearings in this committee about Dale
um and in Prior years I was a member of
two bail commissions that that followed
the the the the passage of of uh bail
reform in 2019 there's a 2019 bail
commission that I was a member of to try
and rejigger that bounce and we made
some challenges there's a 2020 bail
commission where we did the same thing
and we made some more changes I mean uh
full support of instead of you know
coming in with legislation that captures
what one side of this complicated
sophisticated debate is about
let's retain all these bail bills and
let's get together everyone who has all
the stakeholders this summer and spend
some time talking through the way to
adjust uh this bill if it needs
adjustment by you know by the end of by
the middle of the summer I will probably
our study will probably have not 508 but
over 2 000 uh data points cases and and
that's the kind of thing we need to do
we need to base it on data and we need
to base it on conversations with all the
stakeholders
representative Murray thank you madam
chair
um I just with what you're mentioning
with data are you saying that if we
waited till later this year you would
have more data on like crimes from the
past year or uh what is that I I believe
that a prior hearing last week in
Representatives Hall I or maybe in in
this room I forgot which I passed out a
study that had 500 we'd looked at 508
cases and we were able to tell how many
how many times uh when somebody was out
on bail the uh they were arrested for
another crime and it was a dramatically
small number
um and we were also able to tell how
many people were had case their cases
dismissed after being arrested
um
that's only 500 by the by the middle of
the summer we'll have I think 2 000
cases which will be more statistically
significant
um it will and we're concerned with
individual rights but let's make
decisions with all the stakeholders at
the table and which are down over 33
percent since bail reform
um so again the notion that somehow
belliform has made us less safe is not
supported by data again you also heard
from Professor Sher the um the failure
in the case in Manchester of prosecutors
uh both in Manchester and Nashua to use
the multiple tools at their disposal
again we heard rhetoric around these 700
arrests in Manchester but what we didn't
hear like we didn't hear with regard to
the horrific Manchester murder was
specific examples of how in those 700
cases bail reform failed the bail reform
law failed when did they not use their
power to challenge release orders when
did they not use their power to seek
revoking bail for failure to comply with
obligations
and we heard the chief testified that he
wasn't aware of any provisions in
current law that enable prosecutors or
the state to challenge release orders
and so I just want to point out in uh
under current law in 597
6 e section two it says the state may
file in Superior Court of motion for
revocation of the order or Amendment of
the conditions of the release set by
municipal or district court or by
Justice or by a bail commissioner and
that motion shall be determined prop
promptly and so there is clear under
current law authority to challenge
release orders that the government
disagrees with it's black and white and
they're just not doing that
um
again we also have heard often often
over and over that we need to pass bail
reform because it's what we need to make
our community safer and again that is
the rhetoric if we actually look at the
data the data is clear there have been
multiple studies that have looked at the
impact of holding people pre-trial with
just blanket holds without
individualized determination on whether
they're a danger or Flight Risk which
our current law allows the most recent
study again that looked at 1.5 million
cases in Kentucky between 2009 and 2018
found that pre-trial detention for any
times associated with a higher
likelihood of arrest or for a new crime
before case disposition again because
that's triggering all the collateral
harms that come when you're actually
jailing someone pre-trial unnecessarily
and finally I heard my time is up if the
concern is really about getting people
before a judge there's another bill HP
46 before this committee that will
ensure that everyone is brought it will
replace bail Commissioners with
magistrate judges so if the concern is
getting people before a judge and making
sure judges make these decisions there's
a bill that ensures that everyone gets
before a judge not just for these 13
offenses but for all fences but they're
done in a way where it doesn't undermine
take away their Liberty unnecessarily
Best of Both Worlds happy to answer any
questions
s
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Richard Sam perrel
I'm the acting executive director of the
New Hampshire judicial Council
um the way I understand uh this bill is
that it seeks to address two categories
of situations one uh the post arrest
attention of individuals who have
committed certain offenses but don't
have prior arrests immediately they're
not on bail and those who
um uh
regardless of the offense charged or out
on bail currently those are both
situations that the person would need to
have counsel at the hearings and while
the judicial Council takes no position
on the policy underlying uh this bill we
do have some concerns about the
resources that we would be asked to seek
out and provide if there were additional
bail hearings required here as you can
see from the fiscal node our estimation
is that there would be about 2400
additional bail hearings per year that
would be approximately 45 46 a week the
current situation is that we just simply
are struggling every day to find lawyers
to represent people in the hearings that
we already have and there is some
concern that if there is that many
additional hearings we're not going to
be able to locate lawyers have them
appear in court on the short notice of a
36 hour or 24-hour hearing and to be
able to compensate them in a way that's
going to make them come to court the
difficulty we have currently is that the
public defender is already sort of
overloaded they would handle a portion
of the cases but in terms of additional
lawyers those lawyers are often
reluctant to get involved in cases that
involve incarcerated individuals and
often not available on the drop of a hat
to appear in court
so
um again while we take no position on
the policy considerations underlying the
bill we do have some real concerns given
the timeline its effective date and
being able to locate enough lawyers to
provide those services
that are going to be demanded here by
this bill
uh the last thing I just want to say is
that there are several bills floating
around that are very similar I have yet
to testify on any of them and I chose to
do so today because the judicial Council
has been asked to provide fiscal notes
on some of these but not on others and
while I provided a fiscal note on this
one I really wanted to sort of come and
articulate for you what our actual
concern is in terms of providing the
resources that are being asked for
I'm happy to answer any questions if you
thank you seeing none thank you very
much
uh good evening David Rothstein I'm here
opposing the bill on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of criminal
defense lawyers I'm going to try for 90
seconds rather than three minutes three
quick points one the bill has enough
language in it has enough language to do
what everybody here is talking about
which is to try to enhance Public Safety
we're training more information more
resources are needed two paragraph three
really struck me because you've got
homicide leading off the bill and
there's nobody who's charged with
homicide who's going to get out on bail
with a bail commissioner with a judge or
ever as a practical matter but then
you've got stalking you've got simple
assault there are a lot of people
charged with these crimes that when you
look at them they don't do any jail time
there are some people charged with
simple assault to go to state prison
there are many they plead to a
misdemeanor they get no time so this
grouping is a very curious grouping
that's going to catch a lot of people in
the net that don't need to be there
number three the prohibition on PR very
quick example everyone is frustrated
when people reoffend get picked up again
some of those people should be detained
and maybe they should be detained more
often other people what you want to do
is you want to release them on PR you
want to give them a chance because maybe
they're mentally ill maybe there's a
substance use disorder I just had a
client today who was picked up again and
everyone agreed that when she gets into
a bed an inpatient treatment bed that
her jail sentence or jail detention
should convert to PR bail so she can be
in treatment instead of in jail this
type of Bill would not distinguish her
from other people who reoffend so again
it would cast too broad of a net you
have the tools you have the language
if I may yes what you just stated that
that there wouldn't be a a difference
between the this this patient my
understanding what you're saying is that
she
she's she's being hospitalized no she
she was out uh there are a number of
people I'm just talking more generically
there are people who are out on bail for
an offense they reoffend which again is
not what we want to have happen but
there are surrounding circumstances they
have a mental illness they were homeless
they have substance use disorder they
don't stab somebody
um they may be trespassed they may be
committed another drug offense they're
picked up they're put in jail so we
reach an agreement that their preventive
detention should convert to PR bail if
they're if they get into an inpatient
bed that people are working to get them
into under this type of Statute would
say you can't get PR bail you've
reoffended you've been rearrested you're
treated like anybody else who reoffends
and gets rearrested it's just I believe
an example of how you need to look at
individual circumstances some people in
a rearrest situation I'm a criminal
defense attorney I would represent them
I would try to argue that get out
they're going to be detained because
they've been rearrested for certain
types of offenses or because there's
certain types of people other people
should not be detained because they were
rearrested and I do believe that the
people closest to the situation if
they're doing their jobs they have the
potential to sort through those people
and determine
who should be let out under perhaps
enhanced conditions and who should be
detained
thank you
representative Muse
so I think what representative Berry has
done in in the statute is he's he's
tried to narrow down the circumstances
so you talked about how this Bill cast
too wide a net
given the language that we currently
have is there is there any way to to
shrink that net down to a more
acceptable level well I mean I think
first I think you'd have to determine
that that's what you want to do I I
think personally I mean we have not only
this bail statue but we have another
bail statute that allows as Professor
Sher referred to that allows a
prosecutor to file a motion to revoke
somebody's bail on that other offense we
have presumptions that kick in if
someone is a Flight Risk and you can see
on their record that they're a Flight
Risk there's a presumption that kicks in
that has to be overcome if someone
commits a certain type of crime that's
going to be taken into certainly into
consideration if someone reoffends
there's also a presumption that kicks in
that the person is going to have to
overcome it's going to be harder for
them to be released I think that's
logical and I think that is a shrinking
of circumstances
and I and I think there's a possibility
that particular people can and maybe
should more often be detained and maybe
you know maybe there is a an
informational issue with with the
Manchester Conway uh example that was
given earlier maybe it should be out
there faster so that if somebody does go
out and do something up north you know
somebody should know and and as a
citizen I I I I I I think that that
makes perfect sense you need you need
information you need to know if the
person before you is
um you know John Q public or John Q
criminal right and if you don't know
that you're not going to be able to make
good decisions so but there may be other
ways to Shore that up without changing
the language of the bail statute which I
do think allows a broad range of
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Richard head I'm
the government Affairs coordinator for
the judicial branch I wanted to clarify
one thing when Richard testified earlier
the other Richard testified on behalf of
the judicial Council just to make sure
everybody understands judicial council
is now part of the judicial branch it is
an executive branch agency they pay for
the public defender so sometimes just to
make sure everybody understood that
um I'm not going to repeat testimony
I've given previously on bail reform
bills much of the same things that I've
testified in the in the prior bills
applies to this bill
first part of the bill deals with the
list of crimes when judicial Council
estimated the fiscal impact of 2400 new
cases that's the section they were
talking about not section two of the
bill so and I want to focus a couple of
comments on section two of the bill
section two of the bill is the repeat
offender provision and it's in and I'm
just going to read through it but it's
on page two of the bill beginning on
line 23
um and it says a person charged with an
offense who is or was at the time of the
offense at the time the offense was
committed unreleased pending trial and
I'll stop there that's roughly where you
stopped to get that 700 that
representative Berry was talking about
but then it goes on so it expands the
group Beyond just those who are on
release pending trial for a felony or
misdemeanor under federal state law and
then add to that anyone who is on
release pending imposition or execution
of their sentence on appeal of their
sentence or conviction or completion of
the sentence or a probation or parole
for any offense under federal or state
law so you get the 700 was just the
folks who were out on bail essentially
but then you add to that essentially
everybody who is between the time of
their first arrest to the time of the
completion of their sentence from that
first arrest re-arrested this provision
would would come into play so it's a
much larger number than 700 I won't
repeat the testimony of given previously
about what's happening in circuit court
but these would all be new hearings in
Circuit Court the other part I just
wanted to highlight is this requires the
police officer to know the status of the
person they've just arrested and whether
it falls within any of the any of these
statuses from bail through completion of
sentence for the prior crime they do not
have that information when they are
arresting so
at the time of rest
there's not a list that they can go
punch the guy's name into the girl's
name woman's name into and say this is
the status of that person I can't put
this person before a bail commissioner I
have to detain that information is just
not available to them at that time what
that means in in terms of policy I leave
that to you but I just wanted to flag
that for purposes just provide that
information to you with that I will
conclude my comments but I would be
happy to answer any questions
representative Pratt
would you care to comment on the failure
of prosecutors
I don't have any position on on the
previous testimony
thank you
represented
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um from listening to the testimony on
this bill and so many other bills
relating to the courts and bail and Etc
um to me it almost seems like the issue
is more about the um underemployment
that is currently in the system and the
stress that the court is under and that
is why maybe some of these cases are
slipping through and we're seeing issues
um with how the system is being run
right now
um do you think that that could be part
of the problem
um so thank you for the question there
are two aspects to the the current
stress in the system with regard to
judges we have all the judges that we're
supposed to have there's one that's been
nominated that will presumably fill in
the Circuit Court
in uh in terms of Staffing we are uh
down in terms of the number of Staff we
aren't able to fully staff we're down I
think around 10 percent but don't hold
me that
what we do know though is
notwithstanding any shortages
based on the weighted caseload study
that we did last year which measured the
need in terms of judicial resources the
judges but also in terms of Staffing
Resources even at full Staffing with our
current number over allocated in terms
of judges and staff we are substantially
down in terms of their capacity to move
the entire caseload that is before the
circuit out which is it in in terms of
Judges the numbers are roughly if you
convert a judge into a day
there are roughly 10 000 session days
currently available if you have the
total number of judges and the total
number of days they sit we need about 16
000 session days and of the 10 000 and
of those sixteen thousand about five
thousand of are based on statutory
deadlines I don't have the numbers for
staff off the top of my head and I
apologize for that but it is the reason
why the chief is asking in his budget
request for a substantial increase in
Staffing throughout the circuit courts
to be able to bring it up to a standard
where we can meet current caseload what
this does is then takes what we studied
in the in the weighted caseload study
which was an evaluation of the workload
at the time of that study and adds a new
system into it that way to caseload
study also did not take into account the
repeal of felonies first because at the
time of the study last year felonies
first was still in place those felonies
are now going to be before circuit court
beginning January 1st that were not
thank you very much thank you
is there anybody else wishing to testify
on House Bill 653 that is not turned in
a pink card
seeing none I will close the public
hearing